Õpetaja: Ee, jäime siis siiamaani. Vaata, kus meil see meetod on. Niimoodi Aa, ära tehtud, et õppisime siis seda, et meie See suhtluskanal on Need Data bloki muutujad
Õpetaja: siin. Me saame põhimõtteliselt defineerida mudelit. Aga siin taga on ka päris objektid Tühistring tühistring ja edaspidi Me saame teha näiteks mingisugune request. Näiteks paneme ee. Mingi
Õpetaja: kohe. Juba varsti. Saame Näiteks Request Või Respons ka. Võibolla.
Õpetaja: Ja ta saab ka olla nagu selles mõttes mitmekihiline. Siit tuleb nüüd mingi first name bla bla blabla Saate aru, et nagu ta võib ta olla mitmekihiline ka, et see, et meil on stringi asjad, ei tähenda, et see nii peab olema ainult.
Õpetaja: Aa. Ma ei mäleta. Kas ta treeningkommad siin lubab Või mitte, vist ei hakka vinguma, kui on treeningkomma,
Õpetaja: et võib juba olla copy paste imiseks nagu sees. Siin Niimoodi
Õpetaja: mitte dubleerimiseks Pigem Ee, Nägime seda, et see täida kõik välja, et siia tuleb. Kui ma teen Refresh I
Õpetaja: panen siia, Jätan ühe nendest väljadest tühjaks,
Õpetaja: Tuleb täida Kõik Väljad on nii,
Õpetaja: aga meil taaskis oli öeldud seda, et Aa Meil peab olema tehtud see eraldi komponendina
Õpetaja: Alert Danger, Mõte on see, et seda tahaks taaskasutada. Ja see hakkaks olema niimoodi, et see komponent.
Õpetaja: Vot see komponent saab, olema selline et ta on taaskasutatav,
Õpetaja: mis tähendab Seda, et kogu see visuaal näita, kui on mingi sisu. Ära näita, seda alerti. Kui ei ole mingit sisu, kõik see saab olema see Loogika selles komponendis endas sees olemas. Aga ainukene asi, mis me tahame, seda, et me ju ei kirjuta. Me ei tee seda komponenti niimoodi, Et Ta hakkab alati olema Täida kõik väljal.
Õpetaja: Saate sellest mõttest aru. See sisu. Me tahame, et saaks olla vajadusel erinev ja siin tuleb meil esimest korda. Me teeme nüüd niimoodi, et me teeme esialgu käsitsi.
Õpetaja: Siis me vaatame, kuidas ekstraktimisega seda teha. Ee, ja siis mõtleme edasi. Kuidas tulevikus me kavatseme neid komponente teha? Ee, meil on plaan teha selline asi kuskile Copy Based ümber,
Õpetaja: et see ei oleks. Me ei taha, et see oleks siin. Sest Kui ta on siin, siis niimoodi ta siin hakkabki olema ja peaks tegema seda loogikat, et näitaja näita Ja nii edasi. Me tahame, et see see alert ise oleks eraldi klots. Ja me saame seda uuesti kasutada.
Õpetaja: Mõte, selge, Taaskasutus. Eraldi kodifail. Noh, taaskas on öeldud. Ka Päriselus on ka niimoodi, et asju tehakse eraldi klotsid, eks? Teeme esialgu käsitsi selle asja.
Õpetaja: Ee, me tahame nüüd panna seda elama kuskile components alla. Mul on nüüd kogemata see kataloog ära kustunud. Teil ilmselt ka Sonny
Õpetaja: siia. Source I alla Teeme lihtsalt juurde ühe uue kausta nimega Komponents New Director I.
Õpetaja: Et lihtsalt, et siia kausta, hakkame toppima eraldi. Ee, seisvaid, vaateid, Kui neid tekib aja jooksul rohkem, Siis teeme ka mingi alamkatalooge. Hetkel on lihtsalt New Director I
Õpetaja: komponents.
Õpetaja: Enne. Sul on vaja kuidagi nüüd järgi tulla, onju?
Õpetaja: Igal juhul on vaja. Sa Alles tegid torti lahti. Aa, teeme hästi meie natukene koodi. Kui Henril on kõik juba silme ees, siis ma teen Kommit. I ja ta tuleb järgi. Olete nõus
Õpetaja: nüüd siia sisse? Siis teeme oma esimese komponendi. Ja Tema nimi hakkab olema Alert Danger. Parem Klõpsoga, mis ma siit valin?
Õpetaja: Poe komponent vaikimisi. Ta mäletab, et ma viimati. Vahetasin Option Capi. Las ta olla siis selle peal.
Õpetaja: Paneme alert Tanger.
Õpetaja: Kuigi võiks panna ka teha natuke taaski Väliselt. Näiteks ka võiks olla Alert Error
Õpetaja: saaks olla Alert Warning või info? Midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: See Tanger on? Kus see sõna Danger tuleb? Cs is on see värv, Tanger?
Õpetaja: Paneme selle Rtrapi ees.
Õpetaja: Kui keegi juba jõudis teha, siis kustutage faili ära.
Õpetaja: Option Cpi.
Õpetaja: Ad Ee, Mis me nüüd siin teeme? On, See et tõstame kogu selle ära siia Stylebloki asemele. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: Paneme plärake.
Õpetaja: Ee, kohe tegeleme selle ka, et ta ei vinguks praegult Ja Highlights paneb sealt ühe suvalise Tv siia sisse Praegult,
Õpetaja: et, ee, tal on siin vähemalt üks element sees. Siis ta niimoodi enam ei jonni.
Õpetaja: Nii Aa, nüüd ma tahan rääkida Aa järgmisest kontseptsioonist.
Õpetaja: Aa, teeme lihtsalt testi. Kõigepealt kirjutame. Ma teen Step by Step, Teeme siia, test. Üks, kaks, kolm, mida iganes. Lihtsalt mingi sisu. Vaata, et saab aru, et see On see sisu?
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab seda komponenti kasutada? On tähtis on see, et tal on nimi sellel komponendil, mis on defineeritud siin ära,
Õpetaja: kui Meie läheme nüüd sinna. Login View Sse. Läheme tagasi,
Õpetaja: kui mul on tekst liiga väike. Vahepeal on, Tuletage mulle meelde, ma scrollin ta suuremaks, Te näete natukene paremini oma ekraanidel.
Õpetaja: Nii sobib umbes nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma olen, et jäävad lihtsalt selle loo kin Ee ja ma tõstan selle Errori endale. Isegi Siia, Paremale poole. Teil ei ole seda vaja teha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina tahan teha Niimoodi
Õpetaja: Me teeme selle asja uuesti korra, Aa, Teen niimoodi siia juurde, Siia, samma sellesse, ülesse ajutiselt. Teen juurde niimoodi, et me kutsume välja. Siin
Õpetaja: me kirjutame siin ja ma korra, ma Teen kommit i ka ära, et meil oleks hea jälgida. Mõningaid muudatusi on võibolla väga hea hetk. Kus ee. Oli? Henri? Jah, Henri saab järgi tulla,
Õpetaja: on sul Intellisi lahti.
Õpetaja: Kes tahab praegu järgi tulla? Mis, mis need sammud on?
Õpetaja: Ja siis New New Branch, õpetaja Feb seitsmest,
Õpetaja: Kui vaja, siis Ee Riho Saab Hendrit aidata.
Õpetaja: No Kusjuures õpetada. Sa õpib ee. Ise väga hästi,
Õpetaja: sest et. Siis on nagu see, et Sa pead oma auditooriumit teadma. Sul on inimene, kes üldse seda asja ei oska. Siis Sa pead nagu mõtlema nagu, et, oot, kuidas ma talle Siis seda selgitan. Sa pead iseenda jaoks selle selgeks tegema. Sellisel tasemel, et sa tõesti saad piisavalt hästi aru, et kuidagi teisele selgitada, Seal on nagu see päris suur väärtus. On juba seal sees.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ootame selle järgi, Kuni Henri ütleb, et võib minna, aga ootame ta pardale ära.
Õpetaja: Võibolla, et seda aega korra täita. Vaata nagu siis midagi, mis te saate endale, aga pole kõigile vaja. Senikaua korra lähen Login View juurde. Ma küsi. Ütlen, et ta teeks õppematerjalid selles koodi kohta. Miks datablokk on täpselt siukse struktuuriga Syntaxi Mõttes
Õpetaja: Ee, hea võimalus küsida. Ma ei tea, ma seda. Avastasin ka, et kui me kutsume Skill I välja loo uus õppematerjal, kui ma ei vali seda entriga,
Õpetaja: Siis ta ei selle kohe, vaid ta jätab selle siia ette.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd, kui ma kirjutan siin peale tühikut mingisugust teksti, siis ta arvestab ka selle tekstiga, kuidas käivitab. Muidu ta ju alati küsib, et mis teemal sa soovid? Ee, õppematerjali Ee. Ma panen talle, et selgita
Õpetaja: seda valitud.
Õpetaja: Seda ma panen Eesti keel inglise keeles. Selected koodi osa.
Õpetaja: Miks datablokk ma kirjutan? Kutsun seda Data blokiks.
Õpetaja: On täpselt sellise ülesehitusega
Õpetaja: edu See ka et see on meetod.
Õpetaja: Ma pole kunagi seda küsinud, aga ma nagu lihtsalt nagu tahaks, et vaata, mis ta nagu räägib, ma Ütlen entrit.
Õpetaja: Vahepeal uurin, Kaugel on. Ee, Henri.
Õpetaja: Väga hea, Ee, nägite ta? Kas ta küsis mul seekord praegult et mis materjali ma soovin,
Õpetaja: ei küsinud, sellepärast, et ma valisin selle skill i Tabiga. Ja peale tühikut lihtsalt andsin talle mingit täiendavat infot juurde,
Õpetaja: Ta käsitleb seda kui Sisendit
Õpetaja: Näed ee, loov materjali teema kohta? Miks data on voe komponendis Meet meetod, funktsioon, Mitte lihtsalt objekt.
Õpetaja: Sest et miks ma seda tahan, on see, et me hakkame kasutama vahvaid templeid ja asju, mis iga kord ise teeb meile selle bloki ise ära. Aga Üks asi, mida Ma tahaks, on see, et kui te hakkate oma töid tegema ja te teete midagi käsitsi. Te ei hakka Copy Paste ima seda, kui Te tahate databloki teha? Te võite ise selle käsitsi kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Data on oma olemuselt meetod.
Õpetaja: Tal on nimi. Tal on see sulud.
Õpetaja: Nii meetodil on koodiblokk. Loogilised sulud ja ta tagastab andmemudeli objekti. Vaata, mida mingi niukse mõttega jätaks. Selle nagu ise, Nagu meelde.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: nüüd on, olemas, Vaatame hästi kiirelt. Mis ta siis selle kohta ütleb? Ka kui ta selle juba valmis tegi. Või ta vist. Ta teeb veel, ma ei tea, kas ta midagi teeb. Siin Tegi, Tegi tegi. Aa, näed. Link on ka siin. Väga hea. Ee, teeme lahti. Vaatame seda.
Õpetaja: Poe komponent saab sageli. Sellist koodi algab küsida, miks Data on funktsioon, mis tagastab objekti. Miks mitte lihtsalt objekt? On ju
Õpetaja: analoogia vormi koopia veesoritsionaal Kujuta, ette, et sul on blankett. Näiteks arstiankeet. Kui kõik patsiendid täidavad sama paberi, siis ühe inimese andmed kirjutatakse teiste peale, aga kui igaüks saab oma koopia, siis kõigil on eraldi Ee, eraldi sõltumatud. Niiöelda Blanketid Oe komponendid toimivad täpselt nii
Õpetaja: komponent. Iga kord, kui Voe, loeb selle komponendi Eksemplari instants peab igaüks saama oma andmete koopia mitte jagama. Ühte objekti ei saa olla üks objekt, vaid on meetod. Mis tekitab objekti.
Õpetaja: Ee, Rohkem Ei, loe. Ma ei taha seda Kodus saab jälle lugeda. Uurida. Vaata natukene veel edasi. Sellest põhiline nagu ongi see sama, mis ma nagu rääkisin, et. Noh, ta peab olema meetod, ja miks? Sest sellega luuakse eraldi koopia sellest konkreetsest objektist. Ee, lähme nüüd tagasi, siis selle
Õpetaja: Tõstan selle siia hulka ka pärast. Committein ära. Aa, lähme nüüd tagasi. Siis selle Error View juurde. Kuidas me saame nüüd seda asja kutsuda Ja ma tegin meelega et me näeksime muudatusi selles Log in view failis.
Õpetaja: Me lihtsalt tuleme siia Reale ja nüüd suurte tähtedega, hakkame kirjutama selle komponendi nime. Mis need tähed on?
Õpetaja: A ja E, onju. Kui paned Ae
Õpetaja: näita, mis ta teeb. Ta näeb, et Voe komponent alert, Ta teeb meile selle tag I juba ära. Ta teeb küll ainult alguse ära.
Õpetaja: Esimese poole Ta ei tea, kuidas Me tahame seda asja veel praegu teha, et kas ta on kahe tag iga tag iga. Kui ma panen siia kaldkriips, siis ta jääb ühe tag, iga, on Nii
Õpetaja: ma võtan Control Shift tagasi. Kui ma ütlen Control Shift Enter,
Õpetaja: siis ta teeb alguse lõpu. Ehk ta teeb ta kahe täägiliseks meid. Huvitab see variant, kus ta praegu on? Ainult ühe täägiga tal. Ei ole kahte täägi tal ei. Ole. Ulatus coopia
Õpetaja: kunagi Hiljem tutvume ka Niukeste komponentide, kus me soovime, et on algus ja lõpp. Ja kuidas nüüd see asi toimib, on, see, et Ee alla tuli. Esiteks, import. Vaadake, sellepärast ma tahtsin. Nagu me näeme neid ee, erisusi,
Õpetaja: et meie tegime sihukese tag I. Järgmine erisus on see, et tuli import ja Näete, komponents alla. Tuli niiöelda definitsioon, et siin selles komponendis nimega Login View. Me kasutame komponenti nimega Alert Error. See on kolm punkti ehk Siis üleval on see data Tag Ina, et palun
Õpetaja: Siia tuleb. Nüüd kõik see osa, mis on terroris templetis.
Õpetaja: Html peab siia tulema ja Kus selle saab? No see on ju see osa siin. Olete nõus? Test, üks, kaks, kolm,
Õpetaja: Seda osa. Me tahame, et nagu oleks siinsel asemel sa nagu võrduks selle samaga, et ma nagu paneks siia,
Õpetaja: saate aru. See sisu tuleb siia. Dünaamiliselt paneme kokku nii lihtsalt ta kirjutasin Suurte tähtede ja shiftiga. Muudmoodi suur täht ei saa teha
Õpetaja: Või kui sul on käpslokk peal, siis
Õpetaja: ma lihtsalt kirjutan suurte tähtede ka Ae
Õpetaja: Ja siis panin ee, noolu alla ja tähe või midagi taolist. Ma ei mäleta. Enam
Õpetaja: Ja kui paned selle Forward Slash I sinna lõppu, Siis ta ise teeb selle ära.
Õpetaja: Nii et see tähendab nüüd seda. Vaata, et põhimõtteliselt siia siis tuleb. Kui me juba vaatame ka, ma Lähen Näiteks vaatan. On siin test. Üks, kaks, kolm,
Õpetaja: Noh, üks võiks öelda. Vaata, et kui ma tulen ja vaatan siit sellest, et kus Mul siin on test. Üks, kaks, kolm, pole, onju. Sest et see tuleb sellest alamkomponendist,
Õpetaja: tuleb see test. Üks, kaks, kolm
Õpetaja: No siis praegult Ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: no ma ei tea, kas sul see sisu on. Kas sul see sisu on? Siis siis peaks tulema?
Õpetaja: Kus selles Alert Erroris endas. On sul mingi templitis sisu? Kui see sul on tühi, siis ei tule ööd ega mütsi. Jah,
Õpetaja: Henri saab aidata. Vaatab ka
Õpetaja: Viis minutit asju.
Õpetaja: Aga kus ma seda sisu saan vaadata?
Õpetaja: Nagu veebilehel
Õpetaja: Ta peaks automaatselt Refresh ima, vaid vajutada, aga
Õpetaja: talle ei tule see Sisu üks pluss kolm Sul on küll.
Õpetaja: Teeme nii.
Õpetaja: Kuidas pa palk tuleb? Teadmistega.
Õpetaja: Ei, maha, on
Õpetaja: nii? Anname nüüd kuume. Edasi Ausõna. Peame liikuma. Ee, et see sisu nüüd tuleb.
Õpetaja: Ja kui kellegil ei tule, siis vaadake ka seal. Me lihtsalt peame liikuma. Ee, et see eesmärk on see, et me tahamegi, et meil oleks erinevad klotsid, mida me saame kasutada. Meie plaan on hoopis see. Loomulikult, et me tahame, et Seal oleks selline kast ja tuleks ka siis niiöelda vastav sisu.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd ongi see mõte on see, et. Vaata, Aga me ei taha Kirjutada siia sellesse niiöelda hardcoditud kujul sisse, et Forever jääbki siia. Test üks, kaks, kolm. Vaid et meil on selline komponent,
Õpetaja: kus on mingisugune Visuaal. Mingi template osas on mingid Html elemendid ja mingi visuaal. Aga me tahame seda, et see sõnumi sisu
Õpetaja: tuleb sealt kohast,
Õpetaja: kust seda Komponenti käivitatakse ja välja kutsutakse Kui tuua. Ee, niiöelda paralleeli jaava maailmaga, siis see on meetod
Õpetaja: ja meil on vaja siia parameetrit. Info, mis Tuleb sisse. Tavaline settermeetod, näiteks. Noh, kus see settermeetod on? Veel. Võibolla ees. Siin.
Õpetaja: Ee, lähme võtame viimase vestluse siit ee lahti veel
Õpetaja: Nii, Siin on see meetod. Set Public String Mida iganes. Ma kirjutan siia juurde Lisa Ka väljakutsumise näide.
Õpetaja: Nii, meil on meetod set, model, mis võtab mingi sisu.
Õpetaja: See on mingi koodilõik, mis midagi tahab teha. Meil on vaja objekti.
Õpetaja: Käivita selle kaarobjektiga. Meetod, set, Bmw. See tähendab, seda, et see meetod siin käivitub programmiliselt. Siin kuskil ei ole. Bmw ju Ei, ole. On ju,
Õpetaja: et anna. Näed sellele sellele väljale, siin uus Sisu Bmw. See on selle meetodi mõte.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ongi see, et meil, on samamoodi. Kutsu välja komponent, aga anna talle kaasa Mingi info,
Õpetaja: Siin kutsutakse seda parameetriks. Poes kutsutakse seda selles kontekstis Propseks. Properties. Omadus.
Õpetaja: Mis me peame siis tegema, on see, et
Õpetaja: sellele template ile me Tahame, et siia tuleb. Vaata, ma panen küsimärgid. Vaata, me tahame, et siia hakkab tulema mingisugune sisu.
Õpetaja: Siis me peame kõigepealt lisama võimekuse siia Ee, komponenti Alertiusse. Vabandust selle terrorisse siia alla. Kui me kirjutame siia Props
Õpetaja: nii ja siia ei tule nüüd niimoodi. String Ja mingisugune väike Väärtus või tühistring.
Õpetaja: See väärtus ei ole kirjeldatud See, kui me võrdleme seda databloki asjaga, siis te saate aru et siin, on nagu siin On siukene erisus, et meil. Noh, datablokis on meil väike väärtused.
Õpetaja: Ma otsin ülesse. Näed, Props on siin.
Õpetaja: Datablokk on siin, siis Propsi, Me Ei, pane vaikiväärtuseid, nagu meil on siin mingi. Aa,
Õpetaja: siin ei ole mingit väike väärtust siin. Me paneme kirja lihtsalt tüübi.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, et siia Tuleb string Siia käib streng,
Õpetaja: sest see väärtus ei tule meil siit sellest failist. Terror Aler Terror. Vaid hoopis see, kes meid välja kutsub, Peab selle ise meile kaasa andma. Eesmärgiga Me saame seda siin näidata.
Õpetaja: Oi, vabandust, Ma ei mäleta, mida Props tähendab.
Õpetaja: Veits läks tuksi praegu Mitmuses Property D saab olla mitmeid veits. Läks tuksi praegult Kui mingi asi on mitmuses, siis me võime juba vabalt kirjutada, Mis sümbolid
Õpetaja: ja Sellepärast, et neid peab olema. Mitu siin ma annan, Siis Samamoodi nagu muutuja Nimed, nagu on datablokis ja nendel ei anna väärtust,
Õpetaja: No, kui Me tegelikult siin mõtlesime, et selle asja nimi on error. Message
Õpetaja: nii siis siin võiks olla Ka selle võtme Väärtus võiks olla error metsage
Õpetaja: Ja Siin me ütleme, et see on String mis hakkab sisse tulema Tabiga. Valige
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: praegu, kui vaadata lihtsalt seda
Õpetaja: praegu, kui vaadata lihtsalt siis. Aa, ee, tulemust.
Õpetaja: Hetkel on need
Õpetaja: ee jutu. Küsimärgid on, on ju Minu küsimus on, kuidas ma saan nüüd niimoodi, et sa küsi Parkide asemel. Ta võtaks hoopis selle sisu.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saan, nagu mis? Ma pean kirjutama siia.
Õpetaja: Miks topelt loogilised surud?
Õpetaja: Sest et praegu, kui Ma kirjutaks lihtsalt siia. Vaata message.
Õpetaja: Siis Ta mõtleb, et see on String Error Message See ülesse tuleb Error Message, onju? Aga mina tahan anda talle märku. Vaata, et ei, ei, ma ei taha siia String Err. Message vaid, et ma tahan, et sa nüüd võtaksid selle muutuja seest. Ma pean teda natukene aitama.
Õpetaja: Praegu midagi ei tule.
Õpetaja: Its Fine.
Õpetaja: Sest et Preter ei olegi mingit sisu.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb mängu, siis see asi, et sellega me lisasime võimekuse, et siia on võimalik midagi kaasa anda. Infona.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb siis see teine pool,
Õpetaja: et kui ma teen, Login View lahti. Ma teen Login View siia, vasakule poole.
Õpetaja: Siin, kus me kutsume välja seda Me paneme kõik muud asjad siit niimoodi veits kinni eest ära on? Ju. Paneme teie võimalikult vähe asju näha. Mina seda teen. Te ei pea seda tegema nii siin. Kus seda alerta Errorite me. Kui me alguses selle kirjutasime, siis temal ei olnud niukest Propsi nagu error message. Aga nüüd on
Õpetaja: kui nüüd panna siia tühik, et saaks midagi kirjutada,
Õpetaja: kui hakata praegu kirjutama. Error Message. Näete, mis ta pakub?
Õpetaja: Ta Pakub, et selles komponendis on Niukene Property ehk väike Sildikene nimega Error. Message
Õpetaja: nüüd, vahet pole, kas ma kirjutan selle Camel Case
Õpetaja: või Ma kirjutan selle Niiöelda kebab Case Kebabi Varras,
Õpetaja: kas Te Teate, mis kebab, Case ikka on, onju? Ja näed
Õpetaja: Java Name Conventions Võtke lahti. Ja vaadake sealt. Ta pakub Mõlemat varianti. Tehniliselt mõlemad töötavad, Aga on mõeldud, et siin kasutatakse seda. Kebab. Case I
Õpetaja: ee. Ma kohe selgitan ka, miks see natukene aitab meil eristada, et me mõtleme Siin Sada protsenti komponendi. Ee, nime. Nii tema nüüd ütleb, et. Kuule, hei, anna mulle mingi sisu. Kui ma juba praegu panen siia,
Õpetaja: siis Näeme, kuidas see komponent Noh, tuleb sellest sisust Siin me ütleme Kutsu Valer Error välja.
Õpetaja: Seal on Niukene Props nimega Error Message, mis on siin
Õpetaja: Ja me ütleme, et anna sinna sisu. Aa, ta annab selle sisu. Ja Tiiv joonistab lihtsalt selle sisu lihtsalt sinna praegult niisama tekstina välja.
Õpetaja: Vot nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd on siin. Et Miks, miks? See on siis nagu Error Message. Aga ma tahan nüüd anda sinna kaasa selle Error Message sisu.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on üks teistsugune olukord. Kui ma praegu ütlen, et värvid on tekst
Õpetaja: roheline, tähendab alati jutumärkide vahel põhimõtteliselt tähendab Stringi ta annab praegult error message.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma küsin, kuidas ma saan talle nagu märku anda. Vaata, ma mõtlen ikka nagu, ee, datablokis. Seda error message muutujat nii, nagu me tegime siin selles
Õpetaja: Aga Loogilised sulud on. Siis Kui me asume tagide vahel,
Õpetaja: kas me siin oleme? Tagide vahel?
Õpetaja: Ei ole. Näete, siin Oleme tagide vahel. Deev ja Div on ju? Näed, Deev,
Õpetaja: ma olen siin. Vahel, on nii?
Õpetaja: Oota,
Õpetaja: veemodel on kahepidine paind. Vaata aga praegu on see, et me, anname infot alla. Siin on nüüd järgmine asi. Vist kahjuks. Sorry, Kas see on viimane Enamvähem sündaks Asi, mis te peate teadma, Mis siin nagu nende muutujatega on. Kui me tag I sees tahame öelda mingisugusele atribuudile,
Õpetaja: et sina saad sisu Mitte niiöelda tekstist, vaid hoopis muutujast. Siis me selle atribuudi ette Paneme. Kooloni. See tuleb mujal ka veel mängu. Nüüd läheb ta lillaks,
Õpetaja: ehk Siis seda peab ta siin silmas. Kas see on arusaadav?
Õpetaja: Nüüd
Õpetaja: läheb see sisu. Ma panen selle sama Aa praegu, et lihtsalt nagu, et Hei, Kui laetakse sisu, on. Aa, kas ta joonistub ilusti? No nüüd ta joonistab mõlemasse, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd selles mõttes, et visuaalis, me tahaksime, Seda, et ta oleks hoopis Niukene ilus kast.
Õpetaja: Me saame tegelikult selle sama asja nüüd siit kattida. Ära Login just
Õpetaja: avada. Kuidas saab Alert, Ma panen selle kinni. Koera. Kuidas ma saan hästi lihtsalt Alert Errorisse minna. On see, et kui te hoiate kontrollid peal, ma ei ole seda veel õpetanud,
Õpetaja: siis see muutub hüperlingiks.
Õpetaja: Me niimoodi ka meetodites asjades saab niimoodi hüpata. Aga me saame survestada, et. Hei, kui ma vajutan siia peale Tulin siia.
Õpetaja: Kui mõnus on praegu hiir, millel on back, Vajutad ta? Back I. Vajuta forward it.
Õpetaja: Ah, võiks vist olla Niukene Hiir, kus kaks nuppu võiks ikka olla? Vähemalt onju Kuus oleks parem.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma nüüd tulen selle siia asemele, siis tal on nüüd Need klassid ka siin sees. Klass Alert Danger. See tähendab seda, et meil on nüüd Niukene. Ilus
Õpetaja: alert. Message
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt see Dv tuli see osa juurde. Me lihtsalt kattasime selle ära teisest kohast.
Õpetaja: Samal ajal kui teie seda nüüd teete, siis mina nagu lähen. Nüüd võtan lahti ee Väi, väiksed pildid.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan korra, Kas mul isegi õppematerjalides on Võibolla paremad pildid. Ma tegelt Ma alustan. Ee, Vaatan korra mis mul oli Seal,
Õpetaja: Ee, mõned mõned väiksed õppematerjalid. Mul on ka pandud kunagi varasemast ajast ette. Templeid. Paks Ahaa, sama näide.
Õpetaja: Login Viewst kutsutakse välja.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Alert Danger ehk meil alert niiöelda error on selles kontekstis laps.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me saame seda isegi valideerida? On see, et kui ma teen selle
Õpetaja: Aa, lehel. Alati parem klõps. Lähme korra. Teen nüüd suureks.
Õpetaja: Parem klõps inspekt ja võtan selle voe tööriista, mis kohe tuleb ka see nähtavale.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on tekkinud väikene niukene. Ma ei tea Noolekene ennem seda Ei olnud.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen siia peale, ma näen näiteks data blokis toimub User Name Password. Error.
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd teen selle asja lahti,
Õpetaja: siis näete, kuidas tõks madalamal näitab, et on mingi teine komponent Nimega Alert Error.
Õpetaja: Näete seda, on nii?
Õpetaja: Mina näiteks tulen sellesse. Error Message isse ja panen selle siin praegu.
Õpetaja: Siis see voolab siia alla sisse.
Õpetaja: Siin on sõltuvus. See on pärand.
Õpetaja: See on Child on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame nüüd seda õppematerjali, mis ma ühest varasemast korrast olen ära teinud Ja just täpselt selle sama asja,
Õpetaja: kui ma jätan selle siia kõrvale.
Õpetaja: Nüüd andmete mõttes. Kas saab mõelda, et Login Views on datablokis Data Muutuja Error,
Õpetaja: mis on pandud siis niiöelda Alert ee, error I väljakutsumisel. Niiöelda alla voolama propsei andmed voolavad ülevalt alla
Õpetaja: see vesi on andmed Need andmed algavad. See sisu on ju sees. On see Pbb?
Õpetaja: Tema kutsub välja oma alamkomponenti. Kus on Props Error Message drink. Noh, meil oli seal ka.
Õpetaja: Ja need andmed voolavad sinna alla. Me ei pidanud midagi progema. Me ei pidanud selles mõttes midagi progema,
Õpetaja: et nagu et seda saavutada. Seda, et ühed andmed lähevad teise vaatesse. Edasi. See Mõte on lihtsalt see, et meie saame teha mis iganes disaini, mis iganes elemente. Me saame luua mingisuguseid klotse, mida saab taaskasutada. Aga seal on mingisugune muutuv osa Informatsiooni mõttes. On mingi tabel
Õpetaja: ühe korra proged ära Siin on mingi age noh eesnimi Perekonnanimi vanus.
Õpetaja: Teed sellele tabelile disaini. Määrad ära mingid nupud, Asjad, Mida iganes kõik teed, ära ainukene asi, mida tema vajab, on see, et anna mulle andmed, mille pealt read teha?
Õpetaja: Kasutan seda tabelit siin kohas.
Õpetaja: Kasutan sarnast Tabeli, sama tabelit teises kohas
Õpetaja: kolmandas kohas. Võibolla kasutan ainult ühes kohas, aga vahet pole, kui ma hakkan nüüd ka koodi lugema siis vähemalt top level. Seal, kus Sa vaatad View D. Mul ei ole kilomeetrite viisi mingisugust Html I Ja Jumal teab, mida.
Õpetaja: See on kõige hullem kui on Html on Mingi tuhat rida koodi. Noh, sa ei saa mitte midagi aru Sealt see on nii. Sa oled sinna sisse See on väga suur erinevus, Kui sa tuled sinna nagu ja vaatad loed. Niimoodi. Ahah, kaks kolumnit vasakul, pool teisel pool on
Õpetaja: aa okei ja. Ja ja veelgi parem veelgi parem. Mis on, teeb selle asja paremaks. Kujutage ette, et meil nüüd Aa koosneb.
Õpetaja: Kogu see ee lehekülg koosneb erinevatest niiöelda komponentidest,
Õpetaja: nii Teen seda siin veits laiemaks praegu, et
Õpetaja: et Login View on See roheline osa, mis ta on nii
Õpetaja: Mul on. Kujutage ette, et see On mingid mingid tabelid Pildid, mida iganes need kõik on. Need on klotsideks ära tehtud. Nad asuvad kuskil erinevates kohtades. Ma korra panen selle Alert Error I kinni. Ma vaatan, et notebad on taustal kinni. Mida ta võib tekitada? Segadust
Õpetaja: ma tulen, vaatan. Siin on see näete ta Highlight Ib. Niimoodi Rohelise Käära ja näitab on, see
Õpetaja: teen. Selle lahti klikin. Siia peale lihtsalt. Vaata otot siin. On mul mingi komponent mingi Tabel, näiteks. Mul on vaja siin midagi juurde lisada. Üks veerg, näiteks või midagi. Mingi nupp või midagi, vahet? Pole.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul on vaja seal toimetada. Ma nüüd leian selle koha ülesse. Vaata, kui mugavaks on tehtud ka. Näed seda nuppu? Siin
Õpetaja: Open in editor. Ee, ta üritab nüüd teksti editoriga teha siis seda faili lahti.
Õpetaja: Ja mis asi on, kui mitte muu kui Editor?
Õpetaja: Aga kui sul on midagi nopad või mingi asi lahti, siis jumal teab, millega, ta ahte teeb. Ee, sellepärast ma panin meile ka not Bad I kõrvalt teda kinni, vajutan seda. Noh, hästi, natuke Peab kannatust olema.
Õpetaja: Võtab veidi. Aega. Kujutage ette mingi sadu ja sadu faile on.
Õpetaja: Võibolla pean ise klikkima.
Õpetaja: Aa
Õpetaja: põrsas, sellega sa hakkama ei saa. Huvitav, miks.
Õpetaja: Võibolla kellegi teise saab?
Õpetaja: Vanasti Ta tegi ilusti selle lahti. Ka
Õpetaja: teistega keegi töötab. On proovinud.
Õpetaja: Pan kõik kinni. Vaatan korra. Kas see kuidagi aitab? Klikk, klikk.
Õpetaja: Aa, mul on kaks seda akent lahti ka. Ma panen igaks juhuks ühe akna kinni.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma teen niimoodi, et mul oli kaks browser It lahti. Ma ei tea, kas see mõjutab või mitte, Mul pole. Õrna aimu,
Õpetaja: kus See oli sisselogimine Inspekt.
Õpetaja: Voe komponents.
Õpetaja: Login view.
Õpetaja: Võtsin siit selle lahti. Alert Danger. Vaid Ta on Open in editor.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: kahju Ee, vanasti töötas. Noh, okei, Faili nimel saab ikka kätte. Ja ühel või teisel viisil, kui seda pugida küll selle saaks jälle tööle. Vanasti töötas No probleem.
Õpetaja: Nii, take my Nii, aa. Nüüd Ma küsin teilt, et kas te kontseptsioonis saate aru,
Õpetaja: kuidas töötab Props ja mis eesmärki ta teenendab,
Õpetaja: Me soovime teha eraldi mingisugust visuaali, mingeid tabeleid või mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Ja me soovime seda. Taaskasutada või kas ka ainult ühe korra kasutada
Õpetaja: aga Me tahame seda niimoodi teha, vaata et need andmed, mis niiöelda on siis ee niiöelda vaja Seal Niiöelda siis, mille põhjal on vaja midagi valmis ehitada. Need tulevad kuskilt väljaspoolt. Sealt, kus seda komponenti välja kutsutakse,
Õpetaja: See on kõige õigem. Väljend välja kutsutakse. Te võite mõelda. Ka käivitatakse Te võite mõelda seda. Komponenti. Joonistatakse valmis nagu ekraanil. Vahel pole kuidas te mõtlete.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd esimene põhitööriist ja see on number üks. Tööriist üldse. Mis on selles tehnoloogias?
Õpetaja: Andmed voolavad ülevalt alla. Kas see hakkab nagu kuidagi nüüd kõnetama ka, Rohkem mille mõtlesin, nagu null või
Õpetaja: Mul oleks mingil hetkel see.
Õpetaja: See läks kaduma, et, ee.
Õpetaja: Ma teen selle kuidagi seotuks erinevatesse kohtadesse, et. Ee, vaata selle. Selle mõte on see. Ma proovin uuesti seda teha
Õpetaja: see mõte on see eelkõige. See mõte on see. Sa pead hästi natukene ette kujutama, et kogu see Asi on siin ee oluliselt keerukam. Mingi Ma tean, mingi input. Boxid on siia. Aa, label table,
Õpetaja: table. Ma korra teen lihtsalt mingi table, Pluss, mida iganes
Õpetaja: nii ma korra teen, selle asja niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Näed seda. Siin on mingi tabel, millest isegi veel ei saa aru, ma ruttu Mingi suvalise tabeli.
Õpetaja: Võtame selle sama.
Õpetaja: See ei ole kaasategemise koht.
Õpetaja: Aa, table, tark. Aa, table over. Aa, See ei ole üldse Tähtis Nii
Õpetaja: Vastab tõele, et praegult siin on mingisugune Ee alert. Siin on mingi input box. Siin on mingi mingi tabel.
Õpetaja: See asi elab mul eraldi klotsis nimega Hetkelror. Aga kujutame ette, et see on mingi. Ma ei tea, mingi tabeli komponent. Mis Iganes
Õpetaja: nende komponentide mõte on, seda, et Ma ainult ühe korra teen kogu selle asja valmis.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: ja nüüd kus iganes ma olen, panen selle kinni. Näe, Ma lähen nüüd tagasi sinna. Kui ma kustutan selle koha siit. Selle rea siit ära.
Õpetaja: Pole mitte midagi, mina ütlen. Ma soovin saada seda väikest inputkasti tabelit, Mul On olemas see disain ja kõik see elemendid. Asjad ma saan taaskasutada. Ma lihtsalt ütlen, et Palun
Õpetaja: vaata kõik kood mis on siin template osas. Näed, see siin.
Õpetaja: Näe, Ma võin võtta, kogu tulla, võtta kogu selle osa siit tei peal. Kõik osa
Õpetaja: see saaks olla mul ise Siin selles login Views. Vaatame, mitu rida on. Praegult Ee, template lõpeb Real Kolmkümmend kuus Olete nõus.
Õpetaja: Kui mina tulen, panen kogu selle disaini Kõik elemendid, kõik elavad ühes failis. Siis põmaki on minu templeid nüüd juba Kuuskümmend seitse rida, pikk
Õpetaja: kuuskümmend seitse rida, et näidata seda
Õpetaja: aga Eesmärk on see, et me. Ma ei saa, kui ma tuleksin siia peale, Mis toimub siin? Vaata. Noh, mis siin kõik nagu on, ma Peaks lugema seda koodid toda koodi ja kõik loed. Loed, loed, loed, loed, loed, loed, loed. Üritad aru, saada, aga nüüd on hoopis see mõte. Vaata, et. Aga ma ei taha seda koodi siia panna.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan, et mul on eraldi komponent. Väike klotsikene kus on kogu see asi
Õpetaja: näed. Ja mina saan nüüd Forever and Ever üle selle projekti öelda. Palun. Alert Terror Alert, Error.
Õpetaja: Ta tegi mulle See variant ei meeldi. Ma ise tegin valesti. Mulle meeldib niimoodi suurte tähtega. Mõlemad töötaksid idee järgi, aga niimoodi on kohe aru saada, et see on minu Komponent, mis? Mina olen loonud. Või poe komponent. Vahet pole
Õpetaja: korra, anna talle mingi sisu ka, muidu ta hakkab vinguma. Võibolla paneme Ddd.
Õpetaja: Näed, Nüüd on niimoodi, et kas siin on. Ee, kas siin selles on template? Vahest Aa ridu. Põhimõtteliselt ühest
Õpetaja: kolmekümne kolmeni on ja kõik need Read justkui tulevad siia asemele. Ma taaskasutan seda. Klotsi.
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole kolmkümmend rida, Aga tulemus on Täpselt, selline, mis seal on.
Õpetaja: Jah, ma Saan aru, ma. Ma töötasin. Mul oli see, mis on pandud suur komponent alla. Mul oli ta seal. Ee,
Õpetaja: uus nagu järgmise level selle. No siis tuleb lihtsalt tirida nagu õigesse kausta.
Õpetaja: Jah, ja see mõte on nagu see. Vaata, siin on praegult andmed. Ee, mingi kolme inimese andmed. See, mis tuleb, lihtsalt näitena Niiöelda, Margoto enda, Saate aru, See tuli siit, onju Html iga.
Õpetaja: Aga kujutage ette, et meil ongi mingisugune Tabeli komponent.
Õpetaja: Siis mis me siis nüüd tuleb? See jõe värk tuleb siia juurde. Vaata, et ega me ei hakka neid andmeid pärima, nagu Neid andmeid Me ei hakka pärima siin selles failis, Muidu, me ei saa seda ju taaskasutada.
Õpetaja: Me ei saa seda taaskasutada.
Õpetaja: Point on see, et vaata, et need andmed anname siia kaasa Prox I abil.
Õpetaja: Seal kohas, kus me välja kutsume. Seda komponenti,
Õpetaja: siis on päris taaskasutatud siia me selles. Kui siin oleks mingi tabel, siis siia. Ma ei programmeeriks kunagi seda. Vaata, tabeli kuvamine on puhtalt visuaal kasvõi komponent, see on Niiöelda, ee, mida tahad näidata? Vaata, Okei, Sa oled mingeid nuppe asju olla ja saad midagi edasi toimetada. See selleks vaata onju, aga point On see, et selles failis mingi. Ütleme, et see oleks mingi table komponent mingi Customers table.
Õpetaja: Kas sa peaks teile seal me kunagi andmeid ei väriks selles konkreetses failis. Mitte kunagi
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et siis, kui me pärime mingeid andmeid need lähevad mingi sisendiga, Nad lähevad mingi teenuse vastu Täna küsi ühte andmed. Homme Küsin teise andmeid või teises kohas. Või Mingi nupuvajutus. Siis ongi see. Vaata tema lihtsalt visuaalne komponent, et anna mulle lihtsalt objekt. Kus on massiiv?
Õpetaja: Kus on Customer? I andmed. Igal customer. Il on objektil. On first name last name ja vanus, näiteks onju?
Õpetaja: Selle viskad sinna sisse. Ta automaatselt ehitab selle tabeli valmis. Lase nüüd igal pool kutsuda seda miljon korda ka välja. Näete, ma võin seda sama asja tegelikult tehniliselt võtta. Siis samas failis.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma saan neid miljon korda ka välja kutsuda. Ma saaksin igasse ühte poole panna Erinevad andmed ka. Kui ma tahaks. Näiteks siin. Ma panen siia Fff üldse. Palun väga. Dd Ffff
Õpetaja: Mina, Sa, sa. Kasutad seda sama klotsi Uuesti Ja uuesti ja uuesti. Isegi kui sa ainult selle ühe korra kasutad. Isegi kui ainult ühe korra vaata, siis on sellel asjal ikkagi jumet Sellepärast, et. Kas ma tahan näha siin kolmkümmend rida koodi. Vaata meil koodi. Või see on peidetud ja lihtsalt öeldakse Customer Stable,
Õpetaja: ma tahan. Igal juhul näen seal samamoodi, nagu on see peameetod nii, nagu ma vaatan seda loo kinni. Sa tahad seda proovida lugeda nagu kui nagu raamatut.
Õpetaja: Nagu siin. Mul ei ole vaja teada, mis tähendab, kuidas on. Vaata onju, kuidas see loogika on üles ehitatud. Mind Ei, huvita seda mind. Ma näen, et siin seda kontrollitakse. See on samamoodi, Kui ma näeksin kuskil, et ee, on mul mingi kolumn ja siis seal on kirjeld customerstable. Siis ma näen. Tatana. Läheb sisse sinna mingi Customers objekt. Vaata, kõik
Õpetaja: Ma tean, et sellega, tehakse, mind ei huvita sellel Hetkel
Õpetaja: kogu see kood teibel hakkab pihta ja sealt tuleb mingi heeder ja teibelroug ja teibelda.
Õpetaja: Kui keegi tuleb arendust, taas tuleb, et kuule, Seal tabelis võiks üks verg veel olla. Vaata, tahame veel midagi näidata.
Õpetaja: Kui mul oleks need kolmkümmend seitse rida siin need kolmkümmend seitse rida oleks mujal ja mujal. Ja siis tuleb taaski, et Kuule, mingi seda ka. Vaata, on ju Kui nad oleks pilla palla niimoodi laiali, siis Ma peaks minema vähemalt mingi kolme faili ja minema otsima. Vaata ja tegema parandust, et üks veer juurde tekitada versus,
Õpetaja: kui mul on ainult Üks komponent. Ma otsin selle komponendi ülesse. Teen seal korda, et palun üks veerg veel siia juurde igal. Pool Kus on seda kasutatud, on Sama tulemus, siis ma ütlen, selge? Siin on ainult plussid ja miinuseid pole.
Õpetaja: Aga teil on vaja aru saada. Seda. Vaata, on see Propsi asi, et andmed
Õpetaja: ei tule lihtsalt selles samas koodifailist, Vaid need tulevad väljapoolt alati, Sest et muidu meil kaob ära kogu selle asja mõte, me Ei, saa taaskasutada. Kui selles samas kohas, kus seda tabelit kokku pannakse, on see päring Backendi. Siis sa sinna sisse kirjutatud sa saadki Ainult neid täpselt sellisel kujul. Ja need andmed on inimestel.
Õpetaja: Kui sa teed selle klotsi, mina annan sulle andmed, sina tee visuaal. Siis on Meil Contract.
Õpetaja: Meil on leping omavahel ja ma saan sind kasutada igatepidi samal lehel, erineval lehel. Vahet pole erineva sisuga Sama sisuga, kõik on Nagu Minu enda otsustamine, mida ma tahan teha. Aga ainult. Niimoodi me saame seda teha.
Õpetaja: Noh, aa, ma lasen Triinul välja printida homseks Aa Põhimõtteliselt kui vähegi võimalik. Ee, ühe asja.
Õpetaja: Ma leidsin selle juba kuskilt ülesse, kus oli piltide all restful.
Õpetaja: Mm, või oli kuskil mujal, oli idee.
Õpetaja: Üldine koolituse print.
Õpetaja: Sellise asja tahan teile välja printida. See on kahest lehest. Üks on Aa frontend. Teine on backend.
Õpetaja: Vaatame seda asja Koos Ee meil on siin nihukesed veerud. Kuidas
Õpetaja: Action suund Millal eesmärk? Vaatame Propsi, mida me oleme õppinud. Kose märk on ju üles
Õpetaja: Action I suund parent to Child.
Õpetaja: Näete, Ee, siin ema annab mingi kingituse üle oma väiksele Nagale, kes ripub õhus, hõljub väga spoki,
Õpetaja: et see suund on see, et me soovime infot anda alla.
Õpetaja: Kui me pärast vaatame tuvi, siis me näeme, et ta on vastupidine olukord. Need kaks Tööriista on põhitööriistad, mille abil me saame põhimõtteliselt korda saata. Väga väga palju automaagilised.
Õpetaja: Millal, kui on ühesuunaline andmete liikumine ülevalt alla
Õpetaja: ma teeks selle joonise ümber panust noole. Vaata hoopis niimoodi. Tekst ülevalt. Noole alla alla. Kohe on hea vaadata.
Õpetaja: Nii siis, kui on ühesuunaline andmete liikumine ülevalt alla, siis me kasutame Propsi
Õpetaja: Kasutada Propsi, Kuid Child vajab andmeid näiteks kuvamisest. Siin on näide ka juures Vaadake, siin on dropdown.
Õpetaja: Seda seda Dropdown I. Me tahame, et on praegu siin mingid Eesti linnad.
Õpetaja: Aa, teise riigi linnad. Mida iganes linnad linnad sõltuvad kontekstile sisu saab Muutuda ju idee järgi sisu saaks muutuda. Aga meie jaoks on alati üks Sama
Õpetaja: Vahet pole, mis see sisu siin on või midagi taolist saaks teha, et tuleb inglise keelselt, näiteks nii,
Õpetaja: kuid vajab andmeid Pärandis Näiteks kuvamiseks soovime kuvada.
Õpetaja: Props ei tohi olla interaktiivselt seotud ühegi elemendiga, Mis muudaks tema väärtust?
Õpetaja: Mis ma siin Räägin?
Õpetaja: Korra. Toome selle näitena ka. Meil Log in Views on. Juba interaktiivne element nimega input. Username on nii?
Õpetaja: Siin. Tema ei ole Propsi peal. See username on ju? Tatablokk, Olete nõus? Kukkusin siia kontrolliga. Vaid on uuesti. Üleval on seda kasutatud. Siin on kasutatud interaktiivse elemendiga vee. Mudeli abil. Kahepidiselt vaatasime. Ju kui ma, kirjutasin siia username mingisuguse Väärtuse
Õpetaja: Pbb on ju siis siin? Selles kasutajanimes on. See on arusaadav.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma muutsin selle sisu, siis see voolas sinna alla tagasi
Õpetaja: datablokki. Me võime veel mudeliga interaktiivsete elementidega siduda.
Õpetaja: Aga Propsi ei tohi Praegu, kui me vaatame. Ma võtan nüüd selle jama siit tagasi. Vaata, onju,
Õpetaja: mida me ei tohi teha, Kui minul on siin üks input elemant, ma teen uuesti ka ära. Bmp
Õpetaja: impit, näiteks, Ma ei tea, mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei tekst nii, Mul on siin see kast.
Õpetaja: See kast. Oo, kui see kast on veemudeliga seotud
Õpetaja: selle propsiga siin Error Message, siis See on siis see Niimoodi ei Tohi teha.
Õpetaja: Juba vingub siingi.
Õpetaja: Ta ütleb. Vaata. Unexpacked Mutation. Mis tähendab unexpected Mutation mutation. Ootamatu Mutatsioon.
Õpetaja: Props peab olema unmuteable, mis tähendab seda, et me ei tohi, et ta tema väärtus siin selles failis kuidagi muutub.
Õpetaja: Ta ei tohi muteeruda. Ta tohib ainult saada seda väärtust, mis talle üle ülevalt antakse.
Õpetaja: Aga kui sa seod selle, ütleme niimoodi. Ühtepidi on nagu justkui Fine
Õpetaja: ta. Talle ei meeldi see nagu Kohe nagu paneme ust. Refresh. Vaata, mis ta vingub siin. Vaata, sa ei tohi üle kirju. Vaata, see. Sa kirjutaks selle sisu üle aga Props on niimoodi, et sa pead tulema ülevalt alla voolama. Kui ma soovin,
Õpetaja: et mul siin selles Child elemendis selle Aa, selle properti, mis iganes seal on, onju? Siin on. Kui Ma soovin, et see mingil kujul muutub,
Õpetaja: siis ma saan niukest trikki teha, et ma saan saata ülesse sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Ole hea, muuda üleval seal neid andmeid
Õpetaja: ja siis ta voolab alla tagasi. Aga ma ei saa. Teda Ütleme niimoodi kaks asja Vaata, kui ma teen, vahet pole. Kas ma seon teie interaktiivse elemendiga, mis tahab sellele uut sisu kirjutada või mul oleks siin metsadzblokk
Õpetaja: metsas Bloki sees oleks. Ee, näiteks mingi meetod Change. Error message.
Õpetaja: Ma ei saa mitte kunagi siin. Sees Kirjutada This punkt. Error Message. Saa mingi Sisu
Õpetaja: mitte kunagi. Ma ei tohi teda siin muteeruda. Selles failis.
Õpetaja: Mitte kunagi ei tohi Propsi sisu muteeruda. See, mis ülevalt tuleb, see tuleb
Õpetaja: ei tohi seda muuta. Ja veemudel seda teeb. Ma tohiks teha. Niimoodi, Vaata, et kuvas ja input Box I. Ma võin panna näiteks, et
Õpetaja: vaalu ja panen siia. Ma ei tea niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et võta error Sisuliselt seda ma tohiks teha.
Õpetaja: Ma tohin kuvada. Ma tohin võtta selle väärtuste siia input Box I panna.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei tea, siin on nii palju koude katki. Lihtsalt me ei viitsi sellega tegeleda.
Õpetaja: Mis siin valestis on.
Õpetaja: Aa, Noh, mis on valesti? Üritan kuradi muteeruda siin. Nagu. Vaatada Davai.
Õpetaja: Ma kohe taastan selle. Ma tulen Selle juurde. Props ei tohi olla seotud interaktiivselt ühegi ele,
Õpetaja: mis muudaks tema väärtust. Nüüd on üldse üleüldine. Propsi muutmine Childis on keelatud sest et muidu tekib niuke lõputu Luup.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta muutub väärtust. Ta alt rigerdab ja see on. Seda Ei, tohi teha. See ei ole mõeldud niimoodi.
Õpetaja: See ei tohi teha Niimoodi see andmed voolavad ülevalt alla. Noh, ei, usu, võtame selle. Kas me poe kohta tegime? Mingi õpetuse? Ma ei mäleta enam
Õpetaja: selle templi Kontekstis on ju ülevalt poolt, et kui me all ei tohi muuta. Aga kust? Kust See ülevalt? Poolt Siin nagu on?
Õpetaja: Kus sa üle Näed, me paneme nad siis nagu niimoodi üksteise alla.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, Vaata et. Ee, ma korra. Ma teen nüüd selle error teen natukene korda, jälle et ma tahaks kaotada ära kontroletsetiga Kõik need koledused, mis ma siin tegin.
Õpetaja: Nii, oota siis. Räägin nagu lehe mõttes ülevalt alla, Et, ee, et pealeht on näiteks. Ee.
Õpetaja: Ei, mitte lehe mõttes. Vaata,
Õpetaja: siin on niimoodi, et login View Template osas. Ma ütlen, et palun, Joonista mulle alert. Erroris olev template sisu. Põhimõtteliselt see on kindel, mis ma siin ütlen.
Õpetaja: Siin ma kutsun välja komponenti. See on pärand, Vaata siin failis. Ütlen, et ülejäänud sisu. See on põhimõtteliselt see sama asi nagu.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt anna mulle see sisu,
Õpetaja: see on mõte, vaata kui ma, Aga kui ma mõtlen, kui see oleks kolmkümmend rida koodi. Ma ei taha seda kolmkümmend rida koodi. See kolmkümmend rida Koodi on mul, siin, Näed,
Õpetaja: toon komponendis. Noh,
Õpetaja: ta on komponendis. Ma ei taha, Ma ütleme, et kui see oleks mu soov teha mingi niukene asi, mis ma ei tea, siis on suur vahe. Vaata, et see, kus ma pären mina, See suhe hakkab siis pihta. Kui sa kutsud kuskilt kedagi välja,
Õpetaja: Näed, kui mina paneks siia selle, siis mul oleks mingisugune. Ee, kole asi siin.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma ei taha seda. Ma tahan, et see kole Asi oleks selles eraldi failis
Õpetaja: ja ma saan seda kasutada andes sisu.
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlengi, et siin tekib lihtsalt ühendus.
Õpetaja: Ee, nende vahel see Kuidas mul koodis on need asjad kirjutatud? Näed, siin tekib niimoodi, et Vaata, Vastavalt rajale laetakse komponent.
Õpetaja: Mis komponent laetakse? Kui me oleme kaldkriips, Login
Õpetaja: laetakse. Komponent Log in view. Nüüd mina koodis. Olen kirjutanud siin, et. Hei, kutsu välja Error.
Õpetaja: Bla, bla, Bla on ju siis palun väga. Tema kutsub selle komponendi välja.
Õpetaja: Aga ta annab Propsiga kaasa ka infot. Mida iganes mina barentist kirjutan, kirjutan siis
Õpetaja: siis see Voolab sinna alla kaasa ja seal joonistatakse.
Õpetaja: Siis Ma ei saa võtta selle komponendi lehelt omale sisendinfoto alla poole. Tähendab seda, et peaks nagu vastupidama,
Õpetaja: Täpselt aru sain. Ma ei tea. Vot siis kui inimene ei tea, mida ta küsib, siis on ka inimesel väga raske. Vastata ka ise on ju. Ee, teeme niimoodi. Lähme selle asjadega edasi. Me teeme seda asja
Õpetaja: siiamaani et. Ee, see tuleb läbi praktika ka rääkideks.
Õpetaja: Ee, võin teha Kas ma sellisel juhul ma tahan teha enam korda? Vähemalt, et mul siin ei ole mingisugust jälkusi. Nagu näiteks see.
Õpetaja: Nii Ma võin selle korda teha, Sest me teeme Kohe Hakkame siia mudima. Ka.
Õpetaja: Ku Kuidas teil jäi praegu siin? See lõpp, Ee.
Õpetaja: Ja. Aga siin on see Koolon on tähtis, mida me saame ka veel harjutada. Aa, nii, miks? Vaata, kui tähtis on siin, et on Snake Case,
Õpetaja: kui me tahame kasutada mingisugust nime Ja Childis mingit nime. Kui nad mõlemad oleks sama kirjaviisiga, mida see tegelikult toetab,
Õpetaja: siis on raskem aru saada, mis on Mis
Õpetaja: kui see no värv aitab natuke eristada, aga ka niimoodi on kokku lepitud tava, et mis? Sest et me siin Propsis ütlemegi ja Error Message siis väljakutsumisel. Me. Kui me viitame sellele asjale siin seda tehakse alati kebabina.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et vaadake, siis on meil silmal veelgi rohkem erisust.
Õpetaja: Mitte ainult värvid, vaid ka teksti sisu. Mõlemad töötavad samamoodi,
Õpetaja: Aga nii on õige. See Kool on siin
Õpetaja: kui seda kool, sest et Minul peab olema, õigus. Kui ma tahangi kirjutada sinna error message,
Õpetaja: siis on see minu õigus.
Õpetaja: Too see ikka mingi. Eriti kaua siin paneb, et kui kui ma soov Mul peab olema võimalus stringina kirjutada, mida iganes,
Õpetaja: siis see tavaliselt niimoodi lihtsalt ongi. Vaata, et paned aga see on just vastupidine olukord. Ei, ma tahan, et on muutujast. Ma pean teda aitama. Vaata, meil on nagu kahjuks olnud see, et ta alguses on natukene võõras.
Õpetaja: Millal ma kasutan neid topelt loogilisi sulgusid? Millal ma ei pea üldse midagi panema? Millal ma pean panema selle kooloni? See on natukene alguses Ee, raske,
Õpetaja: aga see tuleb praktikaga. Aa, see on see koht. See on see koht mingi hetk. Teeme mingi õppematerjali, ka, Siis kui mingid näidised on natukene, rohkem, siis ma ütlen, et tee mulle mingi paar näidet nende najal.
Õpetaja: Ee, Niukene Easy, Easy Guide, vaata Kus Ee, need käib? Läbi, Aga lähme nüüd edasi. Me peame edasi liikuma. Kuidagi
Õpetaja: nii, Refresh.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb mul see a sisse. Aga kus ta tuleb. Mul on siin error mees. Ja siis see on see koht, kus ma teen Comiti
Õpetaja: ning kes tahab tulla. Aa, saate kohe Peale seda, kui see push on läbi läinud,
Õpetaja: nii palun väga
Õpetaja: hiljem ja toomseks teeme ära ka selle Script I. Vaata, et kellel on Ligipääs,
Õpetaja: et saate väga ruttu tulla, et ta. Ta teeb Siin teeb teie eest need käsud ära.
Õpetaja: Uus haru checkout ja nii edasi, siis Saate veel kiiremini
Õpetaja: ja pisteliselt. Lihtsalt kohe küsin, et kas võin edasi minna. Siis Käsi püsti veel. Kes kelle järgi ootan?
Õpetaja: Praegu, Kelle järgi ootan, kes siis ma ootan?
Õpetaja: Oh Username sinna. Jah,
Õpetaja: võite kogu aeg koodi panna. Nii palju, kui hästi oskate. Aga Lihtsalt arvestage, et me Teeme kõik need asjad, et see on osa taskist, millele Marten oli, millele Marten viitas seda, et taaskis, on see, et seda peab ainult nägema Ainult siis, kui
Õpetaja: ee, sõnumis on sisu.
Õpetaja: Kui message on tühi, siis alerti ei kuvata kui mingi sisu. Noh, sa rääkisid tööriistast mida Keegi Ei tea veel
Õpetaja: ja töötasin Hästi,
Õpetaja: Jah, et selles mõttes sa ei avastanud midagi. Mida ma järgmisena ei nagu teeks? See on osa taasküst. Kas nüüd võib edasi liikuda? Käsi püsti Kedagi ootan. Ma ootan veel
Õpetaja: või minna kuuma. Ma ütlen ka kui te tunnete, et natukene on nagu armutu vaadata. Me peame. Olema. Me ei saa, nagu me peame. Nagu enamvähem keskmise tempoga panema. Meil on nii palju õppida, Meil On nii palju
Õpetaja: Aa, mingisugust Aa taga ajada ja aru saada. See ei ole väärtus. Väärtus On need kõik need asjad mis on vaja läbi katta. Nii paneme edasi. Aa, Noh, mina siit alt veel. Mul oli kogemata. Endal oli ka username I. Sees oli mingi, või mis iganes. Vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd, kus meil on, siis. Aa, see on ära tehtud, et tõesti tuleb meile see alert ette siis panete tähele, Ta on ju meil kogu aeg ees.
Õpetaja: Sisu ei ole. Siis ei peaks ju näitama. Oli seal see mõte.
Õpetaja: Nii, kuidas nüüd seda teha on Siis see täpselt ongi. See mõte, on see, et me saame nüüd selle loogika siia sisse ära ehitada,
Õpetaja: et, ee, mis peab juhtuma
Õpetaja: Ja see sama. Vot see nüüd on sellega, et on vaja mõelda. Vaata, et kui me hakkame nüüd järgmist lähenemist, mille mis asja nimi On Wave
Õpetaja: V. If on voe wife.
Õpetaja: Ja see töötab niimoodi, et kui sa võtad, Ma võtan korra lihtsalt mingi suvalise Tv I kõigepealt
Õpetaja: tiivi mingi. Hei, Hei, seda ka näidatakse. Näed siin üleval? He, He on, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Ee, esiteks, ma praegu rikun reegleid. Template Il peaks alati olema üks Child. Soovitatavalt on ju üks. Kaks. Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: kui mina panen siia V If. See on vaatamise koht praegu.
Õpetaja: Ee, Panen mingisuguse asja, mis rehkendub truuks. Ma panen lihtsalt statsionaalselt truu. Siis seda näitab.
Õpetaja: Kui siin. Vf I väärtus tuleb. False
Õpetaja: siis on Hei, Hei, ka, Hei, hei, on nii.
Õpetaja: Nüüd peab aru saama, et, ee, kui minul ei oleks siin lihtsalt tekst sees, vaid on hoopis. Mingi. Noh, Mul veel alles.
Õpetaja: See tabel
Õpetaja: on see tabel.
Õpetaja: Ma panen, kui ma panen siia praegu true,
Õpetaja: sest kõik, mis on selle divi sees,
Õpetaja: näidatakse hetkel. Ma panin selle tabeli. See tähendab, et seda tabelit näidatakse. Näeme ju kui see, on jällegi False,
Õpetaja: siis seda ei näidata,
Õpetaja: et Kui Te hakkate V If Itama, siis olge väga tähelepanelikud, et millise Aa Dv. Või elemendi sisse te panete?
Õpetaja: Te peate aru saama. Ise. Mida Te üritate peita või näidata?
Õpetaja: On see mingi nupp? No siis võibolla Patt on. Äkki nupp on mingi label. No siis ta võib olla. Peab eraldi divi sees olema, et kaks korda ei taha panna, et label on, et ise tuleb nende divide abil. Vaata, kui hea Asi on div onju, et me saame nende abil mängida. No ma kustutan selle ära. Meil ongi ainult üks div siin. Selles mõttes,
Õpetaja: kas Näidata või mitte.
Õpetaja: No ma ei tea, nüüd võibolla ühte reeglit. Midagi siia sisse peab minema. Kui dünaamiliselt ma korra võibolla teeks katust divisi Ja ma teekski ühe Tv I
Õpetaja: ja ma paneksin ee selle asja siia teise Tv sisse elama. Miks
Õpetaja: Template Il peab olema? Üks Child, Aga Kui see on Conditional?
Õpetaja: Kui Kui me kogu asi kaob eest ära, siis tegelikult samas üks tühi tiiv. Ma arvan, et tohiks midagi juhtuda. Ja vahet pole, kustutage ära. Las ta jääb niimoodi. Kui ta hakkab vinguma, siis me näeme. Ee, proovime. Ma ei ole kindel, et Tohib niimoodi teha. Lihtsalt et üldse, ei tule. No mis mõtet seda üldse välja kutsuda on?
Õpetaja: Muidugi,
Õpetaja: Aa, Me saaksime seda teha. Ma näitan, Me saaksime seda V If I teha ka sinna kohta, kus seda välja kutsutakse. Ehk siis siia siia saaks teha niukse asja nagu V If
Õpetaja: True ja False.
Õpetaja: Noh, True on. Ma panen False,
Õpetaja: aga see on nüüd üks konks.
Õpetaja: Kui me teeme selle loogika niiöelda väljapoole, siis tähendab, et iga kord, kus me seda Alerti kasutame, me peame jälle seda tegema. Siis sellest väljapoole seda V Ifi. Aga meie point on Lihtsalt see, et teeme just niimoodi siia sisse,
Õpetaja: et see on osa loogikast.
Õpetaja: Kui me tuleme siia Timvi,
Õpetaja: võibolla, et oleks parem aru saada, Ma Korraks paneks ta isegi niimoodi, nagu saate aru, See on niimoodi. Sisuliselt
Õpetaja: tõstab ta kokku. Ei tõsta, et siia Me tahame panna selle Alus alustagi. Me tahame panna Vf.
Õpetaja: No kuidas me tahame V If I panna?
Õpetaja: Näita kui on mingi sisu.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan korra. Nüüd on Java script võimaldab päris lühikeselt koodi kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen lihtsalt nii nagu praegult on. Aa, siis. Aa, Kui ta oleks täiesti tühi ehk Nal
Õpetaja: siis kindlasti mitte midagi näitaks. Ma ei tea, kuidas ta praegu tühjast ringi ee rehkendab.
Õpetaja: Kui on tühistring, siis tema, arvate, saad aru, Me saame seda pikalt teha, et kui on
Õpetaja: Kui siin on mingisugune väärtus, et ei ole tühi string, siis näita. Saate aru, See on Pikk võrdlus, mis rehkendub truuks. Ja False, on? Nii?
Õpetaja: See töötab ka. Mitte midagi ei näidata
Õpetaja: Kui ma. Panen login, siis tuleb täida kõik väljad, sest et ta järsku sai sisu Aga lühemalt saab ka kirjutada.
Õpetaja: See on jaavas Javascript, et saab niimoodi kirjutada, ka veef vaatab, kas Siin on mingi sisu või? Ei ole sisu. Kui on mingi sisu, siis ta rehkendub False iks
Õpetaja: truks. Tähendab Vabandust, kui mingi sisu ja Kui ei ole, siis on False,
Õpetaja: et saab lühikeselt kirja panna. Ma teen refresh, vajutan login, täida kõik väljad,
Õpetaja: saate mõttest aru, ja me Eelistame niukest lühi. Sellist lühikest. Kui vähegi, saab, ma vanasti olen pikalt kirjutanud. Aga ma nüüd näen. Aga nagu ära tõmbab silmad kirjuks, õpime ära,
Õpetaja: et kui on V If ja tegelikult. Üldse Mm.
Õpetaja: See on mu Midagi, mis ma enne korra mõtlesin. Ma võin komit I teha, Kes tahab praegu korra järgi tulla? Mida iganes, siis on, võimalus Kuigi nii väheste sammude peale. Ee, võiks suuta kuidagi enam olla peal, aga. Aga võimalus on sellegipoolest. Ma komitin ära.
Õpetaja: Ma korra küsin. Lihtsalt. Ee, samal ajal.
Õpetaja: Ee. Kohta mäletate? See meetod? Vaata Näete, siin on need Võrdlused
Õpetaja: ei ole tühi ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma korra küsin, kas Aa, ta võttis kohe praegu Controllerilt ka. Tegi mulle Cloud is It Tab Ina lahti ja pani mulle read. Nendes vahes onju,
Õpetaja: et, ee. Mäletad, Ma ennem kirjutasin Selected vaata, et see, et et see, mis Ma selekteerisin. Nüüd on nagu see, et ma nagu ütlen. Faili ja rea. Numbrid. Ee, see fail read. Kuuskümmend kuni kuuskümmend. Kaks Ma lihtsalt Panin tähele seal blogini. See on Niukene Kombo Control ad ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ja ma ütlen, et ee, kas seda saaks teha lühemalt, sest et tegelikult ilmselt saab.
Õpetaja: Võib olla tagatud.
Õpetaja: Noh, mingi monster arvutamine nagu
Õpetaja: token il kuluvad.
Õpetaja: Tšau,
Õpetaja: ee, no okei, ee, Vaadake kõige lühem variant,
Õpetaja: kui Ta teeb selle puulaan objektiks. Ee, see on kuidagi talle vajalik.
Õpetaja: Ta ei saa lihtsalt võrdsust panna, et ee, on Niukene konstruktor, kus sa Saad sisse anda mingisuguse võrrandi ja siis ta rekendab truuks ja False iks. Aga kuidas see nüüd on ju kui tema jaoks peaks olema et see on true ja see on true. Kui mõlemal on sisu, siis ta annab kokku. Old Feels are correct ongi? Jah,
Õpetaja: noh, siis Me saaksime selle ise ümber teha. Vaata, On ju et ta ei võimalda niimoodi. Vaata, teha, et sa seod. Ma arvan, et kas ta Siis niimoodi ei toimi. Vaata,
Õpetaja: võime korra proovida. Vaata, et kas ta töötab. Et kas ma pean sundima teda? Vaata, nagu et tee sellest Puuli on objekt. Ma korra pulli pärast proovin. Saab Isegi niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ta töötab? Me just õppisime seda ju. Vaata, et et kui sa Vaatad ifi sees ja annad mingi väärtuse, Siis ta vaatab, kas see on sisu või mitte, aga ma pakun Aga nii. Saab ka, Vaata Aga nii saab ka ju.
Õpetaja: Aga äkki siin on mingisugune väikene bitfall. Mingi auko, mida ma ei taba. Vaata, aga nii saab ka
Õpetaja: ja Vaatame, mis ta selle kohta ütleb. Nagu nüüd ta võib öelda, Sest ma ju tema kasutab seda, et. Vaata, et vaata, võta. Nagu kokku Tee üks true or false.
Õpetaja: Tee sellest, Ee, True. Puule on objekt. Tee Sellest ja siis konstruktoris. Aa läheb nüüd mingid väärtused sisse. See Võib olla mingisugune Aa trikk. Vaata, miks tema seda pakkus. Või Ta võib öelda, et nii saab ka
Õpetaja: jah, täpselt. See on kõige lühem, mis töötab sama hästi and tagastab viimase väärtuse või esimese Wifi jaoks on see täiesti piisav.
Õpetaja: On parem.
Õpetaja: Aga hea on alguses teha seda Niimoodi, Nagu, et me oleme harjunud. Võrdub, Võrdub tühjusega või ei võrdu.
Õpetaja: Ja siis õpime nagu lühemalt. See on täiesti normaalne protsess Me ei Kirjuta mitte kunagi. Aa, perfect. Koodi. See peaks kohe niimoodi olema. Jah, ürita kirjutada head koodi. Kohe, nagu kirjutad koodi. Aga siin on nagu Selline filosoofia. Vaata,
Õpetaja: make It Briti make, It fast make it work. Ee. Sul ei ole mõtet teha mingit maailma kõige paremat koodi kui Sa võibolla läheb prügikasti. Siis lihtsalt. Sa ei vii kuhugi
Õpetaja: Saad asja. Tööle Make Briti No Make Briti all on nüüd mõeldud koodi. Loetavus Kas teen eraldi koodilõikudeks? Meetodid, asjad, muutujad, head, head head ja ja make. It fast. No seda me siin ei õpi kursusel. See tuleb kogemusega ka, et võibolla mingisugused algoritmid saab nagu teha natukene efektiivsemalt Make It fast performance.
Õpetaja: See on viimane asi nii
Õpetaja: saime selle selles mõttes käima. Ja nüüd on nagu see. Vaata, kuidas alati peaks tegema. Kui teil on mingid reaktiivsed asjad. Selles mõttes et te ise olete programmeerinud Mingi sisu pealt.
Õpetaja: Mida peaks tegema, on see, et iga Jumala kord,
Õpetaja: kui sa vajutad nuppu, siis kõige esimese asjana me peaksime veenduma, et Err on tühi.
Õpetaja: Oota, Point on see, et kui ma ühe korra vajutan nuppu,
Õpetaja: siis kas see error message saab uue sisu või mitte, Kas Ta peab korraks minema tühjaks? Mu mõte on nagu see, et kui sa vajutad loogi nuppu,
Õpetaja: siis iga kord Me peame garanteeritult alustama. See on ikka hea tava, et see error message sisu on tühi.
Õpetaja: Saate ma üldse aru või ei saa,
Õpetaja: Ma teen väikse, vaata siis Te saate sellest aru. Ee, teeme koodilu Jupi. Me teeme niikuinii selle.
Õpetaja: Ee, Cloud hakkab sinna ütlema, et ära tee nagu eraldi meetodit. Me Teeme eraldi meetode ka sellest.
Õpetaja: See koodilõik teeb ainult niukest asja. Dis Punkt error. Message võrdub tühistring.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teeksin sellest eraldi meetodi, mis võiks olla selle meetodi nimi. See on mingi tegevus.
Õpetaja: Kuidas öelda niimoodi? Hästi, geneeriliselt. Mida me teeme selle error message? Iga
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: lihtsalt see Vahet pole, kas ta on näiteks siin või ta on kuskil siin tegevuse lõpus. Justkui vaata siis. Sellel võib öelda, et me nagu algseadistame,
Õpetaja: Jah, kui ma teeks sellest Control alt M,
Õpetaja: siis Me lähme alati Top level üks samm alla, et ta palun meetodi bloki
Õpetaja: meetodiblokkide sellest Koodi. Eraldi koodilõik. Selle nimi võiks olla reset
Õpetaja: nii Ja nüüd ta tegi seda, et ta, toppis sellesse niimoodi kaelakuti.
Õpetaja: Lööme, sööme meie selle Loo kinni niimoodi alla,
Õpetaja: et seda asja tõsta. Niimoodi üksteise alla. Võibolla on lihtsam niimoodi. Kui tõmbame need korra lihtsalt kokku.
Õpetaja: Meil siin kolm meetodit, onju? Noh, Taipo, on. Ma Refaktureerin Sage
Õpetaja: näete. Kui Te re refaktureerite midagi. Ta vahel küsib kinnitusakent. Ruttu, minge. Vajutage refaktor, Kui te Juba enne otsustasite, kui see ära ununeb. See on. Te mõttes mõtlete, et ta refaktureeris teie koodi? Ma tegelikult ei küsis mingit kinnitust
Õpetaja: ja Siin mina mõtleks. Vaata, et nagu kontroll X
Õpetaja: ja kontrol R või Vabandust, kontrol. V.
Õpetaja: Ma lihtsalt järjekorra paneks niimoodi
Õpetaja: ja minu mõte on See, et iga nupu vajutusega ee, on meil vähemalt korraks vaja taastada see, et ee niiöelda ei oleks mingeid message, saate mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: selles mõttes, et iga kord, kui me nuppe vajutame, siis ee, see error. Message sisu ise enam. Kas ma küsin niimoodi, et enne seda koodirida Kas siin. On kuskil enne seda koodirida, mis me just tegime? Vaata selle meetodi. Kas siin kuskil oli niukest kohta, mis? Ee, Kirjutas, vaata et Error Message, et see oleks tühi.
Õpetaja: Ma ei olnud. See tähendab, seda, et kui ta juba omale sisu saab.
Õpetaja: Ja järgmise vajutusega oletame, et on okei.
Õpetaja: Aga me siit lehelt veel ära ei lähe. Siis see error. Message jääks ju sinna. Error Message kuvatakse vastavalt. Seda Alerti kuvatakse vastavalt sellele. Kas seal muutujas on sisu või? Ei ole?
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen nagu. Seda. Vaata, oletame, et ee. Siin oleks mingi kinnitussamm, Kujutage ette praegult. Ma. Ma korra login praegu sisse. Vaata, ma teen. Mängime mängu. Ta Tegelt veel ei teegi midagi.
Õpetaja: Siis see logib, ma ma Võtan selle. Ma kommenteerin korra Lihtsalt välja. Selle error. I.
Õpetaja: Kui ma praegult ee, vajutan loo kinni, ütleb. Täida kõik. Välja.
Õpetaja: Mäletan ma nüüd Täidan kõik väljad ära.
Õpetaja: Oletame, et kui ma ütlen loo kinni, siis me kohe pärast siit vaatelt ära ei lähe. Vaid midagi veel toimub siin, nagu onju. Aga kui ma nüüd vajutan loo kinni,
Õpetaja: siis täida kõik. Väljad on endiselt ees sellepärast et pole ühte. Ainsat koodirida selles tegevuse, juures, mis muudab selle väärtust
Õpetaja: ja seda asja näidatakse mul seni kaua, kuni toimub mingi muutus.
Õpetaja: Props jälgib muutusi Props järgi muutused ja Reaktiivne muutuja.
Õpetaja: Kui kunagi sinna Child komponenti Propsi sisu muutub, siis tema vaatab uuesti selle ümber. Kas ma pean näitama? Pean joonistama Midagi ei pea.
Õpetaja: Kui. Kui me ütleme, tuletame, et siin oleks veel, tuleks mingi samm, et ee, palju roll. Näiteks tuleb alla. Palju Rolle. Mul on Mingi Niukene konto, millega ma saan olla nii admin kui ka tavaklient. Aga mida ma näen ja teen on erinevad? Võtame hoopis Bolt
Õpetaja: Oletame Nüüd Bolt. Ma login sisse. Oletame, et mina olen ühtlasi ka ennast reganud juhiks.
Õpetaja: Aga teisisõnu, ma tahan olla ka klient
Õpetaja: nagu see, et Kas ma palun takso? Hello, tahan peale minna. Siis mõni süsteem võib niimoodi olla. Peale logimist Ta lihtsalt ütleb. Vaata, et kui ma trolliesin, Jah,
Õpetaja: noh, uuesti. Näha, kuidas meid olid nagu puhtalt sinna alla.
Õpetaja: No, mina tegin. Ütleme, niimoodi kui Ma tahan tõsta midagi, siis ma lihtsalt Löön asju nagu ridade mõttes. Nagu üksteisest. Lahku,
Õpetaja: Ee, mis ma siis teiseks teen, on see. Vaata, et, ee. Ma tõmban nad nagu, kokku Nagu selles mõttes, et. Noh, ta nagu näitab vaid meetodi nime. Ma tulen selle rea peale. Kontroll X
Õpetaja: Control V eeldus on see, et Neil on need komad seal taga. Vaata, kui mingil asjal on koma puudu, siis on katki,
Õpetaja: et see on eeldus.
Õpetaja: Loo Näed, iga blokk lõppeb komaga.
Õpetaja: Mina teen nii
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Kas Teil on mingeid küsimusi?
Õpetaja: Miks seda reset Error Messagesit on? Vaja Saate kodust veel vaadata rahulikumas tempos, Kui ee, ei saa. Aga nüüd vaata, nüüd on see asi. Vaata, ma hetkel midagi ei tee. Nüüd on see asi olemas. Mul tuleb Viga siis nupuklõpsuga. Algseis on see, Vaata, et igal juhul nupu klõbistades error message. See algseis on tühjus.
Õpetaja: Näed. See on esimene asi mis kutsutakse käima.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et kui ma nüüd täidan ära.
Õpetaja: Ja nii kui ma vajutan. Esimene tegevus on reset message, mis annab, temale
Õpetaja: Tühja sisu, mis voolab sinna alerti. Ja mis jõuab siia?
Õpetaja: See Props on Niukene reaktiivne muutuja. Siin Voe ise jälgib seda sisu või ütleme, Nii
Õpetaja: kas muutub? Ei muutu. See on sündmus. Kui muutub,
Õpetaja: siis Ta teab, et Okei, muutus. Siin tuleb kogu see klots uuesti joonistada. Jah, Rain.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt kirjutasid disk punkt error. Message siis. Ee.
Õpetaja: Ja mis see kontroll? Rtm selle
Õpetaja: kui. See, No ma taastan selle olukorra
Õpetaja: tõstsin ta lihtsalt siia alla. Vaata, see tuli siia ülesse. Ma võin uuesti teha. Näed, ma kustutan. Ee, võtan selle. Ma teen niimoodi nagu oli. Ennem Võtan selle copy. Ma kustutan selle ära. Minu algseis oli. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi oli. Ma võtsin selle bloki, et sellest tahan eraldi meetodit ja Controllert M.
Õpetaja: Lähen alati Top level ja üks samm alla. Vaata, vaata, kui sa näete, kuidas see nagu näitab väikene noolekene näitab, et kuhu see Meetod hakkab tulema. Kui ma võitan top level, siis see meetod tuleb sinna ülesse. Ja see ei ole see, mida ma soovin, Escape,
Õpetaja: mis käib, kui ma panen siia, et Top level üks samm alla. Nüüd ta näitab, et kuhugi meetodi blokki selle login meetodi ette tuleb, vaid on Enter.
Õpetaja: Panen mingi nime, mis oli reset keeruline
Õpetaja: error
Õpetaja: menter. Aga lihtsalt on see, et näed ta. Ta tegi siia selle meetodi aga Nad elavad ju kaelas. Ma lihtsalt löön alati nagu paar rentrit, et, noh, reavahetused
Õpetaja: siia alla ka. Ja siis mis ma teen, et kui Ma tahan järjekorda toppida. Siis ma nagu panen nad niimoodi ühele reale, Sest et siis ma saan olla lihtsalt siin real vajutada control iks, Mis tähendab Cut tulla uuele Reale Controll, B ja
Õpetaja: Done Nii Ja nüüd see töötab sellepärast, et ma teen Refresh Ina ka, veel onju, Mul Ei ole midagi,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd, kui ma vajutan nuppu, esimene tegevus on reset message, mis kaotab ära selle alerdi,
Õpetaja: et, noh, ta töötab, Sest et iga kord kui meil tulevad mingid. Kuidas
Õpetaja: ee, et selle selle mõte on see, et see on niukene väikene asi, mis nagu Kogenud arendaja kohe mõtleb, nagu. Vaata, on ju, et kui sa muudad mingisuguse asja väärtust, ee, siis sa pead mõtlema seda, vaata, et kas Ta peab kuidagi muutuma tagasi,
Õpetaja: et kui noh, eriti nupu vajutuse peale pead alati mõtlema seda, et kui ma nupu vajutas, kui sa lähed siit lehelt ära kuskile siis kõik. See nagu läheb musta auku, onju? Kõik, mis siin toimus. Tsau, siis ma ei pea muretsema.
Õpetaja: Aga kui Ma olen siin samal lehel. Ma pean alati mõtlema, eriti, kui tuleb mingid veateated ja asjad, et. Et, aa, et kui nüüd ma täidan kõik asjad õigesti ära Näiteks vajutan nuppu ja midagi siin lehel hakkab toimuma. Siis mingi vana asi. Võibolla peab peitu tagasi minema,
Õpetaja: et iga kord, kui mingisugune selline reaktiivsus, mis me oleme ise programmeerinud. See veef. Tegime meie ju
Õpetaja: Me peame mõtlema neid tingimusi nagu niiöelda läbi, et Ega see lõpuks oleks tulnud. Ee. Pugina välja nagu kuskilt
Õpetaja: siin. Potentsiaalselt. Mitte sellepärast, et siin kontekstis on meil kohe. Tsau, Baka Lähme mujale, et ei teki seda olukorda. Vaata, et sul on kogu aeg vale vale vale.
Õpetaja: Senikaua kuni sul on õige. Vaata aga õigega me läheme niikuinii siit minema. Nii et siis, ei ole nagu ei saa olla seda olukorda, et täidad kõik õigesti ära. Niiöelda kaob ära, aga meie Jääme siia lehele siin lihtsalt selles konkreetses äriloogilises ülesandes. Seda ei juhtu lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Vot nii.
Õpetaja: Okei. Aa, kui me nüüd vaatame taaski
Õpetaja: blogi sisse Vaimselt kontrollitakse, kas kõik väljad on täidetud. Kui kumbki välja on jäänud, Täitmata näidatakse täida kõik väljad loo sellele jaoks eraldi komponent
Õpetaja: ee kui Message Props I sisse. Message. Kui message on tühistreringi lett ei kuvata. Kui on mingi sisu, kuvatakse letti,
Õpetaja: kõik vajalikud väljad on kui kõik Väljad on täidetud, Siis saadakse vaadat sõnum aadressil. Kett, login koos query Request Parameetritega Query parameeter. On. Urli väline parameeter
Õpetaja: küsimärk Lõpetab Urli ja Siis on nimed. Näed username
Õpetaja: kastist. Võta Admin Password Kastist. Võta väärtused. Saate ma tast aru. See sõnum peab minema lõpuks Backendile teele
Õpetaja: Ja Siis on öeldud. Back end tagastab sellele päringule siukse, sõnumi või sihukese sõrmi või sihukese sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Nii, okei,
Õpetaja: väga hea.
Õpetaja: No nüüd siis tuleb Aa, midagi uut meile Jälle Vahepeal, et me nüüd peame hakkama nagu seda asja mõtlema.
Õpetaja: Ja me esimesel korral teeme selle asja ee siin käsitsi ära.
Õpetaja: No tegelikult ma ütlen. Alates mingi peaaegu kaks kolm kursust. Tagasi Me teeme seda niikuinii kogu aeg käsitsi. Vanasti ma tegin väiksed templateid, aga mulle enam ei meeldi.
Õpetaja: Vaata, nii, Moor Mulle meeldib seda osa tegelikult ikkagi käsitsi teha. Natuke targemalt.
Õpetaja: Nii. Aa, sõnumi Saatmine. Aa,
Õpetaja: kõikidesse modernsesse. Niiöelda kõikidesse modernsetesse. Ee, niiöelda Brauserites on ehitatud Niukene programm nagu Fetch Api niuke programm, mis saab saata sõnumeid
Õpetaja: restsõnumeid saab saata. Sisse ehitatud Ja see on juba olemas Brauseris.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis meie ei kasuta seda, mis on olemas, vaid meil on hoopis siia projekti sisse Imporditud selline asi nagu
Õpetaja: see on Üks tehnoloogia, mis samamoodi ma arvan, Põhjal põhjas ta kasutabki kuidagi ka seda. Ma olen suht kindel, ma ei ole seda kunagi kohta kunagi lugenud. Ma olen Jumala kindel, et see nii on.
Õpetaja: Aa, Me ei taha seda sisse ehitatud varianti kasutada Sellepärast, et aktsias, mis Aa niiöelda saab projektile juurde. Panna
Õpetaja: Ee, sihukesele Aktsiasia kasutamine peab olema päriselus kaalutletud Tegelikult ka
Õpetaja: enamus kohad võibolla kasutavad Pigem seda progemises on natukene rohkem Aa, niukest, abstraktsiooni ja keerukust ja asju, mida ma üldse ei soovi õpetada. Ma ise. Ausalt öeldes, ma Ei tahaks üheski projektis jagastada. Aktsiasil on igasuguseid plusse. Saad igast ide ja igast vägevaid asju teha. Peamine asi, miks me kasutame aktsiast on See, et mulle meeldib selle paganama ülesehitus.
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldib ülesehitus et on nagu If ven Else ja Finali.
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldib seda, et ta on Nagu natukene nagu If lause. Sa saadad sõnumi
Õpetaja: See on see If ja sulgude sisus ka enda, nagu võib mõ mõelda paralleeli. Sa saadad sõnumi. Kui sa saad mingisuguse hea sõnumi,
Õpetaja: mis hakkab mingi kahesajaga,
Õpetaja: siis See on juba ära automatiseeritud, et mistahes kahesajaga sõnum, tuleb siis tema. Läheb nagu käivitub venblokk.
Õpetaja: Nii nagu If Lauses on. No mis, kus meil on? Siin? If Lause. Näete seda siin If
Õpetaja: Else on ju, Kui kõik läheb hästi, Then do something else bla, bla, bla. Olete nõus
Õpetaja: Ja seda saab samamoodi kujutada ette, et saada sõnum, kui kõik Läheb hästi, Den. Midagi teeme Els. Mingisugune viga.
Õpetaja: Õudsalt. Mõnus niimoodi. Ja selle selles mõttes on ta hea.
Õpetaja: Õppimise mõttes Just on ta hea. Aa, viimane. Just viimane kord. Kui siis keegi kasutas oma sõbra abi, kes siis juhtus? Olema Looja Bratt töötab ka kuskil tugevas kohas,
Õpetaja: kes Saatis mulle siis pika kirja monoloogiga, mida mina õpetama peaksin. Ja miks on ju Siis Tal oli ühtlasi kirjas ka see, et et õpeta,
Õpetaja: Aga tead, ma mõtlen seda vaata. Et, ee, ma ei ole nõus. Ma kaalusin seda väljavahetamist, aga siis, kui ma vaatasin seda Fetch süntaksit, Siis ma mõtlesin, et kurat, see kuradi akses on lihtsalt niivõrd palju parem.
Õpetaja: Ta on lihtsalt niimoodi hästi kuidagi struktureeritud ja mulle meeldis see, Sest ma saan oma õpilastel õpetada paremini asju, mis on kuidagi visuaalselt struktureeritud Mitte abstraktsiooniga, et ise pead juurde mõtlema,
Õpetaja: Ee, Ja mis selle aktsiasia Downsight on see, et kui teie veebilehekülg kasutab seda aktsiast, siis Browser peab selle alla tõmbama. Kui ta ei ole seda juba varem ära tõmmanud.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis esimesel Korral läheb mingi mikrosekund kauem aega, kui Browser pole kunagi aktsias kasutanud. Aa, suured veebilehed kasutavad aktsiast, See on Nagu Niukene Noh, seal on eelmine pluss miinus. Miks seda kasutada?
Õpetaja: Minule meeldib lihtsalt see. Struktuur.
Õpetaja: If the Ennels,
Õpetaja: kui ma saan hea sõnumi, Ee, Else, kui ei saa. Ee, see ongi paras koht. Rääkida Mis tähendab hea sõnum ja halb sõnum.
Õpetaja: Ee, kas te olete kunagi tähele pannud. Ee, et veebilehel on ees mingi Http hypertekst
Õpetaja: Protokoll Jah, midagi taolist. See nüüd on tehnoloogia.
Õpetaja: Kokku lepitud standard ja protokoll. Kuidas Ee, Süsteemid omavahel suhtlevad me. Keegi ei viitsi nagu mõelda Nagu seda osa. Vaid me alati mõtleme. Ainult
Õpetaja: on ju seda eelmist. Kõik Brauserid panevad juurde aastast. Kuuskümmend üheksa. Okei, võibolla mitte nii aastast. Üheksakümmend kuus, võibolla. Aa, et seda ise ei pea keegi kirjutama juurde, aga taustal on See nüüd on protokolle tehnoloogia. Kuidas asjad omavahel suhtlevad?
Õpetaja: Või nende ressõnumite? Sa saatmine see kett. Sõnumite saatmine. See on ka enda nüüd selle Peale ehitatud. Aa, lähenemine. Aga mis on nagu meil hästi tähtis teada on Niuke asi nagu
Õpetaja: status, Coach.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kus me vaatame see vist Kõige lihtsam Mdn ist vaadata.
Õpetaja: Jah, suures pildis. Tegemist on siis status koodiga, Mida siis vastassüsteem saab öelda? Sulle Suures pildis jagunevad nad viidegruppi
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis algavad sajaga, on siuksed, informatiivsed.
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis on kahesajaga, on niuksed. Yes, Successful. Kolmsada on Aa niuksed ümbersuunamised. Väga Need me ei Kasuta Aa. Nelisada. On siis Client Error responses. Client Error responses on siis see. Vaata, et kui meie teeme mingi süsteemi
Õpetaja: siis need vead, Mida meie oleme põhimõtteliselt ära progenud. Ja nagu teinud, et keelatud või Aa, mingid andmed on puudu ja head head head ja need on Kõik neljasajaga.
Õpetaja: Nüüd viimane on Server Error. Need on siis sellised vead, mida Server ise viskab, mis ei ole meie programmeerinud
Õpetaja: no lihtne näide, Kui sul ikka andmebaas kukub tagant ära osa loogikast on, see, et võta andmeid ja tagasta neid. Kui sul ei ole siis server viskab Põmm. Nagu Mingi viiesaja. Seal, et error Viissada olete kindlasti teinud ka error viitesadat. Ee, mida te olete kindlalt ka näinud on näiteks nelisada Neli page not found
Õpetaja: frontence süsteem. Tegelikult ise viskab sulle vea, et sina üritad kuhugi lehele minna, mida pole olemas, vaata, on ju, ee, seal põhimõtteliselt siis. Noh, enamvähem automatiseeritud ütleb, et. Kuule, ma ei. Me ei leia niuks lehte. Vaata, on ju, aga see ei ole näiteks Serveri viga. Vaata midagi katastroofist pikali. Isegi mitte Fronten Serveri katastroofiline Viga.
Õpetaja: Viie Kui Teie, Mis meie kontekstis, mis tal on vaja, teada, on Ainult kakssada.
Õpetaja: Kahesajaga on meil kõik kakssada. Me seda. Need on erinevaid. Näed? Ee, kui me läheme korra kahesajale, vaid või neid Ei ole, Niimoodi et kakssada Kuni kakssada, üheksakümmend üheksa. See on maksimum. Niiöelda vahemik.
Õpetaja: Neid Neid koode ise juurde. Ei saa tekitada. Need koodid on standard, Need on Http tehnoloogias ära määratletud ja ei ole niimoodi, et igas vahemikus on sott nagu mingi erinevaid asju
Õpetaja: Nad on jätnud ka mingisugust paar huvitavat asja, kui sa üldse ei oska midagi leida. Näiteks see, et sa oled. Ee,
Õpetaja: gepott. Ma ei tea, seda. Vaatan ka kohe, Et, ee, siin kahesajal on erinevad olukorrad. Näiteks et lihtsalt. Okei, okei,
Õpetaja: ee, success.
Õpetaja: Kõik läks hästi. Lisasime mingeid asju süsteemi, ee kakssada, kaks Accepted
Õpetaja: ja siin on mingid tingimused ka juures. Vaata aga, nad on kõik positiivsed, aga natukene siis täpsustavad, mida teeme,
Õpetaja: nagu Kõik, mis läheb Hästi on kakssada
Õpetaja: ja neljasaja. Neljasajaga on need, kus me valdavalt opereerime Vaatame neljasadat ka. Bad Request
Õpetaja: Ee, seda meie ise programmeerides ei pane. Aga kui me saadame serverile mingi sõnumi? Ta saab isegi aru. Vaata, et kes on selle sõnumi lahendaja, Mis tegevus seal peab hakkama pihta käima. Aga ta vaatab, et see sõnum, mis me oleme saatnud, ei vasta nagu oodatud tingimustele,
Õpetaja: Et näiteks me oleme öelnud, et me ootame sisse. Mingit parameetrit nimega User Name. Kui sõnum läheb ilma selle parameetrita username, siis tal on nagu Bad Request.
Õpetaja: Ta on näe purli järgi ära, et sa tahaks. Login midagi käivitada aga see vorm ei ole nagu nõuete kohaselt täidetud eest.
Õpetaja: No Meie kasutame veel siit ise progedes For pidentem keelatud. Nelisada, neli not found. Rohkem vist väga ei kasuta. Teeme mingi niukse süsteemi.
Õpetaja: Ee, et need. On siis saatete B staa staatused.
Õpetaja: Need on siis see, mille süsteem võib vastata Ja kuidas aktsias töötab, on suurepärane ja lihtne.
Õpetaja: Kui me saadame mingisuguse Aa sõnumi, siis
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis tulevad kahesajaga, tema siis ka enda läheb sinna Ten blokki, et sa saaksid sõnumi
Õpetaja: Server annab sulle mingi vastuse, ja Ütleb kakssada, Üks või kakssada. Kaks või kakssada. Neli või lihtsalt kakssada. Vahet pole. Tema jaoks on kõik, et läks läbi ja käivitub kohe blokk.
Õpetaja: Said sõnumi, siis tee midagi.
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis on nelisada või viissada tema jaoks. Siin vahet pole, Tema jaoks on error.
Õpetaja: Kas seda andis meie enda Progetud Aa serverkoodi teada, et ma ei tea. Keelatud ligipääs või kukkus midagi pikali või on koodis kuskil Backendis viga ja tuleb mingi kriitiline Viissada, Vaata, backhand. Server ei oska enam ka midagi. Teha. Ta ütles, et annab viissada. Siis Vahet pole. Tema jaoks on siis see nagu Else blokk. Põhimõtteliselt midagi läks tuksi,
Õpetaja: et hästi lihtne Kakssada jäi kõik, mis muu on nei.
Õpetaja: No enam lihtsamaks minna ei saa, Sisuliselt on If.
Õpetaja: Saadad sõnumi ja kõik läheb hästi, Siis Then do something as
Õpetaja: error. Viska midagi. Catch on error. Püüa error kinni,
Õpetaja: et ee, hästi Lihtne, Ee, meeldib see
Õpetaja: nüüd? Aa, praegu siis pikemalt. Sellel ei peatu, aga vaatame korraga ära.
Õpetaja: Htp meetodid.
Õpetaja: Aa, kui meie saadame mingisuguse sõnumi, Noh, Võtame jälle oma
Õpetaja: Apollo kinokava ette, kui meie saadame mingisuguse sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Näete, ma läksin siit sellele Urlile pikalt.
Õpetaja: See Url on, kuhu ma lähen. Kui ma vaatan taustat inspektiga ja Vaatan Network korra, teen Refresh I,
Õpetaja: siis kõige esimene. Sõna. Mul on Fetch pealt. Ee, võtan Fetchi maha.
Õpetaja: Kõige esimene sõnum, mis läheb tüüpide järgi või järjekord. Aa, kurat.
Õpetaja: Aa, all See käib niimoodi. Siin
Õpetaja: Ee, Terve Fresh. Kõige esimene sõnum Mis läheb, ongi see sama url. Nüüd ma juba panin. Mingi Läks tuksi. See asi. Kõik.
Õpetaja: Paneme lihtsalt uuesti lahti. Ma panin, et ta järjest läks Nam I järgi.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan selles järjekorras, Kuidas asjad Lähevad? Nii For the Love of God Refresh
Õpetaja: nii nüüd oli juba õige. Ma nägin kõige Esimene sõnum, mis läheb. Vaatame Siit Headeri järgi. On selline see sama aadress.
Õpetaja: Mis? Sõnum, mis on Request Meetod Get,
Õpetaja: kõik mis siit Urlilt lähevad, lähevadki ketid,
Õpetaja: Aga muidu neid tüüpe on rohkem. Ja mis meid huvitavad, on get.
Õpetaja: Loe andmeid. Anna andmeid.
Õpetaja: Post, see on? Ütleme, paneme kruud.
Õpetaja: Äkki kuskil on mingi pilt või midagi?
Õpetaja: Näe see sama.
Õpetaja: No ausõnaga. Kui keegi leiab veel mingi viienda dimensiooni Aa, Millega saab? Mis saab andmetega teha? Põhimõtteliselt, siis öelge mulle andmete lisamine, Andmete lugemine, uuendamine ja kustutamine.
Õpetaja: Kui Mehed, tubli käid.
Õpetaja: Kuidas? No võibolla Ta võib post ka olla. Tuleb uus rida.
Õpetaja: Mida see tähendab, Publish? No see on Lisa ju. Siis arvatavasti ma ei tea. Okei,
Õpetaja: ma Ei tea, mis mis asi on, Publish. Mis asi on Publish Tava kontekstis üldse? Pead analoogia tooma. Vaata, et kuidas on see midagi muud, mis Ei, ole lisamine? Andmete lugemine, Andmete uuendamine, kustutamine. Mm,
Õpetaja: no siis, sellised. Noh ütleme. Süsteemi mõttes. Ma teaks, tekib uus kirje, Vaata, et Kuidas muud moodi kuskilt on? Ta loetav Siis on ju Okei. Ee, kruudmõtetest lähtudes on Agronüüm. Kuidas me näeme seda akronüümi? Näeme mujal ka seda. Näiteks.
Õpetaja: Kui me tahame midagi lisada, siis selles sõnumis, mis me saadame, peab minema kaasa. Niukene märksõna nagu Http Meetod post
Õpetaja: Kui me Tahame andmeid, et too meile andmeid. Siis läheb kett. Kui me tahame üle kirjutada. See on put ja delik. Nüüd need asjad iseenesest, kui Sa paned need sõnad juurde. Ei tähenda, et süsteemis kuskil Back end siis kohe, teeb neid asju.
Õpetaja: See on ainult lihtsalt kokku lepitud süsteem, et kui sa nagu teed mingit teenust, mis lisab midagi, siis tema pool peaks minema postiga. Kui see teenus sulle annab andmeid, siis sa Peaksid selle ära markeerima. Ketiga, see on kokkuleppeline. Lihtsalt tava.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Siin on väiksed probleemid, on ka Ee, kõik, mis ma saan siit. Aa, Ma ütlesin, kõik mis ma siit urile panen Läheb ketiga. On, nii
Õpetaja: ketil. Ei Ole võimalik seda et, ma panen näiteks mingi jason Faili kaasa.
Õpetaja: Kuhu ma panen selle? Kirjutan mingisuguse. Raja Mingisugune rada.
Õpetaja: Ja Kas siis peale seda tuleb nüüd mingi Monster Jason, siia mahub ka teatud tähemärke. By the way Et, see on piiratud siia. Ei või panna nagu viiskümmend kilo gigabaiti teksti lihtsalt siia urlile Kui, See ei tööta
Õpetaja: Et, ee, Et Kethil näiteks ei ole keha.
Õpetaja: Ja vahel võib olla see, niimoodi et sa tahad pärida andmeid ja sa tahad nagu vältida Seda, et sul on hästi palju parameetreid, Urlis.
Õpetaja: Siis sa võid siis tea. See on see igipõline küsimus. Vanasti, Seda Aa, inimesed arvutasid, et Kas võib teha postiga Tegelikult andmete pärimist?
Õpetaja: Kuna sa saad saata kaasa. Kus on igast erinevaid parameetreid? No näiteks nagu kuupäev nimi Mingid asjad. Vaata, nagu booking us Tegelikult näed, ongi. Mingi Urlis. On rämedalt, et. Et. Kas nagu, võiks? Sest et niimoodi oleks kindel, nagu mugavam toimetada,
Õpetaja: Jah, See tegelikult võib. Aga see tegelikult ei ole päris nagu hea tava. Ikkagi.
Õpetaja: See muutub teile selgemaks. Natukene hiljem ka põhiline asi on See, et meil on siis saadete sõnumitel niuksed asjad, et kui me saadame mingi sõnumi teele me peame ära määrama ka enda nagu tüübi.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me aa siis, ee. Saame mingeid vastuseid. Sealt tulevad staatused. Väga vähe On vaja teada. Aa, rohkem ei olegi vaja. Nüüd kui Me tahame sõnumit hakata saatma. See on nüüd kaasategemise koht.
Õpetaja: Siis Mis meie tahame teha, on see, et me tahame saata seda läbi aktsiuse, Mis ma näitan, on projektis olemas. Kui minna ja siia,
Õpetaja: siis see osa. Aa siin. Näete aktsias.
Õpetaja: See tehnoloogia on sisse installitud, ta on sisse imporditud. See rida ka, et igal pool on kasutatav, sest kunagi räägime natuke hiljem. Kui te hakkate projekte tegema ja see tähendab seda, et me saame kasutada.
Õpetaja: Saame kasutada
Õpetaja: aktsiast, kui siia kirjutame sõna?
Õpetaja: Kas teil need asjad tulevad? Ju Aktsiasketi asjad. Need on minu varasemad templateid Ma võin korraks panna selle ette, aga see ei jää. Me tahamegi praegu teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, aktiosket.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on küsimus, et. Ee. Kas ta läheb Lihtsalt urlina. Kas seal on ka mingid Ee, rajavälised parameetrid või? Seal on rajasisesed muutujad
Õpetaja: Ee, praegult. Ärge tehke kaasa. See on lausa praegult. Me tegelikult tahame sellist asja teha, aga me teeme selle käsitsi niikuinii vanasti. Mul oli see template olemas.
Õpetaja: Ta tahab seda eraldi meetodina teha.
Õpetaja: Las olla siis korraks niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma korra kustutan need kaks rida siit ära.
Õpetaja: Nii see oleks olnud. Ee, niimoodi ja ma näitan, et Meil on siin kett, sõnum mingisugusele rajale. Potentsiaalselt mingisugused parameetrid. Kogu see kett on nagu see osa siin üks osa.
Õpetaja: Ja näete, kuidas meil on sada sõnum. Kui kõik läheb hästi, siis on Denblock Kui midagi. Läheb halvasti, on Catchblock
Õpetaja: If ven Els on Niukene Süsteem on nüüd
Õpetaja: Meie tahame seda käsitsi teha. Mina ei tahtnud templeid teda enam kasutada. Või kui ma tahaks templeid kasutada, siis peaks nad natukene ümber tegema.
Õpetaja: Step by Step. Kohe teeme väikse pausi. Ka. Natukene teeme.
Õpetaja: Me kirjutame aktsiast. Siis esimene asi on vaja vajutada. Tab I. Miks on vaja Tab I vajutada. Siis te näete real. Nelikümmend on minul juba tekkinud Import,
Õpetaja: Import, et mida see sõna aktsias siin koodis mul tähendab, see tähendab seda, et tõmba Librise nagu ligipääs aktsias, mis on veel olemas juba aktsias.
Õpetaja: Kui ise kirjutad selle aktsias välja, import ei tule, siis Ta jääb Aa mingi punaseks alt. Entriga. Pirnikene pakub, et lisaimporti saab korda teha.
Õpetaja: See nüüd on muutuja ja siin taga on aktsiase objekt,
Õpetaja: Temal on meetodid. Kuidas saab meetodeid välja kutsuda? Süntaksi Mõttes.
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab meetodeid? Mul objekt Objekti viide on mul olemas muutaja näol. Kuidas Ma Saan aktsiase meetodeid välja kutsuda. Syntaxiga nagu kirjaviis
Õpetaja: punkt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd temal on siin erinevad asjad.
Õpetaja: Üks on nendest. Geth Üks on nendest post.
Õpetaja: Üks on nendest Ee, put.
Õpetaja: Üks on nendest. Patch.
Õpetaja: Üks on nendest, mida meil läheb vaja praegult. Meil taaskütleb.
Õpetaja: Kui kõik väljad on täidetud bla Blabla, Siis tuleb saata Http sõnum aadressile. Gat Login koos que Eri parameetritega okei. Räägime, sellest ka
Õpetaja: mis. Ma siis siin millise ma valin endast kett, onju Ee, nüüd kett. Juba praegult
Õpetaja: näitab midagi meile siin infot
Õpetaja: Ta näitab siin. No teile ebameeldiv süntaks. Ta pole veel harjunud, Aga ta näitab juba ära, et see kett saab võtta. Põhimõtteliselt. Aa, siit kolm sisendit Üks
Õpetaja: Ei, ole kaks tähendab tegelikult seda laiemaks saab teha või ei saa.
Õpetaja: No, Davai. Paneme selle tabiga ära. Lihtsam niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kui te olete kutsunud juba mingi meetodi välja ja te olete seal nende sulgude vahel.
Õpetaja: Kui te vajutate Control B, nagu parameeters,
Õpetaja: siis ta näitab, et ee, veel tagantjärgi näitab nüüd nagu, et mida see meetod, See. See meetod on ära programmeeritud juba aksuse poolt. Kui ma lähen siia, kukkusin kuskile sisse. Mingisuguse Näete, siin on kõik variants. Vaata, onju See meetod on juba varasemalt ära progetud, onju? Nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd see näitab, et Ee.
Õpetaja: Kontroll B näitab siis, et mida tema sisse niiöelda ootab. Nüüd on siin üks hästi lihtne trikk. Mina küsin esiteks mitu parameetrit tema sisse ootab. Ja kuidas te saate olla surmkindlad selles
Õpetaja: mitu parameetrit Potentsiaalselt see meetod sisse ootab.
Õpetaja: Mitu sisendit saab anda?
Õpetaja: Miks kolm mööda. Vale vastus pakkumib?
Õpetaja: Vale vastus kaks. Okei, kaks mõtlegi, et see on Nüüd väikene häkk. Vaata, Vahet pole, mis keeles te toimetate. Siis Siin on üks hästi universaalne lähenem. Mis Enamus programmeerimis keeltes kindlasti peab. Paika. Kuidas ma tean, et siin on kaks, mille järgi minu jaoks on mingi tundmatu kirjaviis. Ma ei saa midagi aru siin öeldakse. Veel,
Õpetaja: see On see küsimärk Siin Me ei mängi rolli siin küsimärgil. On Üks teine mõte, aga koma on see, mis eraldab ju parameetreid igal pool
Õpetaja: Kui sul on üks koma, siis ma ju tean, et on vasakul pool või üks ja paremal pool teine. Vaata, kui oleks kolma, kui Oleks siin kaks. Ee, seda koma, siis ma nende järgi saan. Kin. Kätte. Vaata, et see esimene on Urlijastring on Nii
Õpetaja: Nüüd see. Pange tähele. Vaata seda. Enne koolonit on muutuja nimi. Nagu see on ka vihje. Seal meetodis on ära programmeeritud. Url võtab siis Urli
Õpetaja: ja seal on ära programmeeritud, Võtab sisse
Õpetaja: ja siin on nüüd see tehtud typescript iga. Ja kui me lähme, vaatame, kus asub see fail siis selle Faili lõpus on ts niikuinii.
Õpetaja: No Cts. Veel mingi alam. Mingi värk type script, et siin on tüübid ka ära määratud selles mõttes, et Mis tüüpi asju saab? Olla
Õpetaja: No, Url peab olema String.
Õpetaja: Nii okei. Mis on teise muutuja nimi? Mis sealt sisse ootab?
Õpetaja: Mis on nimi, Konfig. Mingisugused sätted.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me vaatame, mis on peale seal koolonit, kui teisel on nagu String, siis siin, on mingi Axios ja siis on suur Adi. Mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Kui te näete niukseid suuri tähti juba põhimõtteliselt siis need viitavad justkui klassidele ja objektidele.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et Ta ei oota sinna sisse, sest ringi ta ei oota sinna numbrit. Ta ei oota sinna poole neid, vaid ta ootab sinna sisse. Objekti.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Kui te näete, see tuli. See, kes vähegi on kokku puutunud. See on Niukene. Ja mida see küsimärk seal võiks tähendada? Mis te Arvate? Kurjil ei ole ju kuskil seal muuta? Nime juures küsimärki. Aga Unfigil on
Õpetaja: võibolla see üks suur Küsimärk üldse. Küsimärk, mida tähendab tavaliselt summa. Kui
Õpetaja: see on juba nagu lähemal juba. Vaata sellele mõttele, et mida see küsimärk võiks tähendada, Kuidas
Õpetaja: ei pruugi olla vajalik. Vot väga Hea, kui me nüüd paneme selle programmeerimistirmi, siis on niimoodi. Kas selle Urli juures on? Ee, seal? Ee, küsimärki,
Õpetaja: Siis see tähendab seda et mandatari vajalik, Aga konfigi juures on küsimärk. Selles mõttes, et sa võid, aga ei pea. Ja programmeerimises mõjutaks selle kohta nalle peal,
Õpetaja: et me ei pea seda sisendit kaasa andma, Aga Urli peab
Õpetaja: Sa nagu vasakul. Pool on prmiinimum ja paremal. Pool on valikuline. Kas tahad või ei taha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui me vaatame oma ülesannet, selle teeme ära ja siis, ee, siis lähme teeme pausi ka. Ma arvan, et hakkad väsima vaikselt Ise ka mul häälega ära kaduma. Seda ma tunnen.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina küsin. Nagu Esiteks on seda, et keskendume sellele tüübile. Vaata, sest et ega seda urlima kuhugi kirjutama Ei, pea. Vaid Mis see tüüp on, mida ta ootab siia sisse esimesele kohale.
Õpetaja: Aga tüübina String? No kuidas ma Kirjutan stringi.
Õpetaja: Jah, väga hea. Üksik külak omad.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Mida ütleb taask, mis peaks hull olema?
Õpetaja: Mhmh Ah ja kõik kaldkriips. Login. Kui kõik Haljad on väidatud. Siis saatke Back end ile. Sõnum, get. Sõnum
Õpetaja: Ongi et login on login.
Õpetaja: Ee nüüd sõnum koos query Request Parameetritega see. Veel tuleb otsa. Aga Urli saime vist kätte, on ju,
Õpetaja: on nii
Õpetaja: nii?
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et siinkohal teeme teeme pausi, Ma teen kommitti ka Kes tahab, tuleb Aa vahepeal järgi.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme väikse pausi ja siis ma näitan teile veel midagi, millega me hakkame edasi toimetama.
Õpetaja: Me me Hakkame mängima. Meil On juba olemas.
Õpetaja: Noh, meil ongi olemas.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: see component ligi. Või see
Õpetaja: see ongi siis, kui ma tahan nagu märkida leheküljel. Kus see on siis? Ma pean ikka seal Views seda alati märkima. Ma ei saa nagu komponentides ise panna, et see on ee See ro siin keskeldus.
Õpetaja: Sa Mõtled nagu mingi paigutus vä? No aga paigutus on üldse lihtsalt Csss. Iga
Õpetaja: ee. Sa saad kahtepidi, sa saad selles komponendis endast teha mingeid paigutuse Sätteid. Aa, sa mõtled nagu mudalit nagu täitsa vä. Ja seda saab ka siis see lahendus on teistsugune. Siis ta on
Õpetaja: siis, kui sa vaatad, kirjutad sõna modal, siis ta peab olema. Noh, umbes niukene.
Õpetaja: Nii saab ka teha Jah,
Õpetaja: no siuke küsimus.
Õpetaja: See on ee, vormis.
Õpetaja: Kas ma saan ee, tekitada sellise vaateruma, et ma saan korraga võrrelda kahte koodi, üks Mis ma kirjutan, on Näiteks mingit ee, Noh,
Õpetaja: sama arust koopiat, mis on nagu. Noh, ma ei tea. Noh, näiteks sinu koop. Võtan ette, et ma saan kõrval ise vaadata, Nagu seda saan lüüa ekraanil Niimoodi kaheksa teha saan. Ee, kui see on nüüd kuskilt teisest harust vaata, on ju siin on Nagu see on. Hästi, see oleneb. Vaata, kui ee. Kui sul on niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: minu haarus näiteks. Vaata, on see täpselt sama faili nimi Ja täpselt samas kaustas. Siis on suht lihtne. Vaata, ma võin korra vaadata. Kas ma kellegi teise haru näen? Korra ma teen ära,
Õpetaja: Aa, et sa saad vaadata ühte faili, võrrelda minuga, Aga arvesta ära, et kui mitte, on eeldus, eks?
Õpetaja: No sul ei saa olla nagu minu arvutisse. Nagu Ja ma ei saa. No näiteks, kui sa teed täna õhtul kommiti ära, et tänane töö on sul ühes failis. Mul on Endal ju erinevad arvud, et ma saan. Noh, okei, ma näitan, kuidas saab. Sul on nagu paar moodust. Vaata, onju Aa, kõige lihtsam nendest On siis selline variant, et ma ütlen? Eeldus on see. Vaata, et meil on nagu see fail, mida sa võrdled. Vaata, ma panen korra natukene kokku. Niimoodi on ju,
Õpetaja: et eeldus on see, et see fail, mida sa tahad vaadata. Näiteks see Login View, onju on nii? Minul Kui ka sinul. Ee, täpselt sama faili nimega samas kataloogis asukoht, Lihtsalt vaata, kuidas sa saad siis teha On see? Vaata, et sa teed sellele samale failile. Kas siin
Õpetaja: või sa teed näiteks siin? Vahet pole, onju? Kas sa teed onju teed nagu kliki ja sa saad teha Niukse asja nagu kit.
Õpetaja: Ee, compare with branch or tag. No sind huvitab Branch. Võrdle haru vastu. Nii, nüüd on. Ta võrdleb nüüd seda faili. Vaata selle kliki. Me tegime. Vaata selle faili peal. Ja nüüd ta küsib vaata, et. Oo, mille vastu sa tahad vaadata? Näiteks on ju.
Õpetaja: No ma vaatan, Ma võtan korra praegult siit midagi. Rmt Feb. Seitse näiteks. Ee, Rem vist oli, või mis ta nimi oli? Ee,
Õpetaja: Nüüd Tema nüüd näitab. Nagu kahte faili. Vaata, nooleks on üleval. Tema näitab. Näed, Ee, Sinu oma on siis siinpool. Mina olen õpetaja. Tema oma on siin, kuna siin on nihukesed Highlight Id ja asjad juures, mis nagu üritavad nagu näidata nagu neid erinevusi. See võib silme eest Kirjuks võtta, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga sa saad siit võtta nagu. Maha Vaata selle,
Õpetaja: et sa saad nagu koodi vaadata. Kujuta ette, sina, siin, sa Saad koodi kirjutada. Ka see on sinu arvuti. Aga, ee, näita korra veel seda. Kus sa panid selle esimese? See,
Õpetaja: kus sa selle valiku Tegid menüüs alguses. Kui meil on, oletame, et meil on need Ee, kataloogi. Puu on sama nagu faili pealt et kuhu iganes enda faili peal. See, mida millega mina. Vaata üks sama vaata Kit sellepärast, et sa,
Õpetaja: mhmh.
Õpetaja: Okei, niimoodi. Ja siis sa saad vaadata nagu ja siis Sul on veel võimalus. On ka see. Nüüd see vist eeldab seda, et seda saab teha ainult selle haru vastu. Mis on aktiivne, näiteks Vaata, selles samas harus. Mina olen juba teinud. Ee, kui mitte ka. Vaata, üksjagu onju
Õpetaja: Näed? Ma olen praegu teinud siin. Ee Selles, arus Üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis. No palju Palju ka, mitte, onju? Sa saad ka teha niimoodi. Näiteks et sa teed parema klõpsu. Kit
Õpetaja: ja Nüüd sa ei kompeeri nagu mõne teise haru vastu, vaid sa vaatad hoopis mõne ee vastu
Õpetaja: Compare With Revision
Õpetaja: ja et sa saad nagu vaadata. Need on nagu, põhimõtteliselt. See oli mingi nagu. See on viimane commit Vaadata Sa vaadata näiteks, et. Hei, näita mulle, mis oli nagu Selles failis ei olnudki muudatus. Siis muudatus kahte. Aru Saan ka omavahel võrrelda vä.
Õpetaja: Nagu. Vaata, see on hästi Nagu kontseptsiooni kahte haru saab võrrelda sul On faile nagu lademetes. Vaata, saad aru? Vaata, sul on nagu keeruline kõike korraga. Vaata, sa saad vaadata, nagu, noh, sa saad,
Õpetaja: No sa saad niimoodi. Saad vaadata. No ma ütlen jälle, et see on nagu work around.
Õpetaja: Kui sa tahad vaadata kõiki erinevusi, kui ma Võtan veb, seitse ja master.
Õpetaja: Siis ma lihtsalt klikin. Vaata kogu selle juurkataloogi Peale Aa, ikkagi kataloogipõhine oli.
Õpetaja: Noh, Ja siis ma ütlen, et Vaata Brunchi. Vastu. Noh, Master, näiteks.
Õpetaja: No nüüd, ta tekitab niukse nagu failipuu. Vaata, et näed. Et Ee, praegult. Sul on, ee, niukene asi Ennem seda ei olnud võtab mingi asi, mis on sinine. Näiteks indeks. Aat on veel.
Õpetaja: Algseis oli see, mis on vasakul, on paremal ja saad vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ja jällegi. Vaata, kui need Highlight Id kuidagi segavad, vaid lihtsalt saad natuke niimoodi niisama vaadata.
Õpetaja: Jah, ma lihtsalt. Kui ma tahan ise seda õppida, siis mul oleks hea vaadata, kuidas sa oled kirjutanud, et sa pead natukene niimoodi katsetama, uurima ja proovima leidma nagu midagi, mis sul töötab. Vaata Onju, Ee, et sa saad vaadata harude erinevust. Saad vaadata küll. Jah,
Õpetaja: Ja saad ka. Tegelikult, sa ei saa ühte Asja sa vist väga lihtsalt ei saa. Teha On lihtsalt see, et sa tahad näiteks vaadata kahte erinevat haru ja mingeid erinevaid, kui mitte nendest. Vaata, see võib natuke keeruline olla.
Õpetaja: Ühe variandi veel. Ee, kuidas tegelikult ikkagi saab? Ka ka justkui niimoodi saab teha. Oletame, et sul on? Aa, Võtad näiteks selle lahti. Vaata, onju, Kus näitab Kõike Harusi. Näed, sa saad tegelikult võtta põhimõtteliselt mistahes. Nagu oletame, et sind ikkagi huvitab üks fail korraga See on nagu eeldus. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee, siis on see nagu teostatavam niiöelda Sa saad põhimõtteliselt. Mina olen. Näed õpetaja Feb seitse. Ma võin remoodi alt otsida Või endal lokajalist. Vahet pole, kas ma teen näiteks siin õpetaja lahti?
Õpetaja: Kõik õpetaja, see ei ole kõik Masteri lahti. Otsin mingisuguse konkreetse Comiti.
Õpetaja: Siin on indeks Atmfl Fail. Näed, onju?
Õpetaja: Nii? Ee, korra peab vaatama. Ma ei mäleta peast paremal pool Või vasakul pool. Kumb on? Näed, sa siin on mingi number B Null üks kaks. On mingi
Õpetaja: genereeritud Id. Justkui. Vaata igal komitil on ju, et sa. Ma saan korra vaadata, nagu. Hei, mis siin muutused olid?
Õpetaja: Nii, Ta teeb nüüd jälle lahti. Vaata kaks lehte. Vaata, paremal Pool on ikkagi. Mis siis pärast hakkas olema? Vaata, vist on ju. Ma peast ei tea Ja näed, siin on mingi ära, et sa Saad lihtsalt võtta kogu selle teksti niimoodi. Control a control, C. No teed siniseks. Noh, Copy on ju. Paned selle highlight I üldse kinni? Mis faili ma vaatasime indeks. Aat on veel.
Õpetaja: Tuled? Teed lihtsalt siit sellest projekti sellest lahti. Tahad seda faili vaadata? Mingisuguse suvalise haaru suvalise komitiga sa lähed, Otsid selle muudatuse lahti. Sa teed selle nagu lahti. Sa kopid selle sisu ja tuled siia, teed parema klõpsu ja kompeerid,
Õpetaja: et sul on kaks erinevat koodi.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin on, nagu näitab. Vaata, et kell on siin. Lihtsalt mingid tühikud, et mingit muud erinevust väga polegi. On ju, et et kuidagi niimoodi saab ka opereerida. Vaata aga, ütleme nüüd. Ühe faili kaupa. On nagu enamvähem nagu tehtav,
Õpetaja: kui ma tahaks et mul see kuluarvuti see ideks täpselt samamoodi nagu see kooli arutama Sealt hamburgeri menüüst. See piisab või peaks midagi meelde tegema
Õpetaja: ta nagu Ee, ta nagu enamus asjad suudab nagu ära importida. Aga mingid asjad lihtsalt nagu ei tule üle. Aga, noh, ütleme
Õpetaja: kodus import ja Suures pildis peaks töötama. Väike restart ka ja
Õpetaja: info sees olemas.
Õpetaja: Iga päev. Kolmapäeva punkti.
Õpetaja: Väga hea, kuradi ära vaata.
Õpetaja: Jah, mitu
Õpetaja: kõike, aga kahele
Õpetaja: mingi paar tundi ja tavaliselt pundi kokku ajada.
Õpetaja: Aga ma mängija asju vaata.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt oma pigem Pigem tulevad. Ja
Õpetaja: tere ja. Ja jah, Ee,
Õpetaja: kohe läheb.
Õpetaja: Tere,
Õpetaja: saab mängida?
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: aitäh, ma vaatan. Hea
Õpetaja: ja
Õpetaja: et
Õpetaja: loodan kohe.
Õpetaja: Ja lihtsalt, nagu öeldakse, huvitavad paar korteriühiskonnas kuidas
Õpetaja: tallinna keeles.
Õpetaja: Aa, kurat. Paus läks jälle sisse.
Õpetaja: See on vaja.
Õpetaja: Ee, Screenshare ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma panen nüüd kohe teile slaki Natukene manti Paneme Channel Ka Ee, panen teile ühe faili.
Õpetaja: Ma näitan ka kohe. Teie võite juba seda faili endale alla laadida.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, mina näitan, kus ma Selle sain.
Õpetaja: Ma sain sellest samast ist, et kus ta muidu vormina näitab Kõiki neid. Ee, teenuseid,
Õpetaja: Kõik need teenused, mis meil saavad rakenduses olema.
Õpetaja: Siis Aa, kõik on ära defineeritud. Mis saab tulla sisse, mis läheb välja ja nii edasi ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: aga mina andsin teile selle nagu Jason I kujul, mis tegelikult ongi. Selle standard on Jasonis või? Ml is Ee, üks on natuke teistsuguse visuaaliga
Õpetaja: ja järgmisena, mis Ma soovin, Salvestage kuskile downloads ka osta või kuhu iganes. Tal läheb kohe seda vaja.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui meil lõpuks hakkab olema oma back and Server siis on niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: on olemas üks niisugune liidestus nagu sväger. Sväger on siis see, kes suudab panna nagu koodibaasi pealt, ee kokku Niukse, Ee, teenuste niiöelda. Aa, kõik teenused, mis ta on seal ära progetud. Ja mis tal on? Olemas? Niukse dokumentatsiooni keskkonna kus saab näha. Esiteks,
Õpetaja: mis teenused on? Mis sõnumeid saad? Aga näed ka seda, et mida ta sisse ootab, mida ta välja saadab ja nii edasi edasi ja lisajahüvena on Siis see, ka, et seal saab nagu nuppe vajutada ja siis sõnumeid jooksutada. Te saate testida oma backend, rakendust
Õpetaja: ilma igasuguse Frondita.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt need sõnumite saatmine on tehtud seal nagu lihtsalt, väga, väga mugavaks. Siis Ee, on olemas selline koht. Nagu sväger. Editor,
Õpetaja: Ee, online Variant, editor.
Õpetaja: Annan kohe selle lingi. Teile ka.
Õpetaja: Svage. Reditor on siis online versioon. Sellest
Õpetaja: Ma annan teile kohe siia. Ee, Chat I ka
Õpetaja: Näete, kes ise siin reedel leidnud. Ee, vaikimisi. No, minul. Ta mäletab, et ma olen see Copy based. Midagi aga vaikimisi peaks siin olema Lemmiklooma pool. Mingi pet shop. Näide on nii?
Õpetaja: Mingi Pet shop, bla, bla, bla, tuleb. Ette.
Õpetaja: Mul ei ole praegu siin Streetlights, vä Okei, siis on? Siis on midagi uut. Ühesõnaga, põhiline asi, Mis te nüüd tahate teha, on see, et te tahate teha File
Õpetaja: Importfail
Õpetaja: nüüd otsida Selle sama download i alt Selle sama Aa, mis mina just teile andsin.
Õpetaja: Ja siis tuleb noh, see nii vanadest aegadest ma vahepeal olen seda projekti nime niiöelda uuendanud. Aga siin on niuke asi. Nagu pank. Kolmkümmend seitse,
Õpetaja: Väga vana serverid, mille vastu sõnumid lähevad. Näete Vaikimisi on lokalust. Kaheksakümmend kaheksakümmend. Aga tegelikult siin saab isegi muuta, et saada sellele samast ile. Näete
Õpetaja: nüüd selle? Asja? Ta võib siia tõmmata niimoodi vasakule, Vanasti sai teda täitsa peitu panna. Ka praegu saab niimoodi poole listi. Ma olen natukene muutnud niiöelda.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd kui siit vaadata sisse logimine, Kui teha see niimoodi lahti.
Õpetaja: Täpselt nii nagu teie näete praegu. Sa oled Svagger editor Kujutage ette teie back and süsteemi pealt, ise joonistab niukse veebilehe kokku.
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis teil teenused, mis teil on süsteemis olemas kuvatakse. See on kogu selle asja mõte. Selle mõte on dokumentatsioon, eelkõige Meil on kood ja me tahame näiteks anda oma frontend arendajale, nagu Palun arendage selle süsteemi vastu.
Õpetaja: Siis sa siis, kui sul on seal kõik piisavalt hästi. Ära tehtud, Siis ta genereerib ise niukse. Vaate kokku, Saad Frontendi vennale anda. Nagu palun väga, kõik mees. Toimetasime Svägeriga
Õpetaja: nagu, Noh, tegid mingi uue teenuse. Sa tahad Ise Testida testimise jaoks peab tulema serverisse sõnum.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis see täidab siin kahte funktsiooni Eelkõige ta on dokumentatsioon, Aga kui vahva on see, et saab siit sõnumeid saata. Vahetagi teie ülevalt See korra, Vaatame Ükskord me oleme tõmmanud stoppide kooma Aa, vaatame lihtsalt. Ma panen ülevalt, et saada Stoplid I vastusõnum.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on. Süsteemist Otsitakse. Username Password I abil. Kust see tuleb? See Tuleb kõik sellest Jasonist. Kus see Jason tuleb? See tuleb lihtsalt Siis saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Nii, Ja ta jäta meelde ka, kui te panete selle lehe kinni. Tulete. Tagasi Tal on mingi kukis või mis iganes kuskil tal seal meeles on, onju?
Õpetaja: See põhiline asi on see, et Ta siis kirjeldab Ära Vaata, et. Hei, ee, selline teenus. Otsitakse user, impressor ja veel Kasutad kell. Konto on ka aktiivne. Kui astet ei Leitav visatakse erroriks. Üks, kaks, üks, üks ootab sisse. Parameetreid quer. I Parameeter see. Tähendab rajaväline
Õpetaja: aa. Ta, ei ole osa rajast aa. Username, Password. Võimalikud responsid. Võibolla on dokumentatsioon. Kahesaja puhul ütleb. Aa, okei. Noh, seda ta ütleb niikuinii ja näitab, et saadab niukse vastuse, näiteks
Õpetaja: siis Sa tead, no, fronte enda arendaja praegu. Aa, okei, No sellega arvestan. Siis
Õpetaja: Ja võib ta saata, et midagi on halvasti ja saadab siukse asja.
Õpetaja: Nii kui mina panen, siis see muutub interaktiivseks.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta saadab lihtsalt sõnumi Nüüd Stop Light Iosse. Kaldkriips, Login, sõnum. Noh, tuli vastus, Respons,
Õpetaja: user, Id. Üks head. Meil siin näitab pikalt seda urli.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin on nad sees. Login lõppeb siin ära. Username
Õpetaja: Võiksin võtta kogu selle asja. Siit ja panna Brauserisse, saan jälle Stop Light Ilt vastuse.
Õpetaja: Meie süsteem saadab ka sinna vastu.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui teie, hakkate Backendi ja Frontend I arendama. Siis te teetegi sellises järjekorras. Te võite ära vaadata et kõik, teenused, mis on backendis, vaja, ühele lehele, näiteks Progate rahulikult need backendis ära, on ju? Ja siis te saate hakata progema seda frontend osa.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd see asi on teie piibel
Õpetaja: piibel selles mõttes, et nii nagu see vaade näitab asju. Aa, et. Aa. Siis Selliselt ta see sõnumeid sisse Ootab
Õpetaja: Kui te nüüd Frontend, is hakkate saatma sõnumit, siis see peab klappima. Täpselt sellega. Siin. Refresh I. Et näited läksid eest ära,
Õpetaja: Saate aru? See ongi teie Piibel. Sellepärast, et ootab neid sõnumeid täpselt selliselt.
Õpetaja: Kui midagi saadad saatmisel valesti, siis ta võib öelda. Bad Request.
Õpetaja: Halb, halb, ee, sõnumi. Päring vaata halb päring.
Õpetaja: No Tõmba ma korra siia tagasi
Õpetaja: ja nüüd näitan seda oma ekraanil.
Õpetaja: Et kui me hakkame aktsiasega seda tegema, siis tahaksite seda isegi teha. Te Võite seda teha. Võite ka lihtsalt praegu jälgida.
Õpetaja: Kuhu Me pooleli jäime? Me jäime loo kinni, jäime pooleli. Näete, see akses. Siin on ju login.
Õpetaja: Ma isegi kustutan korra selle ära, et saaks otsast peale alustada. Siin võibolla. Hästi, natuke teen suuremaks. Mis on see teenus, mida ma Tahan sõnumit saata. Sisselogimine, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma teen selle lahti, nimelt siit.
Õpetaja: Ja vaadake, kui te. Kui hästi see nüüd klapib selle aktsiasega, see on Ka põhjus, miks ma ei ole nõus. Nagu Never Evel sellest loobuma.
Õpetaja: Et, ee, mis on esimene sõna, mis ma pean kirjutama, kui me Hakkame lähenema vasakult, paremal, ülevalt alla.
Õpetaja: Mis on esimene sõna, mis ma koodi peaks kirjutama? No, aktsias kõigepealt. Loomulikult Onju Aga nüüd esimene sõna
Õpetaja: Punktkett, onju? Tõmbame kett meetodit, Sest et ma tean.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma olen siin sees. Kui ma valin Control B, siis tema ootab urli. Kas Siit kohe järgneb Url, mida mul on vaja.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja
Õpetaja: aa, siit. Isegi see kopinup Aa vahel töötab Vahel mitte. Aa, nii siin kui ka päris. Aa, selles. Aa, siis Kui meil hakkab süsteemi pealt tegema. Tavaliselt ta kopib ja ta kopib seal Urli. Kui ta töötab, siis Ta töötab. Kui mitte, siis tuleb käsitsi kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Ma panen siia sellest ringi ära ja panin. Control V tuli. Login, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd on Selline asi, et vaadake, et. Ee, see osa on tehtud. No selle info me unustame ära. Nüüd. Ta ütleb, et parameetreid on vaja panna.
Õpetaja: No Kuidas mina saan parameetreid panna on see, et siia saab panna kaks asja sisse. Url ja konfig.
Õpetaja: Konfig on. Vaadake suure tähega meie jaoks. See tähendab alati, et kui ma tahan midagi nüüd siin peale koma sisse panna,
Õpetaja: siis see on mingisuguse klassi objekt.
Õpetaja: See peab päris objekt tulema Sisse
Õpetaja: mäletate? Alg täitsa alguses tegime. Oli objekti loomine Old School. Seda keegi ei tee enam, Kuidas saab teha otse kirjaviisis Literal Object. Kuidas saab teha objekti,
Õpetaja: kui ma panen lihtsalt loogilised sulud?
Õpetaja: See asi teeb juba objekti ja avascripti objekti.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tema eeldab, et Siia sisse tuleb Access Request Object.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et sellel objektil on mingisugused väljad, mis on just
Õpetaja: ära defineeritud seal aktsias Request Confi klassis,
Õpetaja: kui ma Nüüd ütleme nii, et ma ei saa siia nüüd pikalt koodi kirjutada. Siis Mis ma teen?
Õpetaja: Mul on vaja siia igast välja siia kirjutada. Näiteks paranks ja username. Ja
Õpetaja: ma ei saa seda siia kõike ühele reale kirjutada, vaid Ma lihtsalt. Löön entriga alla niimoodi,
Õpetaja: Kui ma vajutan kontroll. Tühik, mis on kanda nagu autocompliit,
Õpetaja: siis ta pakub mulle erinevaid väljasid. Mida see objekt lubab?
Õpetaja: Aa, kui siit alla Scrollida.
Õpetaja: Kas nüüd hakkab midagi silma? Kui me vaatame oma piiblit, mida võiks, mida oleks võiks kasutada params
Õpetaja: näete. No paneb selle B tähe. Ära juba vaata.
Õpetaja: Tema võimaldab niukest välja. See objekt nagu params.
Õpetaja: Kui mõtleme, Sõna on siin. Parameeters
Õpetaja: on params. Vaatasid on vasakut ülevalt kett, Login, kett, login, Params Parameeters. Params on nagu muster. Sama params.
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted siin on?
Õpetaja: Mitmus? Esiteks, see on Jaavascriptio objekt. Siin See süntaks Nagu nii nagu Jasonis ja. Ja veel
Õpetaja: nüüd siia peab tulema mingi väärtus. Aga kuna see on,
Õpetaja: siis ta ootab mitmuses asju, kuidas ma Saan Mitmuses asju defineerida.
Õpetaja: Ei ole komaga
Õpetaja: ja loogilistes sulgudest. Sellepärast, et meil on vaja anda skoop ulatus. No kui kaua tuleb neid mitmuse sassi, onju? Kuskilt ta peab algama või kuskilt peab lõppema.
Õpetaja: Nii, loomulikult jälle siia. Reale, ma nüüd ei kirjuta siia sisse. Ma ütlen juba, ette, et tahame hakata neid defineerima.
Õpetaja: Nii, kui ma panen nüüd siia enter ja tuleme uuele Reale, siis me oleme täpselt jälle oma piiblis,
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ta vajab objekti Params. Ja ta vajab siis, et nad oleks. Need lähevad lõpuks Urli. Saate aru talle pea küsimärki, läheb kogu see kupatus kokku. Aga siin koodis. Me ei kirjuta niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No jah, ma oleks võinud niimoodi ka teha. Vaata, paneme siia küsimärgi ja kirjutada ise, Nagu kusername võrdub ja tekitad siia ühe muutuja, Mis tuleb sisust. See tuleb lõpuks kokku. Vaata,
Õpetaja: lõpuks tuleb kokku tegelikult mingisugune sisu. Saate mõttest aru
Õpetaja: tuleb, aga siin selles voes see niimoodi Ei, käi. Seda sellist konfiratsiooni tehakse Aa, konfigobjekti sees. Näete, me alustasime siit. Vaata, kogu see Asi on konfige. Objekt.
Õpetaja: Headers parameeter. See on igasuguseid asju, mis siin ühel Http sõnumil kaasas käib. Siin. Me saame siis öelda, et et Üks parameeter on meil nimega. Nüüd on Copy Based.
Õpetaja: Copy based. Ee, päris. Vähemalt ei ole. Ütleme, et meil on üks parameeter nimega Username pool on. Ja nüüd anname mingisuguse väärtuse. Mis tüüpi see väärtus peab olema?
Õpetaja: Noh, teeme step by step Paneme praegult ise sellest ringi. Paneme siia. Lihtsalt. Aa, vahet pole,
Õpetaja: Las olla lihtsalt kolm Ad.
Õpetaja: Oleme täpsed. Oleme täpsed ja me oleks pidanud Ko kunagi abielluma koos. Minu naine ei ole täpne.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma teda Kui ma teda parandan, siis ta ütleb. Sa parandad kogu aeg seal. Ta räägib mingit oma, mingi Mingi inimestele jagab mingit Story T ja siis seal mingid väiksed ebatäpsused. Ja ma ei suuda lihtsalt, nagu, et
Õpetaja: ta ütles, et see ei ole üldse tähtis. See lugu on tähtis. Ma ütles, et. Ja. Aga räägiks täpselt see on nagu Timm. Noh, siis ei ole mulle midagi öelda Mina olen täpne.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: mis me nüüd teeme? Meil on olemas põhimõtteliselt siinmaal. Vaata, username ja on väärtus, nagu ma panen nagu Aa, Näete seda mustrit?
Õpetaja: On ju sõnum? Ketsõnum. Loogin login. Parameeters. Params
Õpetaja: nimi. Nimi. Väärtus Väärtus, on ju? Nii
Õpetaja: See on piibel, ai kuidas mulle meeldib akses mõnus nii, aga okei, Nüüd on see kava, et alati kopige. Äkki see enne oli suure tähega?
Õpetaja: Ärge hakake kirjutama, see on nii tähtis. Kõik, mis saate copida, siis kahjuks ei saa nagu Selectida. Aga see nupp aitab kõik, mis saate copida, siis Copige kahte tundi Teenust
Õpetaja: nii tublikaad.
Õpetaja: Noh, et oleks midagi näha. Paneme lihtsalt praegu. Teeme Step by step. Lihtsalt Www.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: see on meie piibel Näe, ma Võtan selle osa. Näed, see osa on aktsiase osa. Sõnumi saatmine on siin.
Õpetaja: Get Url.
Õpetaja: Kui on mingeid parameetreid, siis see saab konfekti sisse minna. See kustutan kõik ära. Uuesti. Näed, see. See siin kontroll B on Konfiga objekt.
Õpetaja: Miks ta üldse neid välju Pakkus on see, et Siia ongi uus objekt, aga siia sobib täpselt niisugune objekt. Kus on siis niuksed välja kasutatud? Mis seal on ära programmeeritud, et saab olla
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd siis korra. Võib juba proovida. Noh, see on võibolla vaatamise koht. Teen lahti oma selle ee rakenduse,
Õpetaja: No kus ta mul on Siin urlina
Õpetaja: sisse logimine kisu nisu. Muudkui hüppab ette. Ma panen meelega mingid muud väärtused. Ma panen siia Xx ja Yk,
Õpetaja: ma teen inspektiga Tuuli lahti, et ma tahan jälgida Network I.
Õpetaja: Ma teen Network isid lahti ja vaatan, et mul. Ma ei taha kõike sõnumeid näha enne Kui ma tahtsin näidata Aa, seda. Ma tahan näidata, mida minu Brauser ise hakkab saatma.
Õpetaja: Minu browser saadab tegelikult selle sõnumi, nüüd kui kõik Väljad on täidetud, kui kõik väljad on täidetud.
Õpetaja: See on truu tullakse siia sisse vastatajale.
Õpetaja: Siin käivitatakse mingi tegevus, mis on aktsiases meetod olemas, Aitan sõnumit.
Õpetaja: Näen, et läks Niuke sõnu. See, mis mul oli sinna sisse hardcoditud status. Kakssada näitab seda, et keegi vastas
Õpetaja: kui klikin siia peale. Noh, Headersist saab näha veel seda, et näed, Läks, Getsõnum
Õpetaja: läks Niukene sõnum. Ma saan vaadata Pay loodi, kui ma ise panen midagi kaasa läksid kaasa? Ee, kandja võtab lihtsalt selle sama asja pilvastaks. Siin on ju Aga kui mul oleks postiga Mingi Jason sõnum kaasa siis Ma näen seda siin, ka mis läks serveri poole
Õpetaja: serveri poole sõnumiga läks see informatsioon
Õpetaja: Preview Ee, Kui on mingi pilt veel, siis ta näitab, aga põhiline on see respons,
Õpetaja: mis näitab mingisugust. Aa, Okei, me responsiga veel midagi. Ma ei tea, mis ta niimoodi Näitab, mind väga ei huvita ka praegult.
Õpetaja: Tõesti,
Õpetaja: Tegirect I.
Õpetaja: Võibolla see, et me ei ole veel ära progenud seda ülejäänud poolt, Aga muidu, ma oleks tegelikult Oodanud. Seda, et kontrollin ülejärgseks.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis mul on kogemata
Õpetaja: bloka. Aa, ta saadab selle sõnumi. Ta saadabki esialgu selle siia. Selle peab ära muutma. Ma ei saa Las ta. Olla. Ee,
Õpetaja: ta. Ta saab vastuse. Ta oleks muidu saanud. Dala, Vaata, ta ei oleks saanud kahte sadat. Ma Ei, saa praegu responsi näidata, Aga ma arvan, et kas on sellepärast, et ma pole seda händinud? Aga see ongi nüüd järgmine osa ka.
Õpetaja: Ma võin korra teha niimoodi. Vaata No ma. Ei saa. Ma pean järgmise osa niikuinii ära programmeerima. Ma ei saa isegi siit mingit Alerti teha. Ee, ennem, kui ma olen ära programmeerinud. Nüüd järgmine osa on siis see,
Õpetaja: kui ma teen lahti uuesti selle Svageri on see, et. Aga mis siis, kui ma panen Cancel ja Cancel reset, et mida tema vastab potentsiaalselt tema potentsiaalselt vastab niukse sõnumiga?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui mul Tuleb mingisugune sõnum. Siis ma pean sellega midagi edasi toimetama.
Õpetaja: Mis on mõistlik nüüd? Teha on? See
Õpetaja: et, me tekitame siis datablokki ühe muutuja
Õpetaja: Kuhu me paneme selle vastuse, mis tuleb sisse?
Õpetaja: No okei, teeme Step by step. No ärme tee veel. Paned siis seda?
Õpetaja: Ee, mis ma rääkisin. See on justkui If Olete nõus? Näete, tema sulud algavad siin.
Õpetaja: Ma kustutan kohe ära. Näed, see on nagu If.
Õpetaja: Nüüd temale. Siit Punktiga saab järgneda. Punkt
Õpetaja: tuleb ka. Sven Catch või Finali Block.
Õpetaja: Me tahame kõigepealt ära defineerida program programmiliselt, mis hakkab juhtuma, siis, kui kõik läheb hästi, Kui me saame vastuse,
Õpetaja: siis me tahame käivitada Ten Blocki. Ma ütlen ta praegu. Tajutasid siia niimoodi alla, et oleks visuaalselt natuke nähtav. Me teeme kõik selle asja ilusamaks ja paremaks.
Õpetaja: Ee in a bit
Õpetaja: siis siia. Sisse. Me saame siis põhimõtteliselt ära defineerida, et mis Peab juhtuma selle sulgude vahele, mis peab juhtuma siis,
Õpetaja: kui tuleb vastus ja positiivne vastus.
Õpetaja: Me võime kohe siia entriga alla panna. Paneme kõigepealt Siia otsa. Paneme. Ka. Catch blokk.
Õpetaja: Pange korra punkt ja siis lööge üksteise alla. Vaata, nad on niimoodi nagu hane Reas.
Õpetaja: Meil on If Ven Else on ju nagu veits. Nagu see.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui meie programmeerime, et mis peab hakkama toimuma, me teeme selle kõik uuesti ja Normaalselt teeme uuesti. Aa, hakkame kohe programmilist mõtlemist tegema. Siis on nüüd küsimus, et kuidas me saame selle sõnumi kätte?
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt meil on nüüd Meil tuleb üks eriline süntaks, mis on lambda? Süntaks on keegi lambda Süntaxiga kokku puutunud.
Õpetaja: No mis seal on põhiline? Väga raske definitsioon. Ma Isegi ei mäleta. Aga kirjaviis lihtsalt
Õpetaja: Ja see on nagu. Aga ma mõtlen, okei, Tavaliselt on ära lahendatud niukse nool
Õpetaja: noolekesega, aga ärge seda Noolekist veel tehke. No kõigepealt alustame seda. Vaata, et me saame kogu vastuse koos sulgede ja karvadega. Saame kogu vastuse
Õpetaja: Nüüd aga see vastus.
Õpetaja: See käib niimoodi ka, et aktsiad. Kõik need sõnumid, mis lähevad teele. By, siin on hästi. Tähtis asi, mis me hakkame mõtlema ka on Asünkroonsed. Keegi teab, mis tähendab asünkroon.
Õpetaja: Ma kordan, ee,
Õpetaja: see tähendab seda, et see on nagu natukene militari terminat. Vaatad, lased mingi ee raketi teele. Mingi lennuk on
Õpetaja: Loodetavasti panka alla ei pea. Oleme näinud.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga on mingisugune lennuk. Vaata, sa paned talle sihiku külge ja oletame, et meil on ju Niukene süsteem, mis? Nüüd, ee. Enam ei vaja seda sihtimist. Mõned süsteemid on niimoodi. Et sa laseriga pead ikka ilmselt jälgima.
Õpetaja: See lennuk on seni kaua, kuni rakett otsib põmm pihta.
Õpetaja: Aga paljud süsteemid on niimoodi et see, rakett ise tegelikult saab aru, et Ee, mida ta nüüd peab pihta saama. Ja siis ta ise niiöelda
Õpetaja: nagu, et ta nagu leiab ta ülesse ja paneb talle selle ära Niiöelda või plahvatab natuke enne seda nii nagu vaja. Seal on natuke niukene asi nagu Fire and Forget. Vaata, et sa tulistad selle ära Ja Siis mees saab ruttu jooksu panna. Vaata, halvem variant. On see süsteem, kus sa pead seal kohapeal veel passima, sest et sa oled Väga haavatav. Sellel hetkel. Keegi teine saab sind tulistada. Siis on ju. See on väga paha lugu.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin võib natuke niukest analoogiat tuua. Vaata, et need ee, asünkroonsed sõnumid on selles mõttes. Fire and Forget on see, et kui sõnum pannakse teele see sama käivitub see aktsiasket,
Õpetaja: See on niimoodi, et Niipea kui see sõnum läheb teele, siis tema nüüd ootab. Aa, tema nüüd ootab promiss Objekti
Õpetaja: proovisobjekt on siis selline Objekt, mis lubab, et, ee. Lõpuks tuleb mingisugune vastus. Isegi siis Aa tuleb vastus. Kui vastust ennast ei tule, siis tuleb see vastus, et ei tulnud midagi Timeout. Näiteks
Õpetaja: ootad seal mingi kakskümmend sekundit seda vastust. Ja siis kuskilt tuleb nagu vaikimis ja ta ütleb, et
Õpetaja: no ei tulnud. Midagi Nagu mõistliku aja jooksul ei tule midagi
Õpetaja: aga, jah põhimõtteliselt, see. On siis nagu see et, sõnum läheb teele ja ülejäänud koodibaas paneb edasi.
Õpetaja: See ongi see, et kui Apollo Kinosse minna, nagu seda avama ja näha, kui palju sõnumid seal teele läheb, kui me peaksime niimoodi, et sa saadad ühe sõnumi ära ja sa ootad. Ootad, ootad, ootad.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuni sa saad käte alles, siis järgmise sõnumi võid välja saata. No siis me ei jääkski seda. Apollo Kino. Ennem saab see film kinodest otsa. Kui see leht laeb,
Õpetaja: sest et see lihtsalt võtaks Kõik niivõrd palju aega.
Õpetaja: Sünkroonne programmeerimine tähendab seda, et käivituvad mingisugused tegevused. Nii pea. Kui sa midagi käivitad, siis tema hakkab ise edasi toimetama ja kuuldele. Keegi jääb seal kuuldele nagu ma saadan sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Ee, hei, hei, vaata, On ju? Ma Ei, tea, ee, soovib mingit infot ja Siis peab kuuldele. Vaata Ootab ära, kuni see info tuleb. Ja kui see info tuleb, siis hakatakse sellega vastavalt programmile edasi toimetama, see mis Seal on
Õpetaja: aga ülejäänud Staff läheb edasi.
Õpetaja: Kõik aktsiuse sõnumid ja tegelikult ka sõnumid on asünkroonsed vaikimisel,
Õpetaja: et me ei oota nagu tulemust nagu Ära Ülejäänud programmi mõttes nagu ülejäänud programm liigub edasi.
Õpetaja: Ma saan kakskümmend sõnumit, kõik korraga teele ja siis on promiss, et kunagi tuleb vastus Ja nüüd on nagu igaüks nendest. Sellest sõnumist on nagu omaette. Nagu väike Niukene. Lõim on võibolla Niuke sõna mida kasutada. Vaata, Niukene,
Õpetaja: et Ee, tema lihtsalt ootab seal ja. Ja kui tõesti vastus tuleb, siis tema läheb. Teen bloki ja teeb, mida on vaja ja teised sõnumid samamoodi. Aga see ei ole niimoodi, et see ongi juba eeldus. Et saaks midagi ju edasi teha, On
Õpetaja: mis? Me saame seal paralleelselt mitte Midagi me lihtsalt kasutajana siis ootame. Võibolla paneme mingi spinneri. Paneme loodima samal ajal
Õpetaja: Ega ei olegi midagi teha.
Õpetaja: No selles kontekstis ei olegi midagi teha. Seni ka ei saagi. Siis ongi võimalik see, et peida kõik ära ja näita Spinneri. Te olete ikka näinud ju loodeng,
Õpetaja: Tavaliselt Kõik asjad käivad nii kiirelt. Vaata, väga tihti Me tänapäeval ei näegi. Interneti kiirus on nii meeletuks. Läinud ja veebilehed on võibolla ka enam Vähem optimeeritud. Niiöelda paremaks ära, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga vahel ikka on ju see, et ju ootad ju? Mingisugune asi, kes läheb heledaks, see on Hea, Kui on mingisugune spinner, mis annab sulle nagu. Noh, Spinner, on See mingi ringi pohvering. Teate, küll.
Õpetaja: Mida? Mida? Midagi, Midagi, mis annaks Nagu inimesele märku. Vaata, et et ta ei lähe hulluks, et ta tahab seda nupuklõpsida, Et, noh, kas ma vajutasin või vajutanud, onju teeme ka mingis. Ja,
Õpetaja: ee, et ta ei saagi midagi teha. Tal ei olegi midagi seni kaua teha. Siin kontekstis. Mõnes Mõnes teises kontekstis. Seal Võib olla Ega selles mõttes ka ega kuidas. Kas kui me läheme siia Apollo kinod lehele näiteks? Vaata, Ega seal ei ole ka ju, niimoodi. Ee, et kogu lehe leht tuleb meil kuidagi tükkide kaupa nagu nähtavale tegelikult ei tule.
Õpetaja: Nad on teinud samamoodi. Vaatad korraks lihtsalt ta Näitab mingit spinnerit või mida iganes või on mingi hele taust või? Noh, see, kuidas sa seda disainilt nagu teed, nagu annad kasutajale tagasisidet, Et nagu, et, noh, info tuleb, onju? On ka lehed, Kus, nagu osa kaupa. Natukene nagu laevad. Vaata, no näiteks. Elronil on niimoodi, et Ülemine osa neilt tuleb kohe ära.
Õpetaja: Ja siis. Sa näed, et siis ta loudib. Vaata andmeid. Noh, ütleme, mis siin ikka, ma Elronit ikka Külastan, kui ma võtan siit Elroni lahti.
Õpetaja: Näed, Tallinna laagri?
Õpetaja: Näed siin mingi spinnar Käib ju Mingi asi. Tuli nähtavale. See on siis Spinner Korraks nüüd tuli. Saate mõttes aru. Noh, et, noh, Kuidas Kuidas keegi oma lehel otsustab, et mida ta nagu näitab? Sellel hetkel, kas üldse midagi näitab.
Õpetaja: Võibolla lihtsalt see sama kuubik oleks võinud lõpuni ka panna. Ju? Vaata, on ju? Aga nemad on niimoodi, teinud et vähemalt ülemine Osa tuli nagu ära infoga ja siis jäi teist sõnumit ootama. No loomulikult, See teine sõna tuleb kauem, kuna see on mahukam,
Õpetaja: see see, ka. Mis järjekorras see siin järjekord ei olegi garanteeritud. Kui mina panen kakskümmend sõnumit teele, vaata, siis Minul Ei, ole. Mitte kuidagi garanteeritud. Millises järjekorras. Nad tulevad. See, et sa isegi paned nad mingisugusele ühel hetkel teele. Vaata või? Noh, nagu tõk. Tõk, tõk. Nagu nad lähevad astmeliselt teele mingi mikro sajandik või Mis iganes
Õpetaja: ikkagi ei ole garantii. Üks jõuab oma internetiga kiiremini kohale teine aeglasemini. Mis protsessi ta seal käivitab, Kui andmemahukas see on üks töödeldakse kiiremini, kui teine. Pole vahet, aga seal ei olegi vahet. Sellel ei olegi. Vahet Lihtsalt on tähtis, et Nad Päeva lõpuks loovad kõik informatsiooni ära.
Õpetaja: Ja kui midagi ei too ära, siis on jälle programmeerimise küsimus. Kas me üldse näitame, et midagi on täielikult katki meie jaoks. Nagu on kas kõik või mitte midagi. Või siis näitame osaliselt mingeid asju ja nii edasi, onju, et see on puhas nagu jälle. Mis me tahame teha? Kuidas me kujutame ette, et meie, süsteem peaks käituma.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd, ee, see Den Block on Siis see siia tuleb, siis tõesti ainult kui on ee positiivne vastus. Catch bloki tuleb kõik nelisada viissada dollarit.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Meil on edaspidi vaja hakata suhtlema andmetega, Vähemalt praegult selles etapis siin. Kui sa tahad viidata mingile objektile ja andmetele, siis mida sul on vaja
Õpetaja: et Sa programmiliselt saaks millelegi üldse viidata?
Õpetaja: Millest ma räägin?
Õpetaja: Noh, nimi. Mis nimi?
Õpetaja: See on vaja uueks seda kohta, kuhu suunata teda
Õpetaja: suunata veel ei ole, See pigem on pigem, kuidas sina olid meelestada?
Õpetaja: Pane R. Lihtsalt. See oleks parem. Ee, rem teel Nime on vaja Aga meie jaoks tähendab nimi.
Õpetaja: Silti meil on muutujat vaja, Aga meil on muutujat vaja Praegu siin, selles kontekstis. Sellepärast, et siin selles kohas
Õpetaja: saab olema lõpuks see vastus,
Õpetaja: siis see süntaks on selline, et me mõtleme lihtsalt nime välja. Ja minule meeldib kõige Mõtle, mis tema ise pakub Ta, Kui ma Panen kontrolltühik Siis ta pakub juba pool süntaksit ära. Me võime kasutada seda,
Õpetaja: et saab selle noole kätte Kontroll tühik.
Õpetaja: Tema pakub ee selle nimeks panna. Välju.
Õpetaja: Minul meeldib pigem
Õpetaja: respons.
Õpetaja: See kõnetab mind rohkem.
Õpetaja: Võiks ka välju olla, aga mulle ei meeldi nüüd see osa Siin
Õpetaja: ongi See siin. Ei, Ei, See Syntax ei ole niimoodi. Aga see on kindel. See loo uus sildikene.
Õpetaja: Nüüd seda sõna letti ei saagi isegi panna ei tohi panna. Kas see on uus sildikene?
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd siis on niimoodi. See siin on. Tee midagi
Õpetaja: selle sildikesega, mis tuleb siit Paremalt poolt. Nüüd, kuidas see töötab, on siis see, et meie loome sildikese tehnoloogia paneb ise siia. Siis selle vastuse külge
Õpetaja: see objekt, mis tuleb Jason. Või mis iganes. See elab nüüd selles selle muutuja taga.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd sellest noolekesest paremal pool on meil võimalik viidata sellele sildikesele Ja teha temaga midagi.
Õpetaja: Noh, võibolla teeme siis niimoodi Step by Step. Ja siin on nüüd hästi tähtis seda aru saada. Näete, me päeva Lõpuks oleme kõik sulgude vahel on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui hakkab mingisugune üle. Mitme koodirea mässamine, et me ei saa lihtsalt siin nagu hästi lühidalt kuidagi midagi temaga teha.
Õpetaja: Siis, Mis me peaksime tegema on see, et me paneme ta eraldi skopi ja nüüd saame selle sama
Õpetaja: objektiga toimetada. Üle Mitme rea
Õpetaja: me praegu teeme? Niimoodi, aga meil kindlasti see. Kogu see asi läheb. Pilt läheb ilusamaks. No mina ei, tea kas te tahaksite seda koodi lugeda. Eriti kui te veel isegi ei mõista, Vaata, mis siin toimub, Nagu onju, mis siin toimub. Nagu Midagi, ei saa, aru,
Õpetaja: See läheb kõik paremaks, Aga minul on tähtis, et me praegu mõtleme, nagu mis toimub.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga see on ainult hetkeks. Selles mõttes ma Ütlen, et, ee. Me proovime ühe korra vaadata. Kuidas on see nagu pikalt. Ja siis me ikkagi vaatame kohe. Vaata, kuidas me nüüd teeme niimoodi, et me suudame ise ka nagu oma mõttelõngaga. Nagu kaasas käia nende asjadega.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, See respons on nüüd siin sees, ma teen Siis praegult. Noh, te võite ka teha. Aga See on nagu vaatamise koht vabalt ka. Ma teen lihtsalt Alerdi
Õpetaja: ja ma võiks panna selle responsobjekti siia sisse Aga sellest ei ole ööd ega mütsi kasu, Sest et ta ei suuda seda stringiks niikuinii teha.
Õpetaja: Ma võin proovida praegult korra, kui ma lähen. Ee, siia.
Õpetaja: Mida iganes ma teen. Nüüd peaks tulema alert ja ta ütleb, et see on objekt,
Õpetaja: aga ta ei oska seda nagu alertist nagu strengiks teha. Kui ma ütlen Siin Jason, Kuna ta on Jaava Scripti objekt, ma ütlen, tee Java Script
Õpetaja: string Iks Stringify ja Panen selle response siia sisse.
Õpetaja: Siis on meil juba võimalik midagi näha. Ka.
Õpetaja: Palun väga, siin on see objekt, mis te Arvate sellest?
Õpetaja: No midagi ei saa praegu aru. Väga, onju? See on liiga suur. Ta on kõik ühe rea peal, kes kopida tohiks siit üldse inimene või? Ei tohi vä. Miks
Õpetaja: Vaatame, et.
Õpetaja: No nii ei saa ka.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, ma tean. Vaadake seda nagu.
Õpetaja: Noh ütleme siis see on nüüd vaatamise koht. Ma tõesti tahan ainult lihtsalt näidata seda. Sisu seal dispunkt.
Õpetaja: Error message, palun. Väga. Jason.
Õpetaja: Jason, punkt Stringify See Sama Respons.
Õpetaja: Ma panen ta korra Rms I sisse. Siis sealt ma ikka saan katta.
Õpetaja: La bla, bla, bla.
Õpetaja: No
Õpetaja: see nüüd on Jason, aga niimoodi, et meil on väga keeruline aru saada, mis siin toimub. Ma teen korra lahti Ee.
Õpetaja: No päev pluss plus plussi
Õpetaja: panen selle siia Asemele Ta on? Jälle. Ta on endiselt kõik Ühel Real Ee Plugin on mul olemas. Ma läks Plugins. Jason Viewer format, Jason.
Õpetaja: Nii, võtame nüüd kokku. Mis siin on
Õpetaja: selles Jasonist? Tegelikult, kus algus on? Nagu niimoodi. Siin on see algus.
Õpetaja: Ma tahtsin I Love optimizing panna. Siin.
Õpetaja: Aa, meil on siin mitu erinevat blokki ja see on kogu vastus. Brauser ju saadab sõrumi. Ta saab ka kogu vastuse, Ta saab staatuse, Sealt ta saab staatust teksti.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta saab näiteks mingid konfigi asjad.
Õpetaja: Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Mingisugused asjad. Request Tour mis me saatsime Siin on mingi palju palju infot. Aga mis meid huvitab? Eelkõige
Õpetaja: on tegelikult see data blokk.
Õpetaja: See data bloki sees on tegelikult siis päriselt See Jason. Kui ma teen korra svägeri lahti, panen siit out
Õpetaja: Selle Databloki sees on tegelikult see asi
Õpetaja: natukene. Juba hakkan kahtlema, sest siin on mingisugune, mis? Siin on Sees Ma Näen ka nagu vist
Õpetaja: midagi. Aa, midagi natukene teistmoodi nagu
Õpetaja: Ja ta saadab samamoodi mulle Html dokumendi, Midagi on ukses aa. Midagi, mulle. Tuleb valesti nagu.
Õpetaja: Ee. Et, ta ei tule vale vastus.
Õpetaja: Tuleb vale vastus Tuleb vale vastus kas. See Ikkagi läheb siia.
Õpetaja: Package on Vanasti on töötanud.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma korra panen serveri uuesti käima.
Õpetaja: Kurat, vanasti See ei olnud sellise süntaks ega suhelda ka, et
Õpetaja: pakunevad Midagi on siin valesti. Ee,
Õpetaja: vanasti on niukest api nagu kaldkriipsu. Ta paneks nagu justkui ette ma korra küsin Ee chatilt,
Õpetaja: Mitte Chat Ilt ee cloud ilt.
Õpetaja: Ütlen, ee.
Õpetaja: Ma teen selle asja ära ma valin selle osa siit.
Õpetaja: Jaa, Controller K Näete, räägin nendest ridadest.
Õpetaja: Kirjutan niimoodi koma. Ma tahan, tahan, et sõnumid läheksid.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Ma ei ole väga hea.
Õpetaja: Midagi valesti.
Õpetaja: Saan oodatud tulemuse asemel
Õpetaja: oodatud, Jason, oodatud data, siis on asemel html. I
Õpetaja: Ee, See on kõik uus. Ee, Ma pean ütlema, et ma ei ole vanasti kasutanud, aga on vajalik kasutada. See on uuem ja kiirem ja parem. Ja see konfig on kuidagi valesti.
Õpetaja: Probleem On selles, et lõppu mida ma ei soovi. Stoplight ei tunne seda ära. Ta kas tahab Html I vaba vabale. Mis ma siis tegema pean? Ee, lahendus.
Õpetaja: Ee, reegel. Appi targetu.
Õpetaja: Ma Küsin miks ma. Miks ma. Ei, kas ma. Kas ma saaks lihtsalt. Kas ma lihtsalt saaks eemaldada?
Õpetaja: Ei, nii lihtsalt ei saa. Mis asja, Mis See on, ah?
Õpetaja: Noh, miks sa kohe ei öelnud?
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, segane Minu jaoks on ee. Ja siin ma paneks serveri uuesti käima isegi.
Õpetaja: Aa, sellepärast, et. Ee, see Minu meelest.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis juhtub.
Õpetaja: Vaatan korra veel. Kas ta midagi ütles veel siin? Senikaua nii prefiksi, Millega ta tuvastab. Millised päringuid suunata?
Õpetaja: Jah, pikas perspektiivis Olekski. Hea, kui rakenduses oleks Ka see api nagu pekendis. Me saame seda teha pärast Nii,
Õpetaja: aga see on slaid päring. Päring, arendusserveri Lihtsam on ikkagi.
Õpetaja: Okei, vaatame, Kui see töötab, siis mind, ei huvita see Fancy Fancy lahendus, Mis ta tahab?
Õpetaja: Ee, proovime nüüd uuesti.
Õpetaja: Mhmh,
Õpetaja: oi, mis nüüd on?
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd ma saan aru. Ma tahan minna rajale, aga ma ise Saan mõttes aru. Vaata mis ta tahab. Ee, ma kirjutan
Õpetaja: lihtsalt right ise mulle
Õpetaja: ta. Mul on nagu raske seletada seda praegu, et ma väga ei soovi seda ka teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, Las ta teeb selle valmis. Ja ma annan lihtsalt. Kas ka Copy based Ina, nagu kui ma saan selle tööle. Aa, kuidas ta seda tegema peab?
Õpetaja: Nii jah, halloo.
Õpetaja: Noh, teeme. Näed, ta isegi ütleb ära, et ee, see hotelli lood ei tohiks töötada Nii, Vaatame, kas läheb tööle nüüd või mitte. Refresh
Õpetaja: Nii et ma panen mingisuguse suvalise asja siia. Sisse Login dispons,
Õpetaja: mis Sa oled
Õpetaja: Aa. Okei, Davai, ee, kurat. Ma pean siis muutma. Stoplight e
Õpetaja: davai. Teen praegult hästi prostat. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: pärast. Ma üritan uurida, kas ma Saan kuidagi teha seda üle projekti?
Õpetaja: Tal on. Vaata, see. Ma Nüüd räägin. Kuidas Milles see konks? On. Ma võtan mingisuguse pildi appi
Õpetaja: Ee, pildiks sobiks siin kõige paremini materjalide alt.
Õpetaja: Ma isegi vanasti veits mõtlesin. Et huvitav, kuidas ta aru saab ja nüüd ma saan aru, et ta. See ei olnudki tegelikult väga Okei,
Õpetaja: ee, pildid, pildid.
Õpetaja: Vaata korra, Mis siin. Ee,
Õpetaja: ahah.
Õpetaja: Mäletate seda? Ma rääkisin teile seda, et Ee,
Õpetaja: kui frontend paneb kõik asjad kokku, aga tal veel andmeid ei ole, siis ta tagastab põhimõtteliselt kogu Html I arvutisse kasutajale
Õpetaja: kogu pakk, Nagu mingi.
Õpetaja: Ja mis nüüd toimub, on see, et kui nüüd siit kasutaja arvutist hakkavad Aa minema. Niiöelda sõnumid, mis on mõeldud tegelikult Back end Ile,
Õpetaja: siis Lahendusi on erinevaid. Üks variant on see, et ee, sõna otseses mõttes front Endist läheb sellest vabandust kasutaja läpakast. Läheb See Sõnum otse
Õpetaja: nagu õigele serverile. Back Punkt com.
Õpetaja: Teine variant On see, et ta tegelikult sõnumina See sama. Sõnum, mis on mõeldud back end Ile tuleb niiöelda siiski front and serverisse sisse. Ja Front and server ise. Redirect Ib Selle Niiöelda. Backendi võtab vastuse ja annab tagasi ehk Siis see suhtlus käib läbi Front and serveri.
Õpetaja: See meie projekt ongi niimoodi tehtud.
Õpetaja: Temal on nüüd võrreldes varasema lahendusega ta sai väga hästi aru, kui ma saatsin. Mingi sõnum on sõnum ka. Kaldkriips. Login
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas on tegelikult tark ja kaval ja praktiline teha on seda, et Back end is. Kõik urlid algavad. Mitte kohe
Õpetaja: on ju vaid on
Õpetaja: ee kaldkriips appi. Login, sest et siis need urlid on erinevad. Ja Kuidas tema? Kuidas see nagu see taustal seal voel töötab, on see, et kui nüüd tuleb meie niiöelda kasutaja Brauserist, tuleb sõnum, mis tegelikult tahab andmeid saada. Back end Id.
Õpetaja: Kui tema saadab. Vaata appi, kaldkriips. Login siis tema nüüd teab, et tegelikult see sõnum on mõeldud back end ile ja ta suunab selle sõnumi edasi.
Õpetaja: Kui seda erisust ei ole, siis ta lihtsalt mõtleb, et sa tahad, teha, et see brauser Saadab sõnumi, et anna mulle loo kinni. Niiöelda see pealeht Html. Kas te saate natukene mõttest aru?
Õpetaja: Ta ei saa aru, mida ma tahan Ta Ta kogu aeg mõtleb, et ma tahan saada. Lihtsalt anna mulle loo kinni. See sõnum saab Vaata, kaldkriips. Login kaldkriips, login. Ta kogu Aeg üritab mulle anda. Nagu. Palun, väga, siin on su login vaade. Ta üritab seda asja teha, arusaamata, et tegelikult see on juba praegult See olukord,
Õpetaja: kus me tahame saada andmeid. Back end ilt. Kuidas mina kavatsen selle asja nagu korda teha, on see,
Õpetaja: et ma lihtsalt läksin praegult siia sellesse. Ee,
Õpetaja: on tehtud ka nüüd. Niimoodi. See klassirahade värk on see, et Backendil kõik urlid algavad kaldkriips appi, sest see on mõeldud backend server.
Õpetaja: Sest et siis, kui tuleb see sisse. See sõnum. Kaldkriips, Api kaldkriips. Login siis fronteng server teab, et see ei ole minule.
Õpetaja: See on hoopis Back end ile ja ta suunab kohe õigesse kohta.
Õpetaja: Saab ka tegelikult niimoodi progeda, et sa proged kohe sinna koodi sisse. Vaata, et su Brauser saadab kohe, Aga noh, see on nagu keerulisem lahendus. Ee, milleks seda keerukust? Seega mina proovin ikkagi niimoodi, et Ma ütlen nüüd talle, niimoodi, et Kuule,
Õpetaja: tee niimoodi, et kõik, mis lähevad, tuleb kaldkriips appi.
Õpetaja: Aa, tuleb. Aa siia. Sisse.
Õpetaja: Ta teab, et Nad lähevad sinna. Ja nüüd ma arvan, et me peame niimoodi tegema, et see, kus sa Url on,
Õpetaja: kus meil see sõnumi saatmine oli, Siin
Õpetaja: ma ise. No see on. See on see koht, kus ma üritan ise tööle saada. See on tehniline värk. Lihtsalt praegu
Õpetaja: tehniline värk, Kui ma saan selle tööle loo kin iga
Õpetaja: siis edaspidi. Me teeme niimoodi, et on see url, aga alati on see api ka ma Nüüd Ei tea, kas ta paneb topelt või mitte. Ma ei ole õrna aimu, kuidas need asjad töötavad, sest et see voe projekt on muutunud. Vahepeal
Õpetaja: see see, kuidas ta vanasti oli. Ta enam ei ole nagu päris
Õpetaja: Proovime siis uuesti. Ee, Frontis. Lähen loog Indo ajale
Õpetaja: nüüd Praegu see oli tema jaoks, et Anna mulle palun Frondi vaade.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd tuleb uus sõnum,
Õpetaja: siis ee. Nüüd on mul ära programmeeritud, et Aktsiast saadab kaldkriips ja tema peaks nüüd siit teadma selle ee järgi, et ee. Minul on see mõeldud seda, et kui tuleb kaldkriips appi, Siis nad lähevad sinna. Stop Light I.
Õpetaja: Need ei kuulu meile. See peaks nii töötama teoorias. Ee, ma arust panin
Õpetaja: ja juba näen, et tuli, Sest et nüüd, kui ma panen siia, panen respons.
Õpetaja: Näete,
Õpetaja: ma nüüd sain selle korda. Ee, siin on midagi väga palju ei pidanud siis tegema. Siit seda vite Konfige pole vaja vajutada. Ainukene asi, mis on vaja ette kirjutada, On see kaardkriips Api? Saate mõttes aru.
Õpetaja: Ee, Niimoodi saab tema aru ja nii on normaalne. Nii on normaalne. Ma ütlen, kui muud projekti tegin. Minu teadmised kogu aeg täienevad, eriti frontis
Õpetaja: Aa, et tegelikult Aa on põhjus, miks tegelikult veel tahaks veel kasutada veel niukest asja. Ma räägin ka seda hästi kiirelt vahele veel, et Kasutatakse veel niimoodi, et ta on appi Ja siis tuleb näiteks siin V. Üks.
Õpetaja: See võimaldab teha seda. Vaata, et kui tehakse mingisuguseid ee, Muudatusi süsteemis. Back End is muutub mingisugune loogika.
Õpetaja: Ja mida me ei taha teha, on see, et me. Meil on toimiv, toimiv kood toimiv lahendus.
Õpetaja: Tema istub kogu aeg vaikimise alguses Ee V, üks V, üks V, üks. Kõik rajad hakkavad V üks.
Õpetaja: Me tahame teha mingi uue lahenduse. Aga me tahame teha niimoodi paralleelselt väga lihtsa. Vaevaga on ka vana lahendus endiselt veel elus.
Õpetaja: Siis me saame teha juurde nagu sinna Back and serverisse ühe uue, Kus kõik rada on? Sama. Aga seal on V kaks.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd me saame võtta niimoodi vaikselt salaja, nagu Seal Ta lõppkasutaja ei tea sellest üldse mitte midagi. Me saame võtta kasutusele niiöelda selle uue. Niiöelda versiooni. Me kuskil mingisugused asjad ümber vaata, Et kui sina lähed andmeid tooma, ära mine enam see vee Üks vaid Mine hoopis vegaks
Õpetaja: teenuse pihta.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ta mingi ajal töötab, toimib. Vaatame, et see kõik see, nagu normaalne midagi katki kuskil ei lähe. Ja võibolla vaatame ka mingist jõudlust. Ja Performance It.
Õpetaja: Meil tekib Mingi kindlus, et see asi töötab, Siis me saame lõpuks kustutada selle V ühe ära või teha niimoodi, et see uus teenus hakkab ka olema nagu V. Üks, aga lihtsalt on paralleelselt mingisugused. Niiöelda end point Id,
Õpetaja: mis on nagu dubleeritud, aga lihtsalt üks on mingi uue loogikaga Või mingi mingisuguste parendustega. See on selline olukord, kus ma ei julge nagu seda vana asja veel nagu päris nagu ära kustutada,
Õpetaja: soovime, et See tal on olemas. See toimib ühe nupu vajutusega. Saame neid asju Switchida, kui veel vaja.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, kui tundub mingisugune konfidents, tuleb, siis tehakse eraldi taask Vaata, et korista see vana asi ära. Uus toimiv lahendus on, et et tihtipeale. Kui te näete neid urle, vaata siis nad Juba algusest saati ei olegi. Va Backendi urlid ei ole kõik api Kaldkriips vaid on api. Kaldkriips, V, üks ja Nii edasi saate mõttes aru,
Õpetaja: et siin on nagu mingeid selliseid nüansse ka
Õpetaja: saime selle tööle. Ma ei tea, et saate ka proovida.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kas ikka Saime tööle, et kui te tulite, panite selle. Oota seda nüüd. Ei, tule. Kui te tulite, panite selle kaldkriipsuapi ette,
Õpetaja: et siis kas teil töötab. Ja kuidas te saate seda kontrollida? Ee, mina võtan nüüd selle tobeduse siit ära.
Õpetaja: Aa, midagi ma kohe. Ma kohe teen. Vaata midagi, Ma pean responsega tegema. Siin lihtsalt niisama kaskasin mainima. Aa, ma teen komite ära. Tahate järgi tulla?
Õpetaja: Väga palju ei teinud siin ju, aga Okei,
Õpetaja: ee, midagi ikka tegin ka. Kui ma ütlen buss, ma oleksin teadnud, et seda isegi teha.
Õpetaja: Aa, tööle ta hakkas,
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, Kas Ta hakkab, ee, kisama, et mul on lihtsalt üks muutuja, mida ma midagi teed, aga.
Õpetaja: Ja te mitte kuidagi muud moodi praegu seda ei näe.
Õpetaja: Vaatasin ennem Network i all. Mulle tundus see asi juba väga,
Õpetaja: sest ma ei näinud response ja ma nägin seal Html, I, Kus see vastus tuli?
Õpetaja: See tuli Stoplight ist.
Õpetaja: Ma täna proovin seda hiljem vaadata. Kas ma saan teha niimoodi? Vaata, et see kaldkriipsuapi on Osa kõikidest nendest teenustest, mis siin tulevikus tuleb ja teha selle nagu korda
Õpetaja: viitsiks igale teenusele seda ette kirjutada, Kuigi neid nii palju siin Ei ole
Õpetaja: ee. Kuskil. Kindlasti saab seda teha ka nagu üleüldiselt.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, võibolla siit saaks seda teha.
Õpetaja: Ei,
Õpetaja: kaldkriips. Abi Saite juba proovida? Keegi
Õpetaja: töötas. No peabki töötama, kui selle Fia I paned. Aga nüüd ma teen ee, väikse muudatuse siin ka ja saate kohe öelda kas see endiselt töötab.
Õpetaja: Kus see rada nüüd on? Login,
Õpetaja: aga ma siin ei näe seda.
Õpetaja: Aga kuskil ennem ju nägi ka rada. Vaata või ma Võtsin selle eest ära. Ma panen
Õpetaja: ma korra vaatan. Ee, siin on mingi megakaua. Võtab aega. Pead ootama siin üleval
Õpetaja: Ee, ma vaatan korra, Kuidas Ta näitab projekti Urlli Näete nüüd projekti. Urlil on ee. See api otsa liidetud ise,
Õpetaja: et see tähendab seda. Ma ei pea kõiki käsitsi neid ee muutma, et kui ma nüüd tulen ise ka siia ja vajutan, login
Õpetaja: läks ka katki. Jah,
Õpetaja: aga ma ei ole veel Endiselt kindel. Ma korra vaatan. Ee, veel seda. Kui ma teen ikka Refresh I. Kuidas ta näitab seda
Õpetaja: valide bla, bla, bla.
Õpetaja: Ma proovin siin siseselt. Äkki on siin. Mingi
Õpetaja: Okei, tema jaoks on ikkagi see beef. Nagu, et et see on osa urlist.
Õpetaja: Kuule, aga mul on Üks mõte, kas? Aga mis siis, kui ma üldse võtan siit selle ära? See on proovimise värk. Ära
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma tulen, panen selle siia otsa.
Õpetaja: Nii, panen Uuesti korra käima. Ma korra proovin. Lihtsalt Oleks nagu lihtsam, kui ei pea uuesti kogu aeg panema,
Õpetaja: Ei täpselt. Ei tea, kuidas see asi siin kokku Mängib.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma teen refresh ajaks. Ah, ma ei teinud refresh. I Ma ei tea või see Oli viga.
Õpetaja: Ee, Refresh. I oleks võinud ära teha.
Õpetaja: Panen siia mingi bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Saadan sõnumi Noh, bingo ja vale tulemus,
Õpetaja: Sest et siia ei lähe seda kaasa. Aga ma panin ju siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, okei, okei, okei. Ee, see ikkagi niimoodi ei käi
Õpetaja: sellepärast et ta ei Tabone, oota. Ma vaatan korra, mis mul siin login. Views on.
Õpetaja: No aga võiks justkui töötada, ja nagu ma ütlen, et sellest Põhi kurdist. Ta saab selle punktapi kätte.
Õpetaja: Teed sõnu, mida võibolla isegi ta ei saada. Vaata, Ma ei näinud siin appi. Minul oli Niuke. Tunne, et see asi ikka ei töötab. Kas ma nüüd vaikselt uuesti käima ei pannud?
Õpetaja: Vajutasin, onju nii? Teeme siis puhtalt, Ma võtan uuesti lehe. Võtan Bank
Õpetaja: ka Ütleme et aega, nüüd kulub selle tehnilise jama peale.
Õpetaja: Nüüd üldse ei taha midagi ette tulla. Seal püsti on Vä,
Õpetaja: ee. Ma ei näe midagi taustal. Inspect Netvärk
Õpetaja: ei lähe kord selle rajaga, mis ma siin pakkusin.
Õpetaja: Okei, no millega me siin ikka Siis nagu jaurame, võin homseks vaadata mingit, kas saab nagu mingit üldist lahendust või mitte,
Õpetaja: Ma siis praegult teen, niimoodi nagu sind kenasti oli Ja me teame, et töötas, sest sõbrad ei vääri. Küünlaid
Õpetaja: On vaja siin toimetada. Mitte. Mingi.
Õpetaja: Ee, jebida sellega See on kus Kohas Aa Siin oli? Jah ja. Aga
Õpetaja: ta suudab sinna, Kui ta läheb, appid. Ja kui sa sealt loginist ära võtsid appi, siis ta ei saa.
Õpetaja: Ei, No ma teangi. Ma võtsin siit ära. Vaata, aga mul oligi plaanis. Nagu see siit eemaldada ja panna see nagu see üldisesse konfi, Vaata, nagu, et iga kord, kui sa annad sõnumi appi, vaata, siis Tähendab, iga kord, kui läheb välissõnum, siis ta keevitab kõigepealt selle,
Õpetaja: kuidas
Õpetaja: No teeme uuesti. Vaata On, ju kui ma tahaks, et igal sõnumil läheb kaldkriips appi, siis mina näen. Vaata, et see läheb igal juhul algusesse. Ja siis järgneb see, mis tuleb siit sellest sõnumist. Siit Ma koristan selle ära,
Õpetaja: on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga Aga
Õpetaja: nupu vajutusega käivitub log, In Mis peaks käivitama selle meetodi. Vaata, see peaks ka enda niimoodi töötama, Et kui mina saadan sõnumi,
Õpetaja: siis tema nagu tuleks siia sellesse põhimõtteliselt saadab selle sõnumi nagu niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Sinna, sisse, sinna. Kui sa nahvi teed, Palun
Õpetaja: Jaa, aga Aa. Ja. Ja see on nukini saba lahti, ma Saan aru Jah,
Õpetaja: Ta oleks ja okei, Ja ta ei lähe lost, I vaid ta. Ta tahab sellele lehele minna. Lihtsalt login, Okei, ma Sain aru, see on täiesti loogiline. Loomulikult, sest et tema reageeribki selle peale. Vaata, see sõnum, mis niiöelda tuleb serverisse sisse meie enda serverisse, Tal peab olema see, See osa.
Õpetaja: Aga mul on plaanis. Kuidas me seda lahendame? Teisel moel Ära See tegelt ongi. Natuke teistsugune lahendus, kui See, mis mina üritasin siin niimoodi konfiga Konfigiga niiöelda mässata.
Õpetaja: Aga vähemalt ta töötab mul nüüd siit niimoodi, et ma ei pea eraldi panema, ma Ei, pea kõiki neid teenuseid hakkama muutma ja panema. Kas selles Ee Stop light is Vaata, et iga teenuse ees on punkt appi, Vaid see on nagu osa osade, Ma arvan, Selle ma saavutasin ja teise asja saavutama. Homme ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, aga okei, Ma panen fordele Avokaado ühe korra veel käima.
Õpetaja: Aa, praegu siis ajutiselt. Praegult ajutiselt. Jah, me siin on niuksed. Üldised säted. Mida sa saad teha, Vot see ongi. Vot nüüd tuleb välja vahe aktsiuse ja aktsiusega. Sa saad niuksed asjad üles sättida nagu
Õpetaja: Aa vahelt. Lõika iga kord, kui läheb teele mingisuguse aktsia sõnum,
Õpetaja: siis mina saan öelda. Vaata, et ennem kui voe selle sõnumi välja saadab ennem kui ta selle välja saadab,
Õpetaja: Aa, siis Ta paneb ta interessektoris. Ma saan nagu ära defineerida, et tee mida iganes. Nagu selles mõttes üks asi on, see, kuidas ma saan manipuleerida, on seda, et ma saan seda urli manipuleerida. Öelda et pane saatmisel punkt appi ette igale sõnule.
Õpetaja: Aa, ja seda ei saa teha vähemalt Minu teada ma ei ole kindel. Aa, et see on nagu see. Pluss selle tehnoloogia kasutamisega. Kas me saime selle asja tööle?
Õpetaja: Ee, selles vaatevõtmes, et kui ma tulen looga kinni.
Õpetaja: Noh, Maru Aeglane, aga midagi nagu toimub.
Õpetaja: Aa, aa, Saadan sõnumi. Login.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis nüüd, mis mulle meeldib. Kõik töötas juba. Ja,
Õpetaja: noh, see on see, et oli, vaja näppida vä?
Õpetaja: Mis mul siis Ee. Valesti on?
Õpetaja: Töötas võtame veel, ei tööta,
Õpetaja: aga üsna responsi saab responsible. Entity.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea isegi, mis see tähendab.
Õpetaja: Helilood Dispons.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Nii nädalavahetusel kodutöökoda.
Õpetaja: Jah, oled suusan Facebook,
Õpetaja: Sest et. Aa. Okei. Kas mul kordagi töötas mul kordagi? See töötas. Kui see ei olnud osa, ei töötanud vä mitte kordagi, siis töötas,
Õpetaja: See on nagu nii Okei. Siis ma teen ikkagi niimoodi. Et Vaata, on ju, et. Ee.
Õpetaja: Ahaa,
Õpetaja: oota.
Õpetaja: Kas nendel kaelaadressil on erinevust esimene Ja kolmas
Õpetaja: on küllalt Jah,
Õpetaja: okei, aga ma nüüd arvan. Korra nüüd proovin. Vaata, see on päris nagu justkui see siin peaks olema see Ma ei ole, Ei, mina ei anna alla niimoodi. Nii need asjad ei käi.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi need asjad. Ma ei hakka kaheksa korda sinna upit, Nagu ometi niimoodi. Need ei käi.
Õpetaja: Aga siin ta ei paku rohkem kui ainult siin. Nagu
Õpetaja: ehk siis hakkan ikkagi nii tegema.
Õpetaja: Hops,
Õpetaja: nii, Ma võtan lihtsalt ruttu. Panen selle loo kinni. Oli ennem, onju nii Ma panen ruttu teistele ka ära, sest et, ee, vahel tuleb lihtsalt Ee, nagu nõustuda,
Õpetaja: et lihtsalt on nii. Ei ole mingit D vaja taga ajada. Vaata, Oi, oi, kuidas pidin tööd tegema?
Õpetaja: Eraldi taask oleks selle jaoks vaja Kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Muudatused süsteemis.
Õpetaja: Nii, Publishing.
Õpetaja: Liisa, hakka tööle nagu sa ostad.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: tõmbasin selle ka siin mingi juhtme koomale. Kurat, Yes, Publish Nii kodutoks siit kadus ära.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma korra proovin lihtsalt sõnumit saata selles režiimis. Et Ee, Kas ta siin töötab Niiöelda Siin töötab bla, bla, bla, Blabla töötas juba teil ka seal ja. Okei, no siis on väga hea. Oota Kus mul ka töötab?
Õpetaja: Mul on äkki Minu arvates see töötab. Ma panen selle sama sõnumi teele.
Õpetaja: Näe, juba läks läbi ja respons tuli õige asi. Okei,
Õpetaja: ee, kui mitte, ärme Näpi rohkem midagi siin. Ee, Lepime praegult sellega, et. Ee, siis niimoodi on nii? Aga nüüd on siis see sisuline, pool, et me tõestasime ära, et see tegelikult töötab. Me saime seda juba läbi. Siis Network I. Vaadata. Aga nüüd on. Siis tuleb see.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Tuleb Jälle see Piibli värk.
Õpetaja: Homme annan teile uuendatud piibli ka. Kus on need rajad? On olemas niiöelda.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd on niimoodi, et, ee, meil on vaja siiski natukene rohkemat teha, kui
Õpetaja: kui lihtsalt seda ma ütlen. Praegu ei tee selle objektiga midagi.
Õpetaja: Demo, mis on selle muutuja eluiga. Mis te Arvate, millal ta sureb? Mis reaal on? Ta kutupiilu.
Õpetaja: Ta töötab ainult reaalsure. Siis Real Kuuskümmend. Ee, viis,
Õpetaja: Jah, Kuuskümmend viis, kuuskümmend, kuus. Vahet. Pole. Kuidas seda tõlgendada, on ju? Praegu on niimoodi, et tema tekib siin see sildikene.
Õpetaja: Ja kuni selle skoobiga, kuni siia alla paned, tegelt Noh, põhimõtteliselt selles sulu sulu mõttes. Vaata, siis ta sureb ära. Aga meil on vaja tegelikult seda kuskile salvestada hoida, et oleks meil igatepidi alles Ja võibolla jagada mingi teiste meetodite vahel ka. Mis mõtted siin on,
Õpetaja: Kui ma ütlen, et tahaks seda kuskile salvestada, et ta ei Kao ära. Me oleme näinud, et mingisugused asjad siin elavad väga hästi.
Õpetaja: Teeme muutu. Ja kuhu?
Õpetaja: No see juba siin on Muutuja Vähemalt siin Skoobis on. Aga siin ta sureb ära, onju
Õpetaja: No kuidas sooviks, kuvada mingeid andmeid sealt mis ma kätte sain. Mis ma siis vähemalt teeksin, datablokk
Õpetaja: Nii Ja nüüd hakkab meil siin selline süsteem, mis tegelikult on meile super hea abimees.
Õpetaja: Esiteks on meil vaja mõelda välja mingi nimi,
Õpetaja: Mis me selle muutuja nimeks paneme? Kui me sisse ee, logime Ja siis saame niukse responsi,
Õpetaja: mis võiks olla selle muutuja nimi
Õpetaja: ja aga Võiks olla natuke lihtsalt parem kui respons.
Õpetaja: Login, respons ja tegevus.
Õpetaja: Login
Õpetaja: nii. Pool. On Nüüd, mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: No ma võiks panna Ja tegelikult ülikava. Mida sa siia kirjutad? Sellepärast me teeme korra koodi osa natukene ära ja siis arutleme edasi. On ju see plaan? Kas vastab tõele. See plaan oli ju see, et me paneme ta kuskile elama. Kuhu andmed jäävad. Ehk siis see sama niiöelda muutuja selle külge Tahame panna põhimõtteliselt objekti siit. Seest on nii.
Õpetaja: Ma korraks tegelikult. Ee, võibolla. Jah. Okei, nüüd ma saan natuke. Rohkem meelt ka. Mäletate, ma Näitasin seda Jasonina. Vaata, siin, tata sees. Siin tata Sees saabki olema see sama. Jason. Ma vaatan, kas mul see kuskil. See vite on veel lahti Ka sellisel Kujul
Õpetaja: Networkiga on juba läinud. Aga vahet pole. Võtan selle sisu korra siit responsist. Nii see mõte on see, et Kogu vastus on response.
Õpetaja: Kogu vastus on response.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see asi, mis meid huvitab, ei ole kogu respons vaid siit seest data,
Õpetaja: sest data Sees on see, Jason. Kus on siis need väljad ja väärtused, mis meid tegelikult huvitavad?
Õpetaja: Panen korra Need Tegelikult läheks veel omakorda. Noh, kui panna niimoodi. Hops, hops, hops. Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Need teised asjad meid tegelikult üldse ei huvita. Konfig ja asjad. No siis, kui just huvitab Näiteks võibolla staatus huvitab ja nii edasi. Kogu see sisu on hetkel response sees.
Õpetaja: Nüüd meie tahame teha niimoodi, et me tahame võtta ainult selle data bloki
Õpetaja: sisu ja panna, Sest need muud asjad meid ei huvita.
Õpetaja: Siis me kirjutame niimoodi siia Samma kohta. This
Õpetaja: l log in Response tab. Ütleme, et sina saad uue sisu.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me ütleme, kus kohast sa selle saad. Ütleme response seest.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd siit. See on Kogu response koos sulgede ja karvadega Siit Seest mida me tahame,
Õpetaja: Data osa, siis Kuidas me saame sealt? See on tavaline Jaa, jaoskripti objekt, Punkt,
Õpetaja: Vot jaa. Näete. Ta juba pakub ise meile ette, et mis väljad siin saavad olla,
Õpetaja: Sest et ta teab, et see response kogu Objekt on selline ja seal sees on alati, sest et see on Http protokolli standard
Õpetaja: Siit Meid huvitab see spons data, kui me tahame staatust.
Õpetaja: Palun. Väga.
Õpetaja: Staatus. Mitte tekst, vaid näed siin paremal. Pool näitab tüüpi ka on. Näed, staatus on meil number. Vaatame korra. Seda. Ee, Kas staatus on number? Onju? Number pole siin. Stringe status. Tekst on lihtsalt siis teksti kujul. Representatsioon.
Õpetaja: Ma paneksin siit sta Ee, status
Õpetaja: üks on String teine number. Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Kui me tuleme siia sisse, vaatame seda asja nagu Headers sealt. Siin on ka näha tegelikult neid Blokke Headers.
Õpetaja: Data, Nad on tegelikult olemas.
Õpetaja: Kõik see sisu, mis siin on, on nagu nii.
Õpetaja: Me soovime Loomulikult, Data.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me saame juba seda asja teistmoodi proovida. Ma panen. Ee, selle Network I kinni.
Õpetaja: Vaatan korra. Login Views. Vaatan Log in response, mis on login Response sisu hetkel tühi. String, on nii
Õpetaja: kui mina. Nüüd panen siia mingi Aa, mida iganes. Tema saadab selle sõnumi ja Stoplight vastab talle,
Õpetaja: võibolla pean korra klikkima mujalt. Alati Ei, Refresh I siin Klikin korra ühele komponendile teisele, mis on sees.
Õpetaja: Seal on objekt väljadega user, Id ja role Name on nii,
Õpetaja: nii, Aga nüüd lähevad asjad paremaks. Aga nüüd kas vastab tõele, et siin sees on hoopis objekt Väljadega ei ole string, on nii?
Õpetaja: Aga siis siin meil ju ei tasuks ka see meie mudel. Vaata, et siin käib. String siin käib. String Siin käib String. Me tegelikult siin. Tahaks ka ära defineerida. Ja võibolla vahel ka. Võibolla soovin mingeid algväärtusi anda. Kui siin sees käib objekt, siis Niimoodi oleks Võibolla ausam öelda, siin sees on objekt,
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd, et me edaspidi saame programmeerida selle objekti ja nende väljade sisse, mis siin tegelikult sees on olemas, mis me nägime. Vaata, et siin loogiline responsi sees on.
Õpetaja: On väljad, user Id. Ja siis me tahame kasutada tegelikult seda oma Piiblit.
Õpetaja: Ma teen korra siin Refresh I, et ei ole isegi päris sõnum tulnud vaid lihtsalt mudel.
Õpetaja: Me tahame kasutada seda mudelit mida meile Backendi. Ee, niiöelda. Definitsioon ütleb, et tema hakkab tagastama Happy Path I puhul sellist objekti.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see on see koht, kus me tahame tulla. Kop Ida. See on Jason. Pange tähele. Siin on võtmetel Jutumärgid, on ju?
Õpetaja: Me tahame võtta selle asja siit nüüd hästi ettevaatlikult kogemata niimoodi koppida. Igatepidi on ju siin. Kahjuks ei ole seda nuppu ka, et copy
Õpetaja: päris vastusel Võibolla on, Kui sa teed autoga sellel Example ei ole, kui ma jooksutan seda. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kus kohas on midagi. Läksin tuksi vä.
Õpetaja: Aa, sest on valesti. Vaata, tal ei ole seda punkta upit, Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole, kellel on kopinupp. Kasutage, kellel ei ole kopinupu. Aa, siis kopeerige see tekst. Ja nüüd, mis me tahame teha, on See me tahamegi oma koodibaasi, sest et vaadake, point on see, et sa võid siia panna lihtsalt kasvõi number üks selle väärtuseks.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole Kui kõik väljad on täidetud, kui kõik sõnum saadetakse. Kui saadakse edukas vastus, siis Sten Block käivitub
Õpetaja: on kirjutatud. Kuule, anna uus sisu ülikama, Mida sa siia kirjutad? Tegelik sisu tuleb niikuinii kuskilt mujalt. Aga kui hea oleks see, kui meil oleks siin ees mudel,
Õpetaja: et mis siin sees. Tegelikult siis võib olla
Õpetaja: ma pean tulema ja kuskilt dokumentatsiooni minema ja hakkama vaatama. Kuule, mis siin sees on? Mis Siin käib? Ma Pean käivitama või tee pugima. Vaata, nagu. Noh, see ei ole kuidagi mulle abistav siin praegult. See. See ei ole kuidagi abistav,
Õpetaja: kui aga Ma tuleks siia, võtaks selle sisu.
Õpetaja: Nii põmm kopi ja tuleks Basics selle nüüd siia asemele. Või? Kustutad lihtsalt ära. Taastame niimoodi. Kontroll V.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on juba varem Jeeii nägite, mis juhtus või?
Õpetaja: Jess Mulle meeldib. See uuendus.
Õpetaja: Ta eemaldas ise automaatselt ära. Quotation. Marg Id
Õpetaja: Meil. On ju Siin jutumärgid on nii?
Õpetaja: Tema, mis ta tegi?
Õpetaja: Ta võttis need ise ära. Vanasti oli niimoodi, et ta ikkagi kuramus. Nakk pani need Siia või? No kuramusnahk. Siis ta lihtsalt tegi seda, mis ta tegi. Asi on edasi läinud. Ee, vanasti ta ei võtnud Vä Okei, vahet pole. Ma nüüd näitan, kui. Ta Kui lihtsalt saab nendest lahti.
Õpetaja: Nii, ärge kustutage. Ise Ära pange Control set või? No Vaadake, lihtsalt, järgmine kord. Teate, need on võtmed.
Õpetaja: Kui te lihtsalt nüüd selekteerite selle osa,
Õpetaja: siis siin on Niukene kollane pirn pakub erinevaid variante. Aa, saab ka seda teha. Altentriga saab alati pirne. Vahet pole, on pirn. Sul Kollane on pirn. Sul punane alt. Enter teeb lahti variandid Näete, siin on Niukene asi nagu.
Õpetaja: Kui sa vajutad seda. Ta võtab need ära Samamoodi saab tegelikult alt. Enter saab ka panna vastupidi, kui on vajadus selleks alt. Enter või lähed? Otsid selle pirni ära? Quote? Property Names tema. Peab üksiküla ka oma vaatab. Kas, ta eelistab seda on, ju
Õpetaja: nii Meie soovimegi niimoodi. Ja me ei soovi loomulikult, et siin User Id oleks päriselt väärtus. Üks See sisu tuleb niikuinii internetist. Me paneksime selle Lihtsalt nulliks, et representeerida seda, et tegemist on numbriga ja selle jätaksime tühjaks ringiks. Ja ongi kõik.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen kohe ka siis, kui te Võtate päris vägerist. Seal ei ole niukseid. Näidisväärtuseid. Niikuinii Seal ongi juba mingi null ja siin vist on ee svägeris. Lihtsalt ring,
Õpetaja: kui te võtaks Päris vägerist mitte. See, mis on. See online variant
Õpetaja: ja nüüd on hoopis teine teema
Õpetaja: Nüüd, edaspidi, kui meie soovime nüüd kasutada seda andmeid ja konkreetseid väärtusi, et meil on mudel niiöelda iseendale kui ka ees olemas, et mis siin sees on
Õpetaja: nüüd ma ei pea minema, Kui ma loen seda rida. Näiteks siit. Ahah, ee. Saada sõnum. Saan responsi. Oot, oot, Aga mis seal sees võiks olla? Nüüd Ainukene asi on see ee. Muutused on need, mis keeravad asja nahka.
Õpetaja: Ja kust tulevad tunnid, mis lähevad kuhugi auku ära.
Õpetaja: Kui te teete alguses mingisuguse Mudeli Back I endiselt. Mida üks või teine teenus tagastab. Vaata, tagastab seda infot ja nii edasi. Okei? Ja te teete juba fronti ära,
Õpetaja: Siis te peate arvestama seda, et hoiate nüüd meeles. Kui te mingil põhjusel lähete Backendi, visate näiteks see mingi välja. Te saate aru, Kurat, mul veel mingeid andmeid vaja. Vaata, seal sõnumis vastuses
Õpetaja: mingid igasugused andmed Midagi on puudu. Mingi tahaks või midagi. Midagi, mis on vaja järgmise sammu jaoks. Frondis.
Õpetaja: Kui te tulete, Kui te teete muudatusi mistahes muudatusi backendis, siis te peate hoidma meeles, et need ei ole automaatselt nende Koodiridadega. Kuidagi süngis,
Õpetaja: vaid, et te peate meeles hoidma, et te tulete. Viite siin ka need vastavused, eriti kui te muudate ja kustutate mingisuguse väljanime. See võib nii labaselt olla ka. Vaata näiteks, et user it oli seal niimoodi. Näiteks keegi avastab pugi, et. Oi, kuule, see Camel Case on kole ju
Õpetaja: tema. Te ülejäänud asjad. Me programmeerime niimoodi, et siin on User Id. Täpselt sellisel kujul.
Õpetaja: Keegi teeb äkist korda.
Õpetaja: Mingid Asjad hakkavad Frontis töötama ja see on nagu, mida leida.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: kui natukene nagu mõelda ja asju vaikselt jälgida. Küll see tuleb välja, aga See tuleb välja. Võib tähendada mingi kuradi tunde teie elust. Võibolla
Õpetaja: halvemal juhul päevi. Vaata, sa lihtsalt ei saa aru. Vaata, sest kõik klapib. Lähete Fronti, Vähemalt lähete sägerisse Proovite. Töötab, töötab. Okei? See oleks esimene asi, mida peaks tegema. Seal töötab, Okei, Selliste probleemi ei ole, kui Ilusti ei ole sisenditega kuidagi seotud. Seal võib ka veel midagi olla.
Õpetaja: Siis te peaksite tulema Fronti hakkama siit Jazzima. Seda, No kuidas te Sedazsite Te kasutate neid samu tööriistu. Oota, ma saadan mingisuguse sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Nii ma vaatan. Vaatan siit sellest inspektist. Ee, vaatan voest. Saadan sõnumi, vaatan Login View, datablokki. Login, respons.
Õpetaja: Siin on user Id.
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole. No neid kohti, on kus saab nagu üles leida. Kuskilt tulevad, mingid Errorid tal niikuinii,
Õpetaja: et nad on. Et see on asi, mida te peate meeles hoidma, on see, et need asjad ei ole süngis, need Vead tulevad tavaliselt niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Hakkad muutma, eriti kui midagi muudad ja kustutad see parem ja hiljem tuleb. Vaata, et see see juhtub, aga siis Lihtsalt tasub proovida, kuidagi meeles hoida. See, et Vaata, see on hästi lihtne. Kui sa alles tee, kirjutad ee, back end is mingit koodi ja lahendust.
Õpetaja: Ja sul ei ole veel mingi front Mingit. Tarbijat taga pole. Vaata, sa võid julgelt täiega muudatusi, aga just siis, kui sa Ise tead, et sa tegelikult hakkavad mingit ee, edaspidi tulevikus nimetama neid asju. Dto klassiid, eks?
Õpetaja: Kui sa. Hakkad mingi Tto klassi mingil põhjusel Mudima, mis on juba olemas, siis sa pead nii kui lühi hakkama mõtlema sellele ots. Vot see teenus on olemas.
Õpetaja: Seda klassi on varem kasutatud. See võib olla kuskil Frondis kasutusel. Kus kohas need kohad on? Ma pean üles otsima ja vaatama, et mis mõjud seal on, Kas See on üldse mõistlik asi mida, ma praegu teen äkki. Ma peaks ühe uue klassi tegema selle jaoks ja nii edasi et, seal on arutluskohti. Ee, päris palju.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me oleme seal maal, kus meil seal on olemas.
Õpetaja: Just nägime ka, et tulevad siia.
Õpetaja: Jah, tulevad siia. Algväärtused On sellised
Õpetaja: korra Klikin korra korra mujale ja vaatan. Näed siis, nad on tulnud siia, töötab. Number on ilusti number ja sinine tekst, on nii edasi,
Õpetaja: Okei, Vaatame, mis siis edasi peab tegema.
Õpetaja: Neli sõnum, Staatus, kakssada,
Õpetaja: Edukas päring, päring. Vaata, mis tegema peab. Vastuses saadud user Id Väärtus salvestatakse Session Storage Faili võtmega. User Id
Õpetaja: Session Storage. Mis asi see veel on? Isegi Kuulad.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult oleks Local Storage ka tegelikult väga Okei panna. Täiesti Fine Storage.
Õpetaja: Kui te teete browser I jälle lahti.
Õpetaja: Kasvõi samal See on vaatamise koht. Inspekt.
Õpetaja: Kui ma. Teen lahti Application, Ta võib tal järjest võib teile erinev olla. Ma olen tirinud endale, nii, nagu mulle meeldib. Enamvähem
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen lahti Application siis see on niukene asi nagu Storage Local Storage Extension Storage kuulnud.
Õpetaja: Kui sa lubad. Accept Ida Cook is Eid. Vaata, Noh, see on kus saab ka vähe suuremaid asju panna ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Tegemist on justkui väikeste tekstifailidega. Kus on Niukene süsteem? Võti väärtus. Ja Kõik on teksti, String,
Õpetaja: Kui mina tulen, näiteks praegult siia Local Storage I alla vaatan. Siin on juba mingisugused võtmeväärtused. On siin sees
Õpetaja: mingi First name ja last Name kasutaja. Refresh Token. No need on jäänud minu mingi.
Õpetaja: Vaata, Sest et see url. See kaheksakümmend. Kaheksakümmend üks. Ma kasutan seal sama, Ma Lükkan selle korra tühjaks. Lihtsalt niimoodi. Clear. Kõik
Õpetaja: see on lihtsalt salajane brauseris. Noh, salajane. Mitte nii aga salajane. Kõik teavad seda. See on Siis Brauseris. Selline Niukene ajutine koht, kus Brauser saab infot aa salvestada.
Õpetaja: Ja see on koht, mis on meile ka ligipääsetav.
Õpetaja: Proovime väikse mõtteharjutuse, Vaatame, ma teen näiteks siia. Lang ja panen siia. Est, mida see võiks sümboliseerida?
Õpetaja: Langes. Miks ma peaksin tahtma? Aa, lost. Kaheksakümmend kaheksakümnes või Mingi Www. Mingi aadress Mi Mingit niukest asja salvestada. Mis see võiks tähendada?
Õpetaja: See on vaike.
Õpetaja: See võiks tähendada minu keele valikut. Oletame, et Esimesel korral tulen siia. Ära määratud pole. Äkki see keel on inglise keelne.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina lähen klikin. Ei, ei, ei, soovin. Estonian vaata valikutes on, Miks mitte Onju? Eesti keeles? Tahan asju näha.
Õpetaja: Siis niukest infot hoitakse umbes sellises kohas.
Õpetaja: Kui ma edaspidi tulen. Programmiliselt saab programm, vaadata Kas Local Storage I all on olemas niuke võti nagu Lang ja siis ta vaatab seda väärtust. No kui on väärtus, kui on selline sissekanne olemas siis ta saab koheselt sättida seda, et mina näen seda lehte juba Eesti keeles
Õpetaja: või vene keeles või mis iganes keeles on toetatud.
Õpetaja: Ja see on siin Forever and Ever. Kuni keegi paneb. Näiteks mingi Claire Data. Ja teate, küll, vaata Brauserit Peaks aegajalt puhastama ka, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ta ei ole kuki. Ta on eraldi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd teen selle sama asja, aga tulen siia
Õpetaja: siia. Ma panen ka. Ma panen ka siia pulli pärast, Lang
Õpetaja: ja panen est. Ma panen mõlemad samasugused.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, mis nende kahe vahe võiks olla? Local Storage ja Sessions Storage.
Õpetaja: Mm, aga mul. Kuna mul on mitu Tab I, siis ma ei tea, kuidas see nüüd toimib, onju? Aga ma panen lihtsalt esialgu ühe kinni. Teen uue Tab I, lahti. Ma ei tea, kas teised peavad ka Kinni minema. Mitte Ma lähen selle samale aadressile
Õpetaja: Ee, meie aadressile. Teen juba parema klõpsuga inspekt lahti.
Õpetaja: Aa, vaatan. Application It. Kohe saame teada. Vaatame, Local Storage Lang On alles.
Õpetaja: Session Storage läheks kaduma.
Õpetaja: See on see vahe ja mul on siin Taaskis on kirjutatud Sessions Story S. Aga teeme meie Local Story. See tavaliselt läheks siia, mis läheb tavaliselt siia
Õpetaja: siia. Tavaliselt läheb. Aa
Õpetaja: ee. Oleneb lahendustest Security lahendusest. Täitsa vabalt võib siia minna. Okei, pikud lühid, et siia tavaliselt lähevad Niuksed asjad. Nagu
Õpetaja: sellepärast, kui sa sisse logid. No ma panen kümme näiteks siia see? Ei ole kaastamise koht praegu siia läheb näiteks Siis role.
Õpetaja: Kas te saate aru, mis see sisse läheb? Meil on vaja liikuda erinevate lehtede vahel
Õpetaja: ja meil on mitmeid erinevaid viiseid, kui sa Kui ühelt vaatelt kolid ära, siis dünaamiliselt pannakse lett. Kokku. On ju? Kui sa kolid ühelt vaatelt ära teisele vaatajale, siis selle esialgse vaate Info läheb kõik nagu. Noh, ütleme siis musta auku,
Õpetaja: aga meil on vaja kanda andmeid. Mingeid andmeid on mis meil oleks võibolla vaja kanda Kogu selle sessiooni jooksul
Õpetaja: või üldse, Nagu Kui sa sinna sisse logitud. Vahet pole, et sul on vaja võibolla neid nagu kanda,
Õpetaja: siis ee, Mingid andmed on see, mis on ainult teatud vaates vaja. Näiteks, võibolla on tähtsad. Anna mulle selle Customer I kõik orderid, aga, noh, okei, Mis on tema? Anna selle orderi. Kõik Ee, produktid. Hoopis hoopis niimoodi. No siis vist läks Order Id vaja mingeid asju. Me kanname läbi Urlide
Õpetaja: parameetritega mingeid asju. Me soovime kanda täpselt niimoodi. Ja see asi on, mis on nagu, mis on vaja. Nagu kaine nägu igal lehel. Võibolla oleks. Oleks hea, et on mugav ligipääs siis Neid asju me tahamegi kanda niisuguses kohas nagu
Õpetaja: mõte. On selge, sest et sisselogimise hetkel See vastus, mis meile tuleb, ütleb meile. Vaata, et kes sa oled.
Õpetaja: Edaspidi, kui ma tahan näiteks lisada mingi. Tahan pilte lisada mingi oma süsteem oma pildi. See on seotud minuga. See on minu kontoga seotud Andmebaasis On see niimoodi üles sätitud. See on minuga, kasutad minu user Id. Mul on vaja teada nagu kelle kelle profiili pilt see on.
Õpetaja: Et See on andmebaasi vaja salvestada, sest neid andmeid on vaja ja need sellel hetkel, kui sa sisse logid, on olemas. Aga peale seda, kui liigud edasi, Muidu nad lihtsalt kaoksid Ära
Õpetaja: nüüd. Meie ülesanne ongi see siin järgmisena paneme, siis. See on lihtsam.
Õpetaja: Ma teen selle platsi puhtaks. Siin sellest
Õpetaja: meil ongi nüüd ülesanne. Siin. Sellest taskis et
Õpetaja: vastuses Saadud user Id väärtus salvestatakse Session Storage is faili võtmega. User Id. Pange tähele. Kui me korra vaatame seda näete Key value q Value See on nagu Jason
Õpetaja: Võti väärtus. Võti, väärtus, Parameetri nimi. Sisu.
Õpetaja: Siia tuleb userreid. I. Siia tuleb Üks siia tuleb, siia tuleb, ma ei tea, admin.
Õpetaja: Ja siis edaspidi, Kui me soovime nendele andmetele ligi saada, siis läbi mille me saame,
Õpetaja: või mille me saame nendest kahest, kui Meil on vaja väärtust talle ligi saada, Nii, Ja
Õpetaja: kui me tahame väärtustele saada ligi, siis see võti on ju see mina ütlen, et Palun
Õpetaja: anna mulle see väärtus, mis on siin. Palun anna mulle väärtus. Mis on siin Noh, Läks juba kaduma.
Õpetaja: See on see missioon, aga Meie tahame nüüd teha seda loomulikult programmiliselt.
Õpetaja: Nii siis me tuleme siia kohta,
Õpetaja: kus meil hetkel see informatsioon on olemas.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt see on mistahes osa, mis on peale seda aga mõistlik on seda siin teha et, kui me selle responsi kätte saame me, paneme selle loogiline responsi elama
Õpetaja: Aga järgmine tegevus on see, et me tahame öelda nüüd Local Storage.
Õpetaja: Punkt on jälle muutuja ja objekt. Seal on õige objekt selles tehnoloogias, Mis siin. Jaoskõps on olemas? Või Brauseris?
Õpetaja: Siin on mõned meetodid. Näete kõik, millel on M on juures. Nad. On meetodid,
Õpetaja: mis meetod meile Praegu peaks, võiks huvi pakkuda Okei,
Õpetaja: aga Ghee on see, et sina anna indeks. Tema annab stringi vastu. Näed, sisend on, see, et anna Indeks numbri. Kujuta ennast ringi.
Õpetaja: Ei, see ei huvita mis see Claire võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Local Storage. Claire kustutab kõike ära. Vist ei ole päris, See, mis me tahame.
Õpetaja: Jaa, Vaata kui raketa aitab. Mis see ütleb? Tema ootab sisse. Ee, võtit vihjega. String,
Õpetaja: Ta vist. Annab meile siis Selle väärtuse on ju Vait on? Mida see võiks teha? Ghee saab sisse võtta.
Õpetaja: Ta lihtsalt anna mingi konkreetne võti. Näiteks Lang, või mida Iganes kustutab, ära,
Õpetaja: Näed, sellel. Vaata, siin on see, et kaks pool. Vaata, et me vaatame vasakut poolt, et ta sulgudes sees näitab, Mida Ta sisse ootab paremal pool. Ta näitab, mida ta tagastab. Ja kui mingi asi teeb midagi, lihtsalt aga ei tagasta, siis ta on void, on? Ju Ta tagastab tühjust
Õpetaja: Nüüd set item. Tema ütleb, et Key String ja Value String.
Õpetaja: Noh, see. Vist
Õpetaja: Paneme looked Story sisse, lihtsam on toimetada session. Kõik kohe kaotab Ära kui paned, tab I kinni.
Õpetaja: Ee, sest kui ma nüüd klassiprojekti tegin, ka siis Ee seal pigem Ma õppisin need. See on see koht, kuhu panna. Aga Siis ongi see, et sa pead arvestama sellega, et niipea kui kasutaja paneb, kinni, Vaata siis, Tema jaoks on sessioon läinud.
Õpetaja: Aga kui tahaks päris lahendusega teha, siis tegelikult päris nii ei tahaks. Et paned tab I kinni, on kõik
Õpetaja: pastavat soovile ja disainile erinevust. Sa tead, sealt kaob ise ära.
Õpetaja: Okei, nüüd, Local Story D. Saime aru, et see set item võiks sobida Jällegi, Control B juhendab meid. Vaata, onju, et mis parameetreid ootab. No mis ma siia sisse peaksin kirjutama? Ütleme, et ee, meie Plaan on siis teha sellest actionist? Ära praegult see osa siin
Õpetaja: võtmega User Id.
Õpetaja: Mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Millest alustame, Kuidas ei ole siis
Õpetaja: Ja ta ootab sisse Stringi võtme. Me mõtleme ise välja.
Õpetaja: Mitte ise. Vaid Taaskis on öeldud user. Id.
Õpetaja: Mida sa nüüd siia kirjutan? Palun Aidake mind, ma olen uus arendaja.
Õpetaja: Oma. Vot siia. Nüüd hakkame mõtlema, et kus see väärtus meil on?
Õpetaja: Vot sellepärast ongi mõnus, et kogu See internetist sise tulev asi läks meil kus on ka mudel, mis ütleb, et mis väljad siin sees on?
Õpetaja: See peate alati meeles muidugi hoidma. Te võite kirjutada mida Iganes,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes te võite kirjutada, mida iganes lõppkokkuvõttes mis info siin sees on ja mis väljad on, See, mis tuleb. Aa, ist, on ju? Seda ei tohi ära unustada, Aga see on ju mudel
Õpetaja: Noh, siin. Ma nüüd tahan öelda, et Mis ma nüüd kirjutan siia,
Õpetaja: kas vastab tõele, et nagu selle hetkega? Kui respons tuleb, siis selle objekti sees on kõik andmed olemas kaasa arvatud user Id.
Õpetaja: Me ütleme, et ei hakka Isse panema võtmega user Id. Ja nüüd on meil seda väärtust ennast vaja kätte saada, kus Me saame selle väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Kus on see info? No, natuke täpsemalt. Ei, no ma hakkan kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, this punkt.
Õpetaja: Login response ja vaadake, mis Nüüd juhtub nüüd, kus see mudel on? Üleval olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Nüüd ta teab, et siin sees on väli user Id.
Õpetaja: Ma tee hetke nii Nagu ma nüüd tegin, Vaata, on ju Aga ma. Nüüd näitan seda alternatiivi. Kui meil seda mudelit ei oleks.
Õpetaja: Ma saaksin selle võtta tegelikult ka ju vaband. Response punkt data on ju kogu Response datablokk. Nagu
Õpetaja: et kui ma võtaksin selle asja ja paneksin siia, see on kogu Jason
Õpetaja: hetkel idee järgi Kui meil ei oleks sellist lahendust,
Õpetaja: Kui meil ei oleks sellist lahendust, meil on mudel olemas. Siis siin ma saaksin ise ka kirjutada, et ei võta responsist kogu responsist. Võta sealt data, blokk. Noh, see on meil põhimõtteliselt, et. Hei, võta. See.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd, Kui ma kirjutaksin siia punkti otsa Punkt user, id korra korras. Selle kustutan ära.
Õpetaja: Vot siis see kood näks välja. Niukene,
Õpetaja: et et, no Sa kirjutasid midagi, aga ma. Ei. Ma ei tea, kas seal on või ei ole.
Õpetaja: Kui meil on olemas see mudel ees, Me saame normaalselt programmeerida ja toimetada, ilma, et me teeksime kuskil mingeid eksimusi. Sest et siia juba mingit pläusti kirjutada, ikka on ikka päris suur, kunst,
Õpetaja: Kui ta pakub ainult kahte mingisugust ee. Välja nime ja me paneme siia. Hei,
Õpetaja: no mis asi see on? Hei, juba joonib alla ja Ütleb, et kuule,
Õpetaja: miks. Muutujat pole olemas. Nagu see väldib meil vigade tegemist. Meid. See tagab meile parema loetavuse. Me näeme, mis toimub, Mis Peab olema,
Õpetaja: et iga kord See on jällegi see, et see. Kogu see asja. Me paneme kokku sellest piiblist.
Õpetaja: See räägib meile. Loo. Saada Kett, sõnum. Pane niisugune Orl. No nüüd peab see apiga asja juurde tulema. Anna niuksed, sisendid. Parand Username username String. Väärtus, Väärtus respons, tuleb Selline põmm. Pane see endale sinna Databloki mudelisse maha ongi? Nüüd hakkaks see sõna mudel ka olema. Miks ta seal kutsume? Mudeliks,
Õpetaja: Sest et See representeerib meile seda, et missugused andmed meil siin tegelikult kasutusel on?
Õpetaja: Sa saad anda vaikeväärtused ka ja nii edasi, onju? Aga siin siin Annad vaikeväärtuse? Vaikeväärtuse? Väike väärtuse Siin sa kannad. Annad ka väike väärtuse koos mingi sisuga. Aga see oma tegeliku sisuga saab niikuinii lõpuks peale Seda login responsi niiöelda peale logimist
Õpetaja: oma tegelikku sisu see siia. Sa võid kirjutada, mis iganes sa tahad. Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: tegeliku sisu, ta saab selle rea pealt.
Õpetaja: Ja meie ülesanne on loomulikult hoida neid asju. Ee, niimoodi. Aga see aitab. Meil vältida vigu, sest et see mudel on nüüd ees olemas. Samamoodi kui ma tahaksin siin üleval mingi, Võtan mingi suvalise asja ka ära. Ma lihtsalt korra teen siia. Mingi, Ma ei Tea input i
Õpetaja: imp.
Õpetaja: No mida Iganes. Aa type shop, et see tekst
Õpetaja: Näed, kui mina tahaksin siin veemodeliga kasutada, vaata veemodel ja ütleks,
Õpetaja: Aga ma tahaksin siit ühte välja. Näiteks ma ei tea mingid user Id või midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Siis Kui ma panen punkti, siis ta pakub Sealt mudeli järgi. Ainult neid. Propse. Vaata. Ee. Mis seal selles objektis sees on? Ma ei saa vigu teha.
Õpetaja: Me. Sa ühe korra pead Ainult ühes kohas Pead ettevaatlik olema ja. Ja saama selle asja täpselt kirja. Nii, nagu on edaspidi. Kui ma progen, siis mul on sellisteks Visuaalselt see kood ees.
Õpetaja: Ja ma. Ei tee vigu.
Õpetaja: Noh, kontrolliks sa siit muidugi minema.
Õpetaja: No ja nüüd on põhimõtteliselt on vaja teha samasugune asi, aga ka selle
Õpetaja: rollname on vaja salvestada niisuguse võtmega. Ära
Õpetaja: No mis me siin siis Mis me siin teeme, et seda, asja kiirelt teha.
Õpetaja: Control D.
Õpetaja: Siia tuleb all name siit. Kas kui kontrollpühik peaks pakkuma? Vaata neid variante.
Õpetaja: Noh, oleks saanud ka copida lihtsalt võtnud selle siit niimoodi klõps Ja teinud. Siia klõps.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd saab proovida. Aa, sellepärast, et ma lähen siia sellesse. Viite appi, Teen siit refresh I
Õpetaja: Ei ole mul, mida vaatan. Local Storyt. Noh, siin on mingi voe asjad, mis ta automaatselt panevad. See mind üldse Ei, huvita.
Õpetaja: Kui mina Tulen nüüd siit loo kinni.
Õpetaja: Panen siia mingi. Aa, Pbb. Mida iganes, Nii pea kui ma aitan, login Ma võibolla pean klikkima kuskile mujale, Ma ei teeks ta reaalajas. Ugeneb,
Õpetaja: Tulid, tulid siia.
Õpetaja: No ei usu, ma kustutan ära. Ma panen selle sama sõnum uuesti teele. Tuled,
Õpetaja: nüüd, on. Nüüd me võime login lehelt minna, ära, kui me tahame. Nüüd on meil see võimalus.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et me oleme salvestanud ära selle informatsiooni, Mis meil vaja oli?
Õpetaja: Edaspidi meil läheb seda vaja
Õpetaja: kõikides teie süsteemides minimaalselt on Vaja ikkagi, teada kes sa oled, Või noh, klassikaliselt ikkagi Süsteemides on vähemalt kaks rolli. Üks on admin ja teine on nagu. Kas siis mingi klient? Customer või mis iganes vahet pole, mõnes siis Ka mitu rolli
Õpetaja: olenevalt? Mis äri äriplaani te seal teete, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ma panen isegi see koodi mõttes täna midagi enam juurde ei jõua teha. Ma panen ühe. Ja. Push.
Õpetaja: Aa. Tehke siis tee ka homseks, nagu Kes tahavad järgi tulla. Tehke see kodus ära.
Õpetaja: Tulge järgi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Jah, võin, ee. Mis on nagu siis tähtis meeles hoida
Õpetaja: homseks, et ma mäletaks. Kas te näete kogu seda siin
Õpetaja: homme? Me teeme selle asja põhimõtteliselt uuesti,
Õpetaja: aga me teeme niimoodi. Ee, et, ee. Just. Me saaksime siin. Teha asju juppideks. Kogu see osa tegelikult on üks tegevus
Õpetaja: See selle asja nimi. Võiks Koondmütsina võtta niimoodi häguselt kokku.
Õpetaja: Siin on mitmeid tegevusi. Me ei hakkaks nagu panema meetodi imeks, et mingi Save Ee, ma ei tea. Mingi teisele vaatele. Niimoodi ei teeks seal sees. Ma jätaks lihtsalt nagu et login.
Õpetaja: Meil on siin sõnumi saatmine, mis saab olema eraldi meetod.
Õpetaja: Ee, meil saab olema andalog in error.
Õpetaja: Saad aru?
Õpetaja: Me teeme selle asja niimoodi, et see on nagu söödav ka,
Õpetaja: Et, ee, mida me ei taha, on see, et me tuleme siia vaatesse ja meil puudub niukene. Kena Nice Overview, et kuidas see login töötab. Me tahame tulla siia sisse ja lugeda sisse. Logime.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis on Aa send? Ee, Inrek Quest
Õpetaja: Siis Seal all oleks teinud ee. Oleks Handel. Ee, error, respons. Kõik ta on
Õpetaja: ja rohkem ei ole. Mitte midagi. Ja midagi midagi huvitab. Siis lähed jälle. Uurid Ja Vaatad, Davai. Ee, kuidas tänane päev tundus?
Õpetaja: Täna oli raskem. Juba. Jah, kiire.